part four The Mystery of the myths
Section 1 a species with amnesia
chapter 24
Echoes of our dreams
in some of the most powerful and
enduring myths that we have inherited
from ancient times our species seems to
have retained a confused but resonant
memory of a terrifying Global
catastrophe
where do these myths come from why
though they derive from unrelated
cultures are there story lines so
similar why are they Laden with common
symbolism and why do they so often share
the same stock characters and plots
if they are indeed memories why are
there no historical records of the
planetary disaster they seem to refer to
could it be that the myths themselves
are historical records could it be that
these cunning and Immortal stories
composed by Anonymous Geniuses where the
medium used to record such information
and pass it on in the time before
history began
and the Ark went upon the face of the
waters
there was a king in ancient Sumer who
sought eternal life his name was
Gilgamesh
we know of his exploits because the
myths and traditions of Mesopotamia
inscribed in cuneiform script upon
tablets of baked clay have survived many
thousands of these tablets some dating
back to the beginning of the third
millennium BC have been excavated from
the Sands of modern Iraq they transmit a
unique picture of a vanished culture and
remind us that even in those days of
lofty Antiquity human beings preserved
memories of times still more remote
times from which they were separated by
the interval of a great and terrible
deluge
I will Proclaim to the world the Deeds
of Gilgamesh this was the man to whom
all things were known this was the king
who knew the countries of the world he
was wise he saw Mysteries and new secret
things he brought us a tale of the days
before the flood he went on a long
journey was weary worn out with labor
returning he rested he engraved on a
stone the whole story
the story that Gilgamesh brought back
had been told to him by a certain
utnapistim a king who had ruled
thousands of years earlier who had
survived the great flood and who had
been rewarded with the gift of
immortality because he had preserved the
seeds of humanity and of all living
things
it was long long ago said udnapished him
when the Gods dwelt on Earth Anu lord of
the firmament enlil the enforcer of
divine decisions Ishtar goddess of war
and sexual love and Aya lord of the
waters man's natural friend and
protector in those days the world teamed
the people multiplied the world bellowed
like a wild bull and the great God was
aroused by the clamor and Lille heard
the clamor and he said to the Gods in
Council the Uproar of mankind is
intolerable and sleep is no longer
possible by reason of the Babel so the
gods agreed to exterminate mankind
Aya however took pity on utnapished him
speaking through the read wall of the
King's house he told him of the imminent
catastrophe and instructed him to build
a boat in which he and his family could
survive
tear down your house and build a boat
abandon possessions and look for Life
despise worldly goods and save your soul
tear down your house I say and build a
boat with her dimensions in proportion
her width and length in harmony put
aboard the seed of all living things
into the boat
in the nick of time would napished him
built the boat as ordered I loaded into
her all that I had he said loaded her
with the seed of all living things I put
on board all my kiss and kin put on
board cattle wild beasts from Open
Country all kinds of Craftsmen the time
was fulfilled when the first light of
dawn appeared a black cloud came up from
the base of the sky it thundered within
where adad lord of the storm was riding
a stupor of Despair went up to heaven
when the god of the storm turned
daylight to darkness when he smashed the
land like a cup
on the first day The Tempest blew
swiftly and brought the flood no man
could see his fellow nor could the
people be distinguished from the sky
even the gods were afraid of the flood
they withdrew they went up to the heaven
of Anu and crouched in the outskirts the
Gods cowered like curse while Ishtar
cried shrieking aloud have I given birth
unto these mine own people only to glut
with their bodies the sea as though they
were fish
meanwhile continue to publish them for
six days and nights the wind blew
torrent and Tempest and flood
overwhelmed the world Tempest and flood
raged together like warring hosts when
the seventh day dawned the storm from
the south subsided the sea Rue calm the
flood was stilled I looked at the face
of the world and there was silence
surface of the sea stretched as flat as
a rooftop
all mankind had returned to Clay
I opened a hatch and light fell on my
face then I bowed low I sat down and I
wept the tears streamed down my face for
on every side was the waste of water
protein leaks distant there appeared a
mountain and there the boat grounded on
the mountain of nizir the boat held fast
she held fast and did not budge when the
seventh day dawned I loosed a dove and
let her go she flew away but finding no
resting place she returned then I lose
the swallow and she flew away but
finding no resting place she returned I
loosed a raven she saw that the waters
had retreated she ate she flew around
she called and she did not come back
knew that it was now safe to disembark I
poured out a libation on the Mountaintop
I heaped up wood and cane and Cedar and
Myrtle when the gods smelled the sweet
Savor they gathered like flies over the
sacrifice
these texts are not by any means the
only ones to come down to us from the
ancient land of Sumer
in other tablets some almost five
thousand years old others less than
three thousand years old the Noah figure
of utnapistim is known variously as the
sudra
or atrahasis
even so he is always instantly
recognizable as the same patriarchal
character poor warned by the same
merciful god who writes out the same
Universal flood in the same stormtos
dark and whose descendants repopulate
the world
there are many obvious resemblances
between the Mesopotamian flood myth and
the famous biblical story of Noah and
the deluge
Scholars argue endlessly about the
nature of these resemblances what really
matters however is that in each sphere
of influence the same solemn tradition
has been preserved for posterity a
tradition which tells in graphic
language of a global catastrophe and of
the near total annihilation of mankind
Central America
The Identical message was preserved in
the valley of Mexico far away across the
world from Mount Ararat and nisu
there culturally and geographically
isolated from judeo-christian influences
long ages before the arrival of the
Spaniards stories were told of a great
Deluge as The Listener will recall from
part three it was believed that this
Deluge had swept over the entire Earth
at the end of the fourth Sun destruction
came in the form of torrential rain and
floods the mountains disappeared and men
were transformed into fish
according to Aztec mythology
only two human beings survived a man
Kush kushly and his wife Joshi quetzel
who had been forewarned of the cataclysm
by a god
they escaped in a huge boat that they
had been instructed to build and came to
ground on the peak of a tall mountain
there they descended and afterwards had
many children who were dumb until the
time when a dove on top of a tree gave
them the gift of languages these
languages differed so much that the
children could not understand one
another
a related Central American tradition
that of the mecca kanasex is in even
more striking Conformity with the story
as we have it in Genesis and in the
Mesopotamian sources according to this
tradition the god tez katilpoka
determined to destroy all mankind with a
flood
saving only a certain tespie who
embarked in a spacious vessel with his
wife his children and large numbers of
animals and birds as well as supplies of
grains and seeds the preservation of
which were essential to the Future
subsistence of the human race
The Vessel came to rest on an exposed
Mountaintop after Tess cattle poker had
decreed that the Waters of the flood
should retire wishing to find out
whether it was now safe for him to
disembark tesbe sent out a vulture which
feeding on the carcasses with which the
Earth was now strewn did not return the
man then sent out other birds of which
only the hummingbird came back with a
leafy branch in its beak with this sign
that the land had begun to renew itself
tezp and his family went forth from
their Ark multiplied and repopulated the
Earth
memories of a terrible flood resulting
from Divine displeasure are also
preserved in the purple vu according to
this archaic text the great God decided
to create Humanity soon after the
beginning of time it was an experiment
and he began it with figures made of
wood that looked like man and talk like
man these creatures fell out of favor
because they did not remember their
creator and so a flood was brought about
by The Heart Of Heaven a great flood was
formed which fell on the heads of the
wooden creatures a heavy resin fell from
the sky the face of the Earth was
darkened and a Black Rain began to Fall
by day and By Night the wooden Figures
were annihilated destroyed broken up and
killed
not everyone perished however
like the Aztecs and the mecca Akana sex
the Maya of the Yucatan and Guatemala
believed that a Noah figure and his wife
the great father and the great mother
had survived the flood to populate the
land Anew thus becoming the ancestors of
all subsequent generations of humanity
South America
moving to South America we encounter the
chipkalves of central Colombia according
to their myths they had originally lived
as Savages without laws agriculture or
religion then one day there appeared
among them an old man of A different
race he wore a thick long beard and his
name was bochika he taught the chipkas
how to build huts and live together in
society
his wife who was very beautiful and
named Chia appeared after him but she
was wicked and enjoyed thwarting her
husband's altruistic efforts
since she could not overcome his power
directly she used magical means to cause
a great flood in which the majority of
the population died but Chico was very
angry and exiled cheer from the Earth to
the sky where she became the moon given
the task of lighting the nights he also
caused the Waters of the flood to
dissipate and brought down the few
survivors from the mountains where they
had taken Refuge thereafter he gave them
laws taught them to cultivate the land
and instituted the worship of the sun
with periodic festivals sacrifices and
pilgrimages he then divided the power to
govern among Two Chiefs and spent the
remainder of his days on Earth living in
quiet contemplation as an ascetic when
he ascended to Heaven he became a god
father South still the canarians an
Indian tribe of Ecuador relate an
ancient story of a flood from which two
brothers escaped by going to the top of
a high mountain as the water Rose the
mountain grew higher so that the two
brothers survived the disaster
when they were discovered the tupinamba
Indians of Brazil venerated a series of
civilizing or Creator Heroes
the first of these Heroes was Monon
ancient old who was said to have been
the creator of mankind but who then
destroyed the world with flood and Fire
Peru as we heard in part two is
particularly rich in flood Legends a
typical story tells of an Indian who was
warned by a llama of a deluge together
the man and the Llama fled to a high
mountain called vilka Koto when they
reached the top of the mountain they saw
that all kinds of birds and animals had
already taken Refuge there
sea began to rise and covered all the
Plains and mountains except the top of
vilkokoto and even there the waves
dashed up so high that the animals were
forced to crowd into a narrow area five
days later the water aired and the Sea
returned to its bed but all human beings
except one were drowned and from him are
descended all the nations on Earth
the arcanians of pre-columbian Chile
preserved a tradition that there was
once a flood which very few Indians
escaped the survivors took refuge on a
high mountain called Peg the Thundering
or the glittering which had three Peaks
and the ability to float on water
in the far south of the continent a
yamana legend from Tierra del Fuego
States the moon woman caused the flood
this was at the time of the great
upheaval moon was filled with hatred
towards human beings at that time
everybody drowned with the exception of
those few who were able to escape to the
five mountain peaks that the water did
not cover
another Tierra del fuegen tribe the
pahunch way
associate the flood with a prolonged
period of Darkness the Sun and the Moon
fell from the sky and the world stayed
that way without light until finally two
giant Condors carried both the Sun and
the Moon back up to the sky
North America
meanwhile at the other end of the
Americas among the Inuit of Alaska there
existed a tradition of a terrible flood
accompanied by an earthquake which swept
so rapidly over the face of the Earth
that only a few people managed to escape
in their canoes or take refuge on the
tops of the highest mountains petrified
with Terror
the luisano of lower California had a
legend that a flood covered the
mountains and destroyed most of mankind
only a few were saved because they fled
to the highest peaks which were spared
when all the rest of the world was
inundated the survivors remained there
until the flood ended
farther north similar flood myths were
recorded amongst the hurons and a legend
of the Montagne belonging to the
Algonquin family related how muchabo or
the great hair re-established the World
After the flood with the help of a raven
an otter and a muskrat
Lin's history of The Dakotas an
authoritative work of the 19th century
which preserved many indigenous
Traditions that would otherwise have
been lost reports in Iroquois myth that
the sea and Waters had at one time
infringed upon the land so that all
human life was destroyed the chickasaws
asserted that the world had been
destroyed by water but that one family
was saved and two animals of every kind
Sue also spoke of a time when there was
no dry land and when all men disappeared
from existence
water water everywhere
how far and how widely across the myth
memories of mankind do the ripples of
the great flood spread
very widely indeed
more than 500 Deluge Legends are known
around the world and in a survey of 86
of these 20 Asiatic three European seven
African 46 American and 10 from
Australia and the Pacific The Specialist
researcher Dr Richard Andre concluded
that 62 were entirely independent of the
Mesopotamian and Hebrew accounts for
example early Jesuit Scholars who were
among the first Europeans to visit China
had the opportunity in the Imperial
library to study a vast work consisting
of 4 320 volumes said to have been
handed down from ancient times and to
contain all knowledge this great book
included a number of traditions which
told of the consequences that followed
when mankind rebelled against the high
gods and the system of the universe fell
into disorder planets altered their
courses the sky sank lower towards the
north the sun moon and stars changed
their motions the Earth fell to pieces
and the waters in its bosom rushed
upwards with violence and overflowed the
Earth
in the Malaysian tropical forest the
chewang people believe that every so
often their own world which they call
Earth seven Turns Upside down so that
everything is flooded and destroyed
however through the agency of the
Creator God tohan the flat new surface
of what had previously been the
underside of Earth 7 is molded into
mountains valleys and plains new trees
are planted and new humans born
flood myth of Laos and Northern Thailand
has it that beings called the thins
lived in the upper Kingdom long ages ago
while the masters of the lower world
were three great men pulang Swang Kun
Khan and kunket one day the thens
announced that before eating any meal
people should give them a part of their
food as a sign of respect the people
refused and in a rage the thins created
a flood which devastated the whole earth
the three great men built a raft on top
of which they made a small house and
embarked with a number of women and
children in this way they and their
descendants survived the deluge
in similar fashion the Karens of Burma
have traditions of a global Deluge from
which two brothers were saved on Iraq
such a deluge is also part of the
mythology of Vietnam where a brother and
sister are said to have survived in a
great wooden chest which also contained
two of every kind of animal
several Aboriginal Australian peoples
especially those whose traditional
homelands are along the tropical
northern coast ascribe their Origins to
a great flood which Swept Away the
previous landscape and Society
meanwhile in the origin myths of a
number of other tribes the cosmic
serpent your longer associated with the
rainbow is held responsible for the
deluge there are Japanese Traditions
According to which the Pacific Islands
of Oceania were formed after the Waters
of a great Deluge had receded in Oceania
itself a myth of the Native inhabitants
of Hawaii tells how the world was
destroyed by a flood and later recreated
by a god named tangaloa the Samoans
believed that there was once an
inundation that wiped out almost all
mankind it was survived only by two
human beings who put to Sea in a boat
which eventually came to rest in the
Samoan archipelago
Greece India and Egypt
on the other side of the world Greek
mythology 2 is haunted by memories of a
deluge here however as in Central
America the inundation is not viewed as
an isolated event but as one of a series
of destructions and remakings of the
world
the Aztecs and the Maya spoke in terms
of successive Sons or epochs of which
our own was thought to be the fifth and
last in similar fashion the oral
traditions of ancient Greece collected
and sat down in writing by hessiod in
the 8th Century BC related that prior to
the present creation there had been four
earlier races of men on Earth each of
these was thought more advanced than the
one that followed it and each at the
appointed hour had been swallowed up in
a geological cataclysm
the first and most ancient creation had
been Mankind's golden race who had lived
like the gods free from care without
trouble or woe with ageless limbs they
reveled at their Banquets when they died
it was as men overcome by sleep
with the passing of time and at the
command of Zeus this golden race
eventually sank into the depths of the
earth it was succeeded by the silver
race which was supplanted by the bronze
race which was replaced by the race of
Heroes which was followed by the iron
race our own the fifth and most recent
creation
it is the fate of the bronze race that
is of particular interest to us here
described in the myths as having the
strength of Giants and mighty hands on
their Mighty limbs these formidable men
were exterminated by Zeus King of the
Gods as a punishment for the misdeeds of
Prometheus the rebellious Titan who had
presented Humanity with the gift of fire
the mechanism the vengeful deity used to
sweep the earth clean was an
overwhelming flood
in the most widespread version of the
story Prometheus impregnated a human
female
she bore him a son named juquelion who
ruled over the country of fithia in
thessaly and took to wife PIRA the red
blonde daughter of Epimetheus and
Pandora when Zeus reached his fateful
decision to destroy the bronze race
ducalian forewarned by Prometheus made a
wooden box stored in it all that was
necessary and climbed into it with Pera
the king of the Gods caused Mighty
Reigns to pour from Heaven flooding the
greater part of the Earth all mankind
perished in this Deluge save a few who
had fled to the highest mountains it
also happened at this time that the
mountains of thessaly were split asunder
and the whole country as far as the
Isthmus and the peloponnese became a
single sheet of water
to kayleon and PIRA floated over this
sea in their box for nine days and
nights finally landing on Mount
Parnassus
there after the rains had ceased they
disembarked and sacrificed to the Gods
in response Zeus sent Hermes to ducalion
with permission to ask for whatever he
wished he wished were human beings Zeus
then bathed him take stones and throw
them over his shoulder the stones
duecalion through became men and those
that pirate through became women
as the Hebrews looked back on Noah so
the Greeks of ancient historical times
looked back upon jocelon as the ancestor
of their nation and as the founder of
numerous towns and temples
a similar figure was revered in Vedic
India more than three thousand years ago
one day The Story Goes when a certain
wise man named Manu was making his
ablutions he found in the hollow of his
hand a tiny little fish which begged him
to allow it to live
taking pity on it he put it in a jar the
next day however it had grown so much
bigger that he had to carry it to a lake
soon the lake was too small throw me
into the sea said the fish which was in
reality a manifestation of the god
Vishnu and I shall be more comfortable
then he warned Manu of a coming Deluge
he sent him a large ship with orders to
load it with two of every living species
and the seeds of every plant and then to
go on board himself
Manu had only just carried out these
orders when the Ocean Rose and submerged
everything and nothing was to be seen
But Vishnu in his fish form now a huge
one-horned creature with golden scales
Manu moored his ark to the Horn of the
fish and Vishnu towed it across the
brimming Waters until it came to rest on
the exposed peak of the mountain of the
north the fish said I have saved thee
fastened The Vessel to a tree that the
water may not sweep it away while thou
art on the mountain and in proportion as
the waters decrease Thou shalt descend
Manu descended with the waters the
Deluge had carried away all creatures
and Manu remained alone
with him and with the animals and plants
he had saved from destruction began a
new age of the world after a year there
emerged from the Waters of women who
announced herself as the daughter of
Malu the couple married and produced
children thus becoming the ancestors of
the present race of mankind
last but by no means least ancient
Egyptian Traditions also refer to a
great flood
a funerary text discovered in the Tomb
of pharaoh seti the first for example
tells of the destruction of sinful
Humanity by a deluge the reasons for
this catastrophe are set out in chapter
175 of the Book of the Dead which
attributes the following speech to the
Moon God both
they have fought fights they have upheld
Strife they have done evil they have
created hostilities they have made
Slaughter they have caused trouble and
oppression therefore I am going to blot
out everything which I have made this
Earth shall enter into the watery Abyss
by means of a raging flood and will
become even as it was in primeval time
on the trail of a mystery
with the words of Thoth we have come
full circle to the Sumerian and biblical
floods the Earth was filled with
violence says Genesis and God looked
upon the Earth and behold it was corrupt
for All Flesh had corrupted his way upon
the Earth
and God said unto Noah the end of All
Flesh has come before me for the Earth
is filled with violence through them and
behold I will destroy them with the
Earth
like the flood of juquelion the flood of
Manu and the flood that destroyed the
Aztec's fourth Sun the biblical Deluge
was the end of a world age a new age
succeeded it our own populated by the
descendants of Noah from the very
beginning however it was understood that
this age too would in due course come to
a catastrophic end
as the old song puts it God gave Noah
the rainbow sign no more water the fire
next time
the scriptural source for this prophecy
of world destruction is to be found in 2
Peter 3.
we must be careful to remember that
during the last days there are bound to
be people who will be scornful and who
will say everything goes on as it has
since it began at the creation
they are choosing to forget that there
were Heavens at the beginning and that
the earth was formed by the word of God
out of water and between the waters so
that the world of that time was
destroyed by being flooded by water
but by the same word the present sky and
Earth are destined for fire and are only
being reserved until Judgment Day so
that all Sinners may be destroyed the
day of the Lord will come as a thief in
the night and then with a roar the sky
will vanish the elements will catch fire
and fall apart and the Earth and all
that it contains will be burnt up
the Bible therefore envisages two ages
of the world our own being the second
and last elsewhere in other cultures
different numbers of creations and
destructions are recorded in China for
instance the perished ages are called
kiss 10 of which are said to have
elapsed from the beginning of time until
Confucius at the end of each kiss in a
general convulsion of nature the sea is
carried out of its bed mountains spring
up out of the ground Rivers change their
course human beings and everything are
ruined and the ancient traces are faced
Buddhist scriptures speak of seven sons
each brought to an end by water fire or
wind
at the end of the Seventh Son the
current world cycle it is expected that
the Earth will break into flames
Aboriginal traditions of Sarawak and
Saba recall that the sky was once low
and tell us that six Sons perished at
present the world is illuminated by the
Seventh Son similarly the sibiline books
speak of nine sons that are nine ages
and prophesied two ages Yet to Come
Those of the eighth and the ninth Sun
on the other side of the Atlantic Ocean
the Hopi Indians of Arizona who are
distant relatives of the Aztecs
recorded three previous Sons each
culminating in a great Annihilation
followed by the gradual re-emergence of
mankind
in Aztec cosmology of course there were
four Sons prior to our own
such minor differences concerning the
precise number of destructions and
Creations envisaged in this or that
mythology should not distract us from
the remarkable convergence of ancient
Traditions evident here all over the
world these Traditions appear to
commemorate a widespread series of
catastrophes in many cases the character
of each successive cataclysm is obscured
by the use of poetic language and the
piling up of metaphor and symbols quite
frequently also at least two different
kinds of disaster may be portrayed as
having occurred simultaneously most
frequently floods and earthquakes but
sometimes fire and a terrifying Darkness
all this contributes to the creation of
a confused and jumbled picture the myths
of the Hopi however stand out for their
straightforwardness and simplicity what
they tell us is this
the first world was destroyed as a
punishment for human misdemeanors by an
all-consuming fire that came from above
and below
the second world ended when the
terrestrial Globe toppled from its axis
and everything was covered with ice
third world ended in a universal flood
the present world is the fourth its fate
will depend on whether or not its
inhabitants behave in accordance with
the Creator's plans
we are on the trail of a mystery here
and while we may never hope to Fathom
the plans of the Creator we should be
able to reach a judgment concerning the
riddle of our converging myths of global
destruction through these myths the
voices of the Ancients speak to us
directly what are they trying to say
chapter 25 the many masks of the
Apocalypse
like the Hopi Indians of North America
the avestikarians of pre-islamic Iran
believed that there were three epochs of
creation prior to our own in the first
ebook men were pure and sinless tall and
long-lived but at its close the evil one
declared war against ahura Mazda the
holy God and the tumultuous cataclysm
ensued
during the second Epoch the evil one was
unsuccessful
in the third good and evil were exactly
balanced in the fourth evil the present
age of the world evil triumphed at the
outset and has maintained its Supremacy
ever since
the end of the fourth epoch is predicted
soon
but it is the cataclysm at the end of
the first Epoch that interests us here
it is not a flood and yet it converges
in so many ways with many Global flood
Traditions that some connection is
strongly suggested
the avestic scriptures take us back to a
time of paradise on Earth when the
remote ancestors of the ancient Iranian
people lived in the fabled iriana
Vallejo the first good and happy
creation of ahura Mazda that flourished
in the first age of the world the
mythical birthplace and original home of
the Aryan race
in those days Ariana Vallejo enjoyed a
mild and productive climate with seven
months of Summer and five of winter rich
in wildlife and in crops its Meadows
flowing with streams this Garden of
delights was converted into an
uninhabitable Wasteland of 10 months
winter and only two months summer as a
result of the onslaught of angromainu
the evil one
the first of the good lands and
countries which I Uhura Mazda created
was Ariana Vallejo then angra minu who
is full of death created an opposition
to the same a mighty Serpent and snow 10
months of winter are there now two
months of Summer and these are cold as
to the water cold as to the Earth cold
as to the trees there all around Falls
deep snow that is the diarist of plagues
The Listener will agree that a sudden
and drastic change in the climate of
Ariana Vallejo is indicated the avestic
scriptures leave us in no doubt about
this earlier they describe a meeting of
the celestial Gods called by ahura Mazda
and tell us that the fair yima the Good
Shepherd of high Renown in the Ariana
Vallejo attended this meeting with all
his excellent Mortals
it is at this point that the strange
parallels with the traditions of the
biblical flood begin to crop up for
ahura Mazda takes advantage of the
meeting to warn yima of what is about to
happen as a result of the powers of the
evil one
and ahura Mazda spake unto yima saying
yemad Affair upon the material world a
fatal winter is about to descend that
shall bring a vehement destroying Frost
upon the corporeal world will the evil
of winter come wherefore snow will fall
in great abundance
and all three sorts of beasts Shall
Perish those that live in the wilderness
and those that live on the tops of the
mountains and those that live in the
depths of The Valleys under the shelter
of stables therefore make the avar a
hypogeum or underground enclosure the
length of a riding ground to all four
corners there they bring thou the
representatives of every kind of Beast
Great and Small of the cattle of the
beasts of burden and of men of dogs of
birds and of the red burning fire
Thou shalt thou make water flow Thou
shalt put birds in the trees along the
water's edge in vergia which is
Everlasting there put specimens of all
plants the loveliest and most fragrant
and of all fruits the most succulent all
these kinds of things and creatures
shall not perish so long as they are in
the VAR but put there no deformed
creature nor impotent nor mad neither
Wicked nor deceitful nor rancorous nor
jealous nor a man with irregular teeth
nor a leper
apart from the scale of the Enterprise
there is only one real difference
between yima's divinely inspired VAR and
Noah's divinely inspired Ark the ark is
a means of surviving a terrible and
devastating flood which will destroy
every living creature by Drowning the
world in water the VAR is a means of
surviving a terrible and devastating
winter which will destroy every living
creature by covering the Earth with a
freezing blanket of ice and snow
in the bundahish another of the
zoroastrian scriptures believed to
incorporate ancient material from a lost
part of the original avesta more
information is provided on the cataclysm
of glaciation that overwhelmed Ariana
Viejo when angromainu sent the vehement
destroying Frost he also assaulted and
deranged the sky the bundahish tells us
that this assault enabled the evil one
to master one third of the sky and
overspread it with Darkness as the
encroaching ice sheets tightened their
grip
Indescribable cold fire earthquakes and
derangement of the Skies
the avestic areas of Iran who are known
to have migrated to Western Asia from
some other distant Homeland are not the
only possessors of archaic Traditions
which Echo the basic setting of the
great flood in ways unlikely to be
coincidental
indeed though these are most commonly
associated with the Deluge The Familiar
themes of the Divine warning and of the
Salvation of a remnant of mankind from a
universal disaster are also found in
many different parts of the world in
connection with the sudden onset of
glacial conditions
in South America for example Toba
Indians of the grand Chaco region that
sprawls across the modern borders of
Paraguay Argentina and Chile still
repeat an ancient myth concerning the
Advent of what they call the great cold
or warning comes from a semi-divine hero
figure named Asin
Asin told a man to gather as much wood
as he could and to cover his Hut with a
thick layer of thatch because a time of
great cold was coming
as soon as the Hut had been prepared
Asin and the man shut themselves inside
and waited when the Great cold set in
shivering people arrived to beg a
Firebrand from them Asin was hard and
gave Embers only to those who had been
his friends the people were freezing and
they cried the whole night at midnight
they were all dead young and old men and
women this period of ice and sleet
lasted for a long time and all the fires
were put out
Frost was as thick as leather
as in the avestic traditions
it seems that the great cold was
accompanied by great darkness in the
words of one Toba Elder these
afflictions were sent because when the
earth is full of people it has to change
the population has to be thinned out to
save the world in the case of the long
Darkness the sun simply disappeared and
the people starved as they ran out of
food they began eating their children
eventually they all died
the Mayan purple Vu Associates the flood
with much hail Black Rain and mist and
Indescribable cold it also says that
this was a period when it was cloudy and
Twilight all over the world the faces of
the sun and the moon were covered
other Maya sources confirmed that these
strange and terrible phenomena were
experienced by mankind in the time of
the Ancients the Earth darkened it
happened that the sun was still bright
and clear then at midday it got dark
sunlight did not return till the 26th
year after the flood
The Listener may recall that many Deluge
and catastrophe myths contain references
not only to the onset of a great
Darkness but to other changes in the
appearance of the heavens
in Tierra del Fuego for instance it was
said that the Sun and the Moon fell from
the sky and in China that the planets
altered their courses the sun moon and
stars changed their emotions the Incas
believed that in ancient times the Andes
were split apart when the sky made war
on the Earth
the Tarahumara of northern Mexico have
preserved world destruction Legends
based on a change in the sun's path an
African myth from the lower Congo states
that long ago the sun met the moon and
threw mud at it which made it less
bright when this meeting happened there
was a great flood
the Kato Indians of California say
simply that the sky fell
and the ancient Greek or Roman myths
tell that the flood of juquelion was
immediately preceded by awesome
celestial events these events are
graphically symbolized in the story of
how faithon child of the sun harnessed
his father's Chariot but was unable to
guide it along his father's course
soon the fiery horses felt how their
Reigns were in an unpracticed hand
rearing and swerving aside they left
their wanted way then all the Earth was
amazed to see that the Glorious Sun
instead of holding his stately
beneficent course across the sky seemed
to speed crookedly overhead and to rush
down in Wrath like a meteor
this is not the place to speculate on
what may have caused the alarming
disturbances in the patterns of the
heavens that are linked with cataclysm
legends from all over the world
for our purposes at present it's
sufficient to note that such Traditions
seem to refer to the same derangement of
the sky that accompanied the Fatal
winter and spreading ice sheets
described in the Iranian avesta
other linkages occur fire for example
often follows or precedes the flood in
the case of faithon's adventure with the
Sun the grass withered the crops were
scorched the woods went up in Fire and
smoke then beneath them the bare Earth
cracked and crumbled and the blackened
rocks burst asunder under the Heat
volcanism and earthquakes are also
mentioned frequently in association with
the flood particularly in the Americas
the araucanians of Chile say quite
explicitly that the flood was the result
of volcanic eruptions accompanied by
violent earthquakes
the man Maya of Santiago chimartanengo
in the western Highlands of Guatemala
retain memories of a flood of burning
pitch which they say was one of the
instruments of world destruction and in
the grand Chaco of Argentina the matako
Indians tell of a black cloud that came
from the south at the time of the flood
and covered the whole Sky lightning
struck and thunder was heard yet the
drops that fell were not like rain they
were like fire
a monster chased the Sun
there is one ancient culture that
perhaps preserves more Vivid memories in
its myths than any others that of the
so-called Teutonic tribes of Germany and
Scandinavia a culture best remembered
through the songs of the Norse skulls
and Sages
the stories those songs retell have
their roots in a past which may be much
older than Scholars imagine and which
combine familiar images with strange
symbolic devices and allegorical
language to recall a cataclysm of
awesome magnitude
in a distant forest in the East an aged
giantess brought into the world a whole
brood of young wolves whose father was
fenrir
one of these monsters chased the sun to
take possession of it
the chase was for long in vain but each
season the wolf grew in strength and at
last he reached the sun its bright rays
were one by one extinguished it took on
a blood red Hue that entirely
disappeared
thereafter the world was enveloped in
hideous winter
snowstorms descended from all points of
the Horizon war broke out all over the
Earth brother slew brother children no
longer respected the ties of blood it
was a time when men were no better than
wolves eager to destroy one another soon
the world was going to sink into the
abyss of nothingness
meanwhile the wolf fenrir whom the gods
had long ago so carefully chained up
broke his bonds at last and escaped
shook himself and the world trembled the
ash tree igdrasil envisaged as the axis
of the Earth was shaken from its roots
to its topmost branches mountains
crumbled or split from top to bottom and
the dwarves who had their Subterranean
dwellings in them sought desperately and
in vain for entrances so long familiar
but now disappeared
abandoned by the gods men were driven
from their hearths and the human race
was swept from the surface of the Earth
the Earth itself was beginning to lose
its shape already the stars were coming
adrift from the sky and falling into the
gaping void they were like swallows
weary from too long a voyage who drop
and sink into the waves
the giant suit set the entire Earth on
fire the universe was no longer more
than an immense furnace Flames spurted
from Fishers in the Rocks everywhere
there was the hissing of steam all
living things all plant life were
blotted out only the naked soil remained
but like the sky itself the Earth was no
more than cracks and crevices
and now all the rivers all the Seas Rose
and overflowed from every side waves
lashed against waves they swelled and
boiled slowly over all things the Earth
sank Beneath the Sea
yet not all men perished in the great
catastrophe
enclosed in the wood itself of the ash
tree igdrasil which the devouring flames
of the universal conflagration had been
unable to consume the ancestors of a
future race of man had escaped death
in this Asylum they had found their only
nourishment had been the morning Jew
s it was that from the wreckage of the
ancient world a new world was born
slowly the Earth emerged from the waves
mountains rose again and from them
streamed cataracts of singing Waters
the new world this Teutonic myth
announces is our own needless to say
like the fifth son of the Aztecs and the
Maya it was created long ago and is new
no longer can it be a coincidence that
one of the many Central American flood
myths about the fourth Epoch for Apple
water does not install the Noah couple
in an arc but places them instead in a
great tree just like dracil
was ended by floods the mountains
disappeared two persons survived because
they were ordered by one of the Gods to
bore a hole in the trunk of a very large
tree and to crawl inside when the skies
fell the pair entered and survived their
offspring repopulated the world
isn't it odd that the same symbolic
language keeps cropping up in ancient
Traditions from so many widely scattered
regions of the world
how can this be explained are we talking
about some vast subconscious wave of
Intercultural telepathy or could
elements of these remarkable Universal
myths have been engineered long ages ago
by clever and purposeful people which of
these improbable propositions is the
more likely to be true or are there
other possible explanations for the
Enigma of the myths
we shall return to these questions in
due course meanwhile what are we to
conclude about the apocalyptic visions
of Fire and Ice flood volcanism and
earthquakes which the myths contain they
have about them a haunting and familiar
realism could this be because they speak
to us of a past we suspect to be our own
but can neither remember clearly nor
forget completely
chapter 26 a species born in the earth's
Long Winter
in all that we call history everything
we clearly remember about ourselves as a
species Humanity has not once come close
to Total annihilation
in various regions at various times
there have been terrible natural
disasters but there has not been a
single occasion in the past five
thousand years when mankind as a whole
can be said to have faced Extinction
has this always been so or is it
possible if we go back far enough that
we might discover an Epoch when our
ancestors were nearly wiped out
it is just such an Epoch that seems to
be the focus in the great myths of
cataclysm
Scholars normally attribute these myths
to the fantasies of ancient poets but
what if the scholars are wrong what if
some terrible series of natural
catastrophes did reduce our prehistoric
ancestors to a handful of individuals
scattered here and there across the face
of the Earth far apart and out of touch
with one another
we are looking for an Epoch that will
fit the myths as snugly as the slipper
on Cinderella's foot in this search
however there's obviously no point in
investigating any period prior to the
emergence on the planet of recognizably
modern human beings we're not interested
here in Homo habilis or Homo erectus or
even Homo sapiens neanderthalensis we
are interested only in Homo sapiens
sapiens our own species and we haven't
been around very long
students of early man disagree to some
extent over how long we've been around
some researchers as we shall see claim
that partial human remains in excess of
one hundred thousand years old may be
fully modern others argue for a reduced
Antiquity in the range of 35 to 40 000
years and yet others propose a
compromise of fifty thousand years but
no one knows for sure the origin of
fully modern humans denoted by the
subspecies name Homo sapiens sapiens
remains one of the great puzzles of
paleoanthropology admits one Authority
about three and a half million years of
more or less relevant Evolution are
indicated in the fossil record
for all practical purposes that record
starts with a small bipedal hominid
nicknamed Lucy whose remains were
discovered in 1974 in the Ethiopian
section of East Africa's Great Rift
Valley with a brain capacity of 400
cubic centimeters less than a third of
the modern average Lucy definitely
wasn't human but she wasn't an ape
either and she had some remarkably
human-like features notably her upright
gate and the shape of her pelvis and
back teeth for these and other reasons
her species classified as
Australopithecus afarensis has been
accepted by the majority of
paleoanthropologists as our earliest
direct ancestor
about two million years ago
representatives of Homo habilis the
founder members of the homo line to
which we ourselves belong began to leave
their fossilized skulls and skeletons
behind
as time went by this species showed
clear signs of evolution towards an Ever
more grace Isle and refined form and
towards a larger and more versatile
brain
Homo erectus who overlapped with and
then succeeded Homo habilis appeared
about 1.6 million years ago with a brain
capacity in the region of 900 cubic
centimeters as against 700 cubic
centimeters in the case of habilis
the million or so years after that down
to about 400 000 years ago saw no
significant evolutionary changes or none
attested to by surviving fossils then
Homo erectus passed through the gates of
Extinction into hominid heaven and
slowly very very slowly what the
paleoanthropologists call the Sapient
grade began to appear
exactly when the tradition to a more
Sapient form began is difficult to
establish some believe the transition
which involved an increase in brain size
and a decrease in the robustness of the
skull bones began as early as 400 000
years ago unfortunately there are simply
not enough fossils from this important
period to be sure about what was
happening
what was definitely not happening four
hundred thousand years ago was the
emergence of anything identifiable as
our own storytelling myth-making
subspecies Homo sapiens sapiens the
consensus is that Sapient humans must
have evolved from Homo erectus and it is
true that a number of archaic Sapient
populations did come into existence
between four hundred thousand and one
hundred thousand years ago unfortunately
the relationship of these transitional
species to ourselves is far from clear
as noted the first contenders for
membership of the exclusive Club of homo
sapiens sapiens have been dated by some
researchers to the latter part of this
period but these remains are all partial
and their identification is by no means
universally accepted the oldest part of
a skull cap is a putative modern human
specimen from about 113
000 BC around this day two Homo sapiens
neanderthalensis first appears a quite
distinct subspecies which most of us
know as Neanderthal man
tall heavily muscled with prominent brow
ridges and a protruding face Neanderthal
man had a bigger average brain size than
modern humans 1 400 cubic centimeters as
against our
1360 cubic centimeters
possession of such a big brain was no
doubt an asset to these intelligent
spiritually sensitive resourceful
creatures and the fossil record suggests
that they were the dominant species on
the planet from about a hundred thousand
years ago until forty thousand years ago
at some point during this lengthy and
poorly understood period Homo sapiens
sapiens established itself leaving
behind fossil remains from about forty
thousand years ago that are undisputably
those of modern humans and supplanting
the Neanderthals completely by about 35
000 years ago in summary human beings
like ourselves whom we could pass in the
street without blinking an eyelid if
they were shaved and dressed in modern
clothes are creatures of the last 115
000 years at the very most and more
probably of only the last fifty thousand
years it follows that if the myths of
cataclysm we have reviewed do reflect an
Epoch of geological upheaval experienced
by Humanity these upheavals took place
within the last 115
000 years and more probably within the
last fifty thousand years
Cinderella's slipper
it is a curious Coincidence of geology
and paleoanthropology that the onset and
progress of the last ice age and the
emergence and proliferation of modern
man more or less Shadow each other
curious too is the fact that so little
is known about either
in North America the last ice age is
called the Wisconsin glaciation named
for rock deposits studied in the state
of Wisconsin and its early phase has
been dated by geologists to 115
000 years ago
there were various advances and Retreats
of the ice cap after that with the
fastest rate of accumulation taking
place between sixty thousand years ago
and seventeen thousand years ago
process culminating in the tasewell
advance which saw the glaciation reached
its maximum extent around fifteen
thousand BC
my 13 000 BC however millions of square
miles of ice had melted for reasons that
have never properly been explained and
by 8000 BC the Wisconsin had withdrawn
completely
the Ice Age was a global phenomenon
affecting both the northern and the
southern hemispheres similar climatic
and geological conditions therefore
prevailed in many other parts of the
world as well notably in eastern Asia
Australia New Zealand and South America
there was massive glaciation in Europe
where the ice reached outward from
Scandinavia and Scotland to cover most
of Great Britain Denmark Poland Russia
large parts of Germany all of
Switzerland and big chunks of Austria
Italy and France
known technically as the warm glaciation
this European Ice Age started about 70
000 years ago a little later than its
American counterpart but attained its
maximum extent at the same time
seventeen thousand years ago and then
experienced the same rapid withdrawal
and shared the same terminal date
The crucial stages of Ice Age chronology
thus appear to be one around sixty
thousand years ago when the worm and the
Wisconsin and other glaciations were
well underway two around seventeen
thousand years ago when the ice sheets
had reached their maximum extent in both
the old world and the new
three the seven thousand years of
deglaciation that followed
the emergence of homo sapiens sapiens
thus coincided with a lengthy period of
geological and climatic turbulence a
period marked Above All Else by
ferocious freezing and flooding the many
Millennia during which the ice was
remorselessly expanding must have been
terrifying and awful for our ancestors
but those final seven thousand years of
deglaciation particularly the episodes
of very rapid and extensive melting must
have been worse
let us not jump to conclusions about the
state of social or religious or
scientific or intellectual development
of human beings who lived through the
sustained collapse of that tumultuous
epoch the popular stereotype may be
wrong in assuming that they were all
primitive cave dwellers in reality
little is known about them and almost
the only thing that can be said is that
they were men and women exactly like
ourselves physiologically and
psychologically it is possible that they
came close to Total Extinction on
several occasions during the upheavals
they experienced it is also possible
that the great myths of cataclysm to
which Scholars attribute no historical
value may contain accurate records and
eyewitness accounts of real events
as we'll hear in the next chapter if we
are looking for an Epoch that fits those
myths as snugly as the slipper on
Cinderella's foot it would seem that the
last ice age is it
chapter 27.
the face of the Earth was darkened and a
Black Rain began to fall
terrible forces were Unleashed on all
living creatures during the last ice age
we made the juice how these Afflicted
Humanity from The Firm evidence of their
consequences for other large species
often this evidence looks puzzling
as Charles Darwin observed after
visiting South America
no one I think can have marveled more at
the extinction of species than I have
done
when I found in La Plata Argentina the
tooth of a horse embedded with the
remains of Mastodon megatherium toxadon
and other extinct monsters which all
coexisted at a very late geological
period I was filled with astonishment
for seeing that the horse since its
introduction by the Spaniards in South
America has run wild over the whole
country and has increased its numbers at
an unparalleled rate I ask myself what
could have so recently exterminated the
former horse under conditions of Life
apparently so favorable
the answer of course was the ice age
that was what exterminated the former
horses of the Americas and a number of
other previously successful mammals nor
were the extinctions limited to the new
world on the contrary in different parts
of the Earth for different reasons and
at different times the long Epoch of
glaciation witnessed several quite
distinct episodes of Extinction in all
areas the vast majority of the many
destroyed species were lost in the final
seven thousand years from about 15 000
BC down to 8000 BC
at this stage of our investigation it is
not necessary to establish the specific
nature of the climatic seismic and
geological events linked to the various
advances and Retreats of the ice sheets
which killed off the animals we might
reasonably guess that tidal waves
earthquakes gigantic windstorms and the
sudden onset and remission of glacial
conditions played their parts
but more important whatever the actual
agencies involve is the Stark empirical
reality that mass extinctions of animals
did take place as a result of the
turmoil of the last ice age
this turmoil as Darwin concluded in his
journal must have shaken the entire
framework of the globe
in the new world for example more than
70 Genera of large mammals became
extinct between 15 000 BC and 8000 BC
including all North American members of
seven families and one complete order
the proboscadea these staggering losses
involving the violent obliteration of
more than 40 million animals were not
spread out evenly over the whole period
on the contrary the vast majority of the
extinctions occurred in just two
thousand years between 11 000 BC and
9000 BC to put this in perspective
during the previous three hundred
thousand years only about 20 Genera had
disappeared
the same pattern of late and massive
extinctions was repeated across Europe
and Asia even far off Australia was not
exempt losing perhaps 19 Genera of large
vertebrates not all of the mammals in a
relatively short period of time
Alaska and Siberia the sudden freeze
the northern regions of Alaska and
Siberia appear to have been the worst
hit by the murderous upheavals between
thirteen thousand and eleven thousand
years ago in a great swathe of Death
Around the edge of the Arctic Circle the
remains of uncountable numbers of large
animals have been found including many
carcasses with the flesh still intact
and astonishing quantities of perfectly
preserved Mammoth tusks indeed in both
regions Mammoth carcasses have been
thawed to feed sled dogs and Mammoth
Stakes have featured on restaurant menus
in Fairbanks one Authority has commented
hundreds of thousands of individuals
must have been frozen immediately after
death and remained Frozen otherwise the
meat and ivory would have spoiled some
powerful General force was certainly at
work to bring this catastrophe about
Dr Dale Guthrie of The Institute of
Arctic biology has made an interesting
point about the sheer variety of animals
that flourished in Alaska before the
11th millennium BC
when learning of this exotic mixture of
saber-toothed cats camels horses rhinos
asses deer with gigantic antlers Lions
ferrets and Saiga one cannot help
wondering about the world in which they
lived this great diversity of species so
different from that encounter today
raises the most obvious question is it
not likely that the rest of the
environment was also different
the Alaskan muck in which the remains
are embedded is like a fine dark gray
sand frozen solid within this mass in
the words of Professor hibben of the
University of New Mexico lie the Twisted
parts of animals and trees intermingled
with lenses of ice and layers of peat
and mosses bison horses wolves Bears
Lions whole herds of animals were
apparently killed together overcome by
some common power such piles of bodies
of animals or men simply do not occur by
any ordinary natural means
at various levels Stone artifacts have
been found Frozen in situ at Great
depths and in association with Ice Age
fauna which confirms that men were
contemporary with extinct animals in
Alaska
throughout the Alaskan mucks also there
is evidence of atmospheric disturbances
of unparalleled violence Mammoth and
bison alike were torn and twisted as
though by a cosmic hand in Godly rage
in one place we can find the four-legged
and shoulder of a mammoth with portions
of the Flesh and toenails and hair still
clinging to the blackened Bones close by
is the neck and skull of a bison with
the vertebrae clinging together with
tendons and ligaments and the chitinus
covering of the horns intact there is no
Mark of knife or cutting instrument as
there would be if human hunters for
example had been involved the animals
were simply torn apart and Scattered
over the landscape like things of straw
and string even though some of them
weighed several tons
mixed with piles of bones are trees also
twisted and torn and piled in Tangled
groups and the hole is covered with a
fine sifting muck than frozen solid much
the same picture emerges in Siberia
where catastrophic climatic changes and
geological upheavals occurred at around
the same time
here the frozen mammoth graveyards mined
for their Ivory since the Roman era
we're still yielding an estimated 20 000
pairs of tusks every decade at the
beginning of the 20th century
once again some mysterious Factor
appears to have been at work in bringing
about these mass extinctions with their
woolly coats and thick skins mammoths
are generally considered adapted to cold
weather and we are not surprised to come
across their remains in Siberia
harder to explain is the fact that human
beings perished alongside them as well
as many other animals that in no sense
can be described as cold adapted species
the northern Siberian Plains supported
vast numbers of rhinoceroses Antelope
horses bison and other herbivorous
creatures while a variety of carnivores
including the saber-toothed cat preyed
upon them
like the mammoths these other animals
ranged to the extreme north of Siberia
to the shores of the Arctic Ocean and
yet further north to the layakov and new
Siberian Islands only a very short
distance from the North Pole
researchers have confirmed that of the
34 animal species living in Siberia
prior to the catastrophes of the 11th
millennium BC including Mammoth giant
deer cave hyena and Cave Lions no less
than 28 were adapted only to temperate
conditions in this context one of the
most puzzling aspects of the extinctions
which runs quite contrary to what
today's geographical and climatic
conditions lead us to expect is that the
further north one goes the more the
mammoth and other remains increase in
number indeed some of the new Siberian
Islands well within the Arctic Circle
were described by the explorers who
first discovered them as being made up
almost entirely of Mammoth Burns and
tusks the only logical conclusion as the
19th century French zoologist George
cuvier put it is that this eternal Frost
did not previously exist in those parts
in which the animals were frozen or they
could not have survived in such a
temperature the same instant that these
creatures were bereft of Life the
country which they inhabited became
Frozen
there is a great deal of other evidence
which suggests that a sudden freeze took
place in Siberia during the 11th
millennium BC
in his survey of the new Siberian
Islands the Arctic Explorer Baron Edward
vantal found the remains of a
saber-toothed tiger and a fruit tree
that had been 90 feet tall when it was
standing
the tree was well preserved in the
permafrost with his roots and seeds
green leaves and ripe fruit still clung
to its branches at the present time the
only representative of tree vegetation
on the islands is a willow that grows
one inch high
equally indicative of the cataclysmic
change that took place at the onset of
the great cold in Siberia is the food
the extinct animals were eating when
they perished the mammoths died suddenly
in intense cold and in great numbers
death came so quickly that the swallowed
vegetation is yet undigested brasses
blue bells buttercups tender sedges and
wild beans have been found yet
identifiable and undeteriorated in their
mouths and stomachs
needless to say such Flora does not grow
anywhere in Siberia today its presence
there in the 11th millennium BC compels
us to accept that the region had a
pleasant and productive climate one that
was temperate or even warm
by the end of the last ice age in other
parts of the world should have been the
beginning of fatal winter in this form
of paradise is a question we shall
postpone until part 8. what is certain
however is that at some point between
twelve thousand to thirteen thousand
years ago a destroying Frost descended
with horrifying speed upon Siberia and
has never relaxed its grip in an eerie
echo of the avestic Traditions a land
which had previously enjoyed seven
months of Summer was converted almost
overnight into a land of ice and snow
with 10 months of harsh and Frozen
winter
a thousand krakatoas all at once
many of the myths of cataclysm speak of
times of terrible cold of darkened Skies
of black burning bituminous rain for
centuries it must have been like that
all the way across the Arc of death
incorporating immense tracts of Siberia
the Yukon and Alaska
here interspersed in the muck depths and
sometimes through the very piles of
Bones and tusks themselves are layers of
volcanic ash
there is no doubt that coincidental with
the extinctions there were volcanic
eruptions of tremendous proportions
there is a remarkable amount of evidence
of excessive volcanism during the
decline of the Wisconsin ice cap to the
south of the Frozen Alaskan mucks
thousands of prehistoric animals and
plants were mired all at once in the
famous La Brea Tar Pits of Los Angeles
among the creatures on Earth were bison
horses camels sloths mammoths mastodons
and at least 700 saber-toothed tigers
a disarticulated human skeleton was also
found completely enveloped in bitumen
mingled with the bones of an extinct
species of vulture in general the La
Brea remains broken mashed contorted and
mixed in a most heterogeneous Mass speak
eloquently of a sudden and Dreadful
volcanic cataclysm
ilar finds of typical late Ice Age birds
and mammals have been Unearthed from
asphalt at two other locations in
California
Carpenteria and McKittrick in the San
Pedro Valley Mastodon skeletons were
discovered still standing upright
engulfed in great heaps of volcanic ash
and sand fossils from the glacial Lake
floristan in Colorado and from Oregon's
John Day Basin were also excavated from
tombs of volcanic ash
although the tremendous eruption that
created such Mass Graves may have been
at their most intense during the last
days of the Wisconsin they appear to
have been recurrent throughout much of
the Ice Age not only in North America
but in Central and South America in the
North Atlantic in Continental Asia and
in Japan it is difficult to imagine what
this widespread volcanism might have
meant for people living in those strange
and terrible times
but those who recall the
cauliflower-shaped clouds of dust smoke
and Ash ejected into the upper
atmosphere by the eruption of mounts and
Helens in 1980 will appreciate that a
large number of such explosions
occurring sequentially over a sustained
period at different points around the
globe would not only have had
devastating local effects but would have
caused a severe deterioration in the
world's climate
Mount Saint Helens spat out an estimated
one cubic kilometer of rock and was
small scale by comparison with the
typical volcanism of the Ice Age
a more representative impression would
be the Indonesian volcano Krakatoa which
erupted in 1883 with such violence that
more than 36 000 people were killed and
the explosion was heard three thousand
miles away
from the epicenter in the Sunda Strait
tsunamis 100 feet high roared across the
Java Sea and the Indian Ocean carrying
steamships miles in land and causing
flooding as far away as East Africa and
the Western coasts of the Americas
18 cubic kilometers of rock and vast
quantities of Ash and dust were pumped
into the upper atmosphere
Skies all over the world were noticeably
darker for more than two years and
sunsets notably redder average global
temperatures fell measurably during this
period because volcanic dust particles
reflect the sun's Rays back into space
during the episodes of intense volcanism
which characterized the Ice Age we must
envisage not one but many krakatoes the
combined effect would at first have been
a great intensification of glacial
conditions as the light of the sun was
cut by the boiling dust clouds and has
already low temperatures plummeted even
further
volcanoes also inject enormous volumes
of carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
and carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas
so it is reasonable to suppose as the
dust began to settle during periods of
relative calm that a degree of global
warming would have occurred a number of
authorities attribute the repeated
advances and Retreats of the great ice
sheets to precisely this seesaw
interaction between volcanism and
Global flooding
geologists agree that by 8000 BC the
great Wisconsin and verm ice caps had
retreated the Ice Age was over
however the seven thousand years prior
to that
had witnessed climatic and geological
turbulence on a scale that was almost
unimaginable lurching from cataclysm to
disaster and from Misfortune to Calamity
the few scattered tribes of surviving
humans must have led lives of constant
Terror and confusion there would have
been periods of quiescence when they
might have hoped that the worst was over
while the melting of the giant glaciers
continued however these episodes of
Tranquility would have been punctuated
again and again by violent floods
moreover sections of the Earth's crust
hitherto pressed down into the
asthenosphere by billions of tons of ice
would have been liberated by the Thor
and began to rise again sometimes
rapidly causing devastating earthquakes
and filling the air with terrible noise
sometimes we're much worse than others
the bulk of the animal extinctions took
place between 11 000 BC and 9000 BC when
there were violent and unexplained
fluctuations of climate in the words of
geologist John imbrie a climatic
Revolution took place around 11 000
years ago
there were also greatly increased rates
of sedimentation and an Abrupt
temperature increase of 6 to 10 degrees
centigrade in the surface waters of the
Atlantic Ocean
another turbulent episode a gain
accompanied by mass extinctions took
place between 15 000 BC and 13 000 BC we
heard in the previous chapter that the
Tays will advance brought the ice sheets
to their maximum extent around 17 000
years ago and that a dramatic and
prolonged Thor then ensued completely
deglaciating millions of square miles of
North America and Europe in less than 2
000 years
there were some anomalies all of Western
Alaska the Yukon territory in Canada and
most of Siberia including the new
Siberian Islands now among the coldest
parts of the world remained unglaciated
until the Ice Age was near its end they
acquired their present climate only
about 12 000 years ago apparently very
abruptly when the mammoths and other
large mammals were frozen in their
tracks
elsewhere the picture was different most
of Europe was buried under ice two miles
thick so too was most of North America
where the ice cap had spread from
centers near Hudson Bay to enshroud all
of Eastern Canada New England and much
of the Midwest down to the 37th parallel
well to the south of Cincinnati in the
Mississippi Valley and more than halfway
to the equator
at its peak seventeen thousand years ago
it is calculated that the total ice
volume covering the Northern Hemisphere
was in the region of 6 million cubic
miles and of course there were extensive
glaciations in the southern hemisphere
too as we noted the Surplus water flow
from which these numerous ice caps were
formed had been provided by the world
seas and oceans which were then about
400 feet lower than they are today
it was at this moment that the pendulum
of climate swung violently in the
opposite direction the great meltdown
began so suddenly and over such vast
areas that it has been described as a
sort of Miracle
geologists refer to it as the Bolling
phase of warm climate in Europe and as
the Brady intestadial in North America
in both regions an ice cap that may have
taken forty thousand years to develop
disappeared for the most part in 2000 it
must be obvious that this could not have
been the result of gradually acting
climatic factors usually called upon to
explain ice ages the rapidity of the
deglaciation suggests that some
extraordinary Factor was affecting the
climate the dates suggest that this
Factor first made itself felt about
sixteen thousand five hundred years ago
that it had destroyed most perhaps three
quarters of the glaciers by two thousand
years later and that the vast bulk of
these dramatic developments took place
in a millennium or less
inevitably the first consequence was a
precipitous rise in sea levels perhaps
as much as 350 feet islands and land
bridges disappeared and vast sections of
low-lying Continental Coastline were
submerged
from time to time great tidal waves rose
up to engulf higher land as well they
ebbed away but in the process left
unmistakable traces of their presence
in the United States Ice Age Marine
features are present along the Gulf
Coast east of the Mississippi River in
some places at altitudes that may exceed
200 feet
in bogs covering glacial deposits in
Michigan skeletons of two whales were
discovered in Georgia Marine deposits
occur at altitudes of 160 feet and in
Northern Florida at altitudes of at
least 240 feet
Texas well to the south of the farthest
extents of the Wisconsin glaciation the
remains of Ice Age land mammals are
found in Marine deposits another Marine
deposit containing walrus seals and at
least five Genera of whales overlies the
Seaboard of the northeastern states and
the Arctic coast of Canada in many areas
along the Pacific coast of North America
Ice Age Marine deposits extend more than
200 miles Inland the bones of a whale
have been found north of Lake Ontario
about 440 feet above sea level
skeleton of another whale in Vermont
more than 500 feet above sea level and
another in the Montreal Quebec area
about 600 feet above sea level
flood myths from all over the world
characteristically and recurrently
described scenes when humans and animals
flee the rising tides and take refuge on
mountaintops the fossil record confirms
that this did indeed happen during the
melting of the ice sheets and that the
mountains were not always high enough to
save the refugees from disaster for
example tissues in the rocks on the tops
of isolated Hills in central France are
filled with what is known as osseus
breccia consisting of the splinted bones
of mammoths woolly rhinoceroses and
other animals
the 1430 feet peak of Mount Gene in
burgundy is capped by a breccia
containing remains of Mammoth reindeer
horse and other animals much further
south so too is the Rock of Gibraltar
where a human molar and some flints
worked by Paleolithic man were
discovered among the animal bones hippo
remains together with Mammoth rhinoceros
horse bear bison wolf and lion have been
found in England in the neighborhood of
Plymouth on the channel
the hills around Palermo in Sicily
disclosed an extraordinary quantity of
Bones of hippopotami incomplete hecatums
on the basis of this and other evidence
Joseph prestwich formerly professor of
geology at Oxford University concluded
that Central Europe England and the
Mediterranean islands of Corsica
Sardinia and Sicily were all completely
submerged on several occasions during
the rapid melting of the ice sheets the
animals naturally retreated as the
waters Advanced deeper into the hills
until they found themselves in babe they
thronged together in vast multitudes
crushing into the more accessible caves
until overtaken by the waters and
destroyed Rocky debris and large blocks
from the sides of the hills were hurled
down by the currents of water crushing
and smashing the bones certain
communities of early man must have
suffered in this General catastrophe
it is probable that similar flood
disasters occurred in China at much the
same time in caves near P King bones of
mammoths and Buffalos have been found in
association with human skeletal remains
a number of authorities attribute the
violent intermingling of Mammoth
carcasses with splinted and broken trees
in Siberia to a great tidal wave that
uprooted forests and buried the tangle
of Carnage in a flood of mud
in the polar region this froze solid and
has preserved the evidence in permafrost
to the present
all over South America too Ice Age
fossils have been Unearthed in which
incongruous animal types carnivores and
herbivores are mixed promiscuously with
human bones no less significant is the
association over truly widespread areas
of fossilized land and sea creatures
mingled in no order and yet entombed in
the same geological Horizon
North America was also badly affected by
flooding as the great Wisconsin ice
sheets melted they created huge but
temporary Lakes which filled up with
Incredible speed drowning everything in
their paths then drained away in a few
hundred years Lake Agassiz for example
the largest glacial Lake in the new
world once occupied an area of 110
000 square miles covering large parts of
what are now Manitoba Ontario
Saskatchewan and Canada and North Dakota
and Minnesota in the United States
remarkably it endured for less than a
millennium indicating a catastrophically
sudden episode of melting and flooding
followed by a period of quiescence
a token of good faith
it was long believed that human beings
did not reach the new world until around
11 000 years ago but recent finds have
steadily pushed that Horizon back
Stone implements dating to 25
000 BC have been identified by Canadian
researchers in the Old Crow Basin in the
Yukon Territory of Alaska
in South America as far south as Peru
and Tierra del Fuego human remains and
artifacts have been found which have
been reliably dated to 12 000 BC with
another group between 19 000 BC and 23
000 BC with this and other evidence
taken into account a very reasonable
conclusion on the peopling of the
Americas is that it began at least 35
000 years ago but may well have included
waves of immigrants at later dates too
those newly arriving Ice Age Americans
trekking in from Siberia across the
Bering land bridge would have faced the
most appalling conditions between 17
000 and 10 000 years ago
it was then that the Wisconsin glaciers
all at once went into their ferocious
meltdown forcing a 350-foot rise in
global sea levels amid scenes of
unprecedented climatic and geological
turmoil for seven thousand years of
Human Experience earthquakes volcanic
eruptions and immense floods
interspersed with Eerie periods of Peace
must have dominated the day-to-day lives
of the new world peoples
perhaps this is why so many of their
myths speak with such conviction of fire
and floods and Times of darkness and of
the creation and destruction of sons
moreover as we've heard the myths of the
new world are not in this respect
isolated from those of the old all
around the globe a remarkable uniformity
reveals itself over issues such as the
great flood and the great cold and the
time of the great upheaval it is not
just that the same experiences are being
recounted again and again that on its
own would be quite understandable since
the Ice Age and its after effects were
Global phenomena more Curious by far is
the way in which the same symbolic
motifs keep recurring the one good man
and his family the warning given by a
God the seeds of all living things saved
the survival ship the enclosure against
the cold the trunk of a tree in which
the progenitors of future Humanity hide
themselves the birds and other creatures
released after the flood to find land
and so on
isn't it also odd that so many of the
myths turn out to contain descriptions
of figures like Quetzalcoatl and Vera
kocha said to have come in the time of
Darkness After the flood to teach
architecture astronomy science and the
rule of law to the scattered and
devastated tribes of survivors
who were these civilizing Heroes were
they figments of the Primitive
imagination
or gods or men if they were men could
they have tampered with the myths in
some way turning them into vehicles for
transporting knowledge Through Time
such Notions seem fanciful but as we
shall hear in part 5 astronomical data
of a disturbingly accurate and
scientific nature turns up repeatedly in
certain myths As Time worn and as
universal in their distribution as those
of the great flood
where did their scientific content come
from
part five
The Mystery of the myths section 2
the precessional code
chapter 28
the Machinery of Heaven
although a modern reader does not expect
a text on Celestial mechanics to read
like a lullaby
he insists on his capacity to understand
mythical images instantly because he can
respect as scientific only page-long
approximation formulas and the like
he does not think of the possibility
that equally relevant knowledge might
once have been expressed in everyday
language
he never suspects such a possibility
although the visible accomplishments of
ancient cultures to mention only the
pyramids or mythology should be a cogent
reason for concluding that serious and
intelligent men were at work behind the
stage men who were bound to have used a
technical language
the quotation is from the late Giorgio
de santellana professor of the history
of science at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology in the chapters
that follow we shall be learning about
his revolutionary investigations into
ancient mythology in brief however this
proposition is this long ages ago
serious and intelligent people devised a
system prevailing the technical
terminology of an advanced astronomical
science behind the everyday language of
myth
is Santa Diana right
and if he's right who were these serious
and intelligent people these astronomers
these ancient scientists who worked
behind the stage of prehistory
let's start with some basics
the wild Celestial dance
the earth makes a complete circuit
around its own axis once every 24 hours
and has an equatorial circumference of
24
902.45 miles
it follows therefore that a man standing
still on the equator is in fact in
motion revolving with the planet at just
over 1 000 miles per hour
viewed from outer space looking down on
the North Pole the direction of rotation
is anti-clockwise
while spinning daily on its own axis the
Earth also orbits the sun again in an
anti-clockwise Direction on a path which
is slightly elliptical rather than
completely circular
it pursues this orbit at truly Breakneck
speed traveling as far along it in an
hour sixty six thousand six hundred
miles as the average motorist will drive
in six years
to bring the calculations down in scale
this means that we are hurtling through
space much faster than any Bullet at the
rate of 18.5 miles every second
in the time that it has taken me to read
this paragraph we have voyaged about 550
miles further along the earth's path
around the Sun
with a year required to complete a full
circuit the only evidence we have of the
tremendous orbital race we are
participating in is the slow March of
the seasons and in the operations of the
seasons themselves it is possible to see
a wondrous and impartial mechanism at
work
Distributing spring summer autumn and
winter fairly around the globe across
the northern and southern hemispheres
year in year out with absolute
regularity
the Earth's axis of rotation is tilted
in relation to the plane of its orbit at
about 23.5 degrees to the vertical
this tilt which causes the seasons
points the North Pole and the entire
Northern Hemisphere away from the Sun
for six months a year while the southern
hemisphere enjoys its summer and points
the South Pole and the southern
hemisphere away from the Sun but the
remaining six months while the Northern
Hemisphere enjoys its summer the seasons
result from the annual variation in the
angle at which the sun's Rays reach any
particular point on the Earth's surface
and from the annual variation in the
number of hours of sunlight received
there at different times of the year the
Earth's Tilt is referred to in technical
language as its obliquity
and the plane of its orbit extended
outwards to form a great circle in the
celestial sphere is known as the
ecliptic
astronomers also speak of the celestial
equator which is an extension of the
Earth's equator into the celestial
sphere
the celestial equator is today inclined
at about 23.5 degrees to the ecliptic
because the Earth's axis is inclined at
23.5 degrees to the vertical this angle
termed the obliquity of the ecliptic is
not fixed and immutable for all time
on the contrary as we heard in chapter
11 in relation to the dating of the
Andean city of tiwanaco
it is subject to constant though very
slow oscillations these occur across a
range of slightly less than three
degrees Rising closest to the vertical
at 22.1 degrees and falling farthest
away at 24.5 degrees a full cycle from
24.5 degrees to 22.1 degrees and back
again to 24.5 degrees takes
approximately 41 000 years to complete
so our fragile Planet nods and Spins
while soaring along its orbital path
the orbit takes a year and the spin
takes a day and the nod has a cycle of
41 000 years a wild Celestial dance
seems to be going on as we Skip and skim
and dive through eternity and we feel
the tug of contradictory urges to fall
into the sun on one hand to make a break
for the outer Darkness on the other
recondite influences
the sun's gravitational domain in the
inner Circles of which the Earth is held
captive is now known to extend more than
15 trillion miles into space almost
halfway to the nearest star
its pull upon our planet is therefore
immense
also affecting us is the gravity of the
other planets with which we share the
solar system each of these exerts an
attraction which tends to draw the Earth
out of its regular orbit around the sun
the planets are of different sizes
however and revolve around the Sun at
different speeds the combined
gravitational influence they are able to
exert thus changes over time in complex
but predictable ways and the orbit
changes its shape constantly in response
since the orbit is an ellipse these
changes affect its degree of elongation
known technically as its eccentricity
this varies from a low value close to
zero when the orbit approaches the form
of a perfect circle to a high value of
about six percent when it is at its most
elongated and elliptical
there are other forms of planetary
influence too thus though no explanation
has yet been forthcoming it is known
that shortwave radio frequencies are
Disturbed when Jupiter Saturn and Mars
line up
and in this connection evidence has also
emerged of a strange and unexpected
correlation between the positions of
Jupiter Saturn and Mars and their orbits
around the Sun and violent electrical
disturbances in the earth's upper
atmosphere this would seem to indicate
that the planets and the Sun share in a
cosmic electrical balance mechanism that
extends a billion miles from the center
of our solar system such an electrical
balance is not accounted for in current
astrophysical theories
the New York Times from which the above
report is taken does not attempt to
clarify matters further its writers are
probably unaware of just how much they
sound like barosis the child day and
historian astronomer and Seer of the 3rd
Century BC who made a deep study of the
Omens he believed would presage the
final destruction of the world he
concluded I birosis interpreter of
bellus affirmed that all the Earth
inherits will be consigned to Flame when
the five planets assemble in cancer so
arranged in one row that a straight line
may pass through their spheres
a conjunction of five planets that might
have been expected to have profound
gravitational effects did take place on
the 5th of May in the year 2000 when
Neptune Uranus Venus Mercury and Mars
aligned with Earth on the other side of
the Sun
let us also note that modern astrologers
who have charted the Mayan date for the
end of the fifth Sun calculate that
there will be a most peculiar
arrangement of planets at that time
indeed an arrangement so peculiar that
it can only occur once in forty five
thousand two hundred years from this
extraordinary pattern we might well
expect an extraordinary effect no one in
his or her right mind would rush to
accept such a proposition nevertheless
it cannot be denied that multiple
influences many of which we do not fully
understand appear to be at work within
our solar system among these influences
that of our own satellite the Moon is
particularly strong earthquakes for
example occur more often when the moon
is full or when the earth is between the
Sun and the Moon when the moon is new or
between the Sun and the Earth when the
moon crosses the Meridian of the
affected locality and when the moon is
closest to the Earth on its orbit indeed
when the moon reaches this latter point
technically referred to as its perigee
its gravitational attraction increases
by about six percent this happens once
every 27 and one-third days the tidal
pull that it exerts on these occasions
affects not only the great movements of
our oceans but those of the reservoirs
of hot magma penned within the Earth's
thin crust which has been described as
resembling a paper bag filled with honey
or molasses swinging along at a rate of
more than a thousand miles an hour in
Equatorial rotation and more than 66 000
miles an hour in orbit
the wobble of a deformed planet
all this circular motion of course
generates immense centrifugal forces and
these are Sir Isaac Newton demonstrated
in the 17th century caused the Earth's
paper bag to bulge outwards of the
Equator
the corollary is a flattening at the
pole in consequence our planet deviates
slightly from the form of a perfect
sphere and is more accurately described
as an oblate spheroid its radius at the
equator
3963.374 miles is about 14 miles longer
than its polar radius
3949.921 miles
for billions of years the flattened
poles and the bulging equator have been
engaged in a covert mathematical
interaction with the recondite influence
of gravity
because the Earth is flattened explains
one Authority the moon's gravity tends
to tilt the Earth's axis so that it
becomes perpendicular to the moon's
orbit and to a lesser extent the same is
true for the Sun at the same time the
equatorial bulge the extra mass
distributed around the equator acts like
the rim of a gyroscope to keep the Earth
steady on its axis year in year out on a
planetary scale it is this gyroscopic
effect that prevents the tug of the Sun
and the Moon from radically altering the
Earth's axis of rotation the pull these
two bodies jointly exert is however
sufficiently strong to force the axis to
precess which means that it wobbles
slowly in a clockwise Direction opposite
to that of the Earth's spin
this important motion is our planet's
characteristic signature within the
solar system anyone who has ever set
atop spinning should be able to
understand it without much difficulty
atop after all is simply another type of
gyroscope in full uninterrupted spin it
stands upright but the moment its axis
is deflected from the vertical it begins
to exhibit a second Behavior a slow and
obstinate reverse wobble around a great
circle this wobble which is precession
changes the direction in which the axis
points while keeping constant its newly
tilted angle
a second analogy somewhat different in
approach may help to clarify matters a
little further one envisage the Earth
floating in space inclined at
approximately 23.5 degrees to the
vertical and spinning around on its axis
once every 24 hours
2. envisage this axis as a massively
strong pivot or axle passing through the
center of the earth exiting via the
North and South poles and extending
outwards from there in both directions
three imagine that you are a giant
striding through the solar system with
orders to carry out a specific task
4. imagine approaching the Tilted Earth
which because of your great size now
looks no bigger to you than a mill wheel
5. imagine reaching out and grasping the
two ends of the extended axis
six and imagine yourself slowly
beginning to inter rotate them pushing
one end pulling the other
seven the Earth was already spinning
when you arrive
eight your orders therefore are not to
get involved in its axial rotation but
rather to impart to it its other motion
that slow clockwise wobble called
precession nine to fulfill this
commission you will have to push the
northern tip of the extended axis up and
around a great circle in the northern
Celestial hemisphere while at the same
time pulling the southern tip around an
equally large Circle in the southern
Celestial hemisphere this will involve a
slow swiveling pedaling motion with your
hands and shoulders
10. be warned however the milk wheel of
the earth is heavier than it looks
so much heavier in fact that it's going
to take you 25
776 years to turn the two tips of its
axis through one full processional cycle
at the end of which they will be aiming
at the same points in the celestial
sphere as when you arrived 11-0 and by
the way now that you've started the job
we may as well tell you that you're
never going to be allowed to leave as
soon as one processional cycle is over
another must begin and another and
another and another and so on endlessly
forever and ever and ever
12. you can think of this if you like as
one of the basic mechanisms of the solar
system
or if you prefer as one of the
fundamental Commandments of the Divine
will
in the process little by little as you
slowly sweep the extended axis around
the heavens its two tips will point to
one star after another in the polar
latitudes of the Southern Celestial
Hemisphere and sometimes of course to
empty space and to one star after
another in the polar latitudes of the
northern Celestial hemisphere we are
talking here about a kind of musical
chairs Among the circumpolar Stars and
what keeps everything in motion is the
Earth's axial precession a motion driven
by giant gravitational and gyroscopic
forces that is regular predictable and
relatively easy to work out with the aid
of modern equipment thus for example the
northern pole star is presently Alpha
ursai minoris which we know as Polaris
but computer calculations enable us to
state with certainty that in 3000 BC
Arthur draconis occupied the pole
position at the time of the Greeks the
northern pulse star was beta usai
minoris and in ad14000 it will be vegan
a great secret of the past
it will not hurt to remind ourselves of
some of the fundamental data concerning
the movements of the earth and its
orientation in space
it tilts at about 23.5 degrees to the
vertical an angle from which it can vary
by as much as 1.5 degrees on either side
over periods of 41 000 years
it completes a full pre-sessional cycle
once every twenty five thousand seven
hundred and seventy six years
it spins on its own axis once every 24
hours
it orbits the sun once every 365 days
actually
365.2422 days
the most important influence on its
seasons is the angle at which the Rays
of the sun strike it at various points
on its orbital path
let us also note that there are four
crucial astronomical moments in the year
marking the official beginning of each
of the four seasons
these moments or cardinal points which
were of immense importance to the
Ancients are the winter and summer
solstices and the spring and Autumn
equinoxes in the northern hemisphere the
winter solstice the shortest Day falls
on the 21st of December
and the summer solstice the longest day
on the 21st of June in the southern
hemisphere on the other hand everything
is literally upside down there winter
begins on the 21st of June and summer on
the 21st of December The Equinox is by
contrast are the two points in the year
on which night and day are of equal
length all over the planet once again
however as with the solstices the date
that marks the onset of spring in the
northern hemisphere the 20th of March
marks that of autumn in the Southern
Hemisphere and the date for the onset of
autumn in the northern hemisphere the
22nd of September marks the onset of
spring in the southern hemisphere
like the subtler variations of the
seasons all this is brought about by the
benevolent obliquity of the planet the
northern hemisphere's summer solstice
Falls at that point in the orbit when
the North Pole is aimed most directly
towards the Sun
six months later the winter solstice
marks that point when the North Pole is
aimed most directly away from the Sun
and logically enough the reason that day
and night are of exactly equal length
all over the planet on the spring and
Autumn equinoxes is that these Mark the
two points when the Earth's axis of
rotation lies broadside onto the Sun let
us now take a look at a strange and
beautiful phenomenon of celestial
mechanics this phenomenon is known as
the precession of the equinoxes it has
rigid and repetitive mathematical
qualities that can be analyzed and
predicted precisely it is however
extremely difficult to observe and even
harder to measure accurately without
sophisticated instrumentation in this
there may lie a clue to one of the great
Mysteries of the past
chapter 29 the first crack in an ancient
code
the plane of the Earth's orbit projected
outwards to form a great circle in the
celestial sphere is known as the
ecliptic
ringed around the ecliptic in a starry
belt that extends approximately seven
degrees north and south are the 12
constellations of the zodiac Ares Taurus
Gemini cancer Leo Virgo Libra Scorpius
Sagittarius capricornus Aquarius and
Pisces
these constellations are irregular in
size shape and distribution nevertheless
and one assumes by chance they're
spacing around the rim of the ecliptic
is sufficiently even to bestow a sense
of cosmic order upon the diurnal risings
and settings of the Sun
to picture what is involved here do the
following 1. Mark a dot in the center of
a blank sheet of paper
2. draw a circle around the dot about
half an inch away from it three enclose
that Circle in a second larger Circle
the dot represents the Sun the smaller
of the two concentric circles represents
the Earth's orbit the larger Circle
represents the rim of the ecliptic
around the perimeter of this larger
Circle therefore you should now draw 12
boxes spacing them evenly to represent
the constellations of the zodiac
since there are 360 degrees in a circle
each constellation can be considered to
occupy a space of 30 degrees along the
ecliptic the dot is the sun the inner of
the two concentric circles is the
Earth's orbit we know that the Earth
travels on this orbit in an
anti-clockwise direction from the West
towards the east and that every 24 hours
it also makes one complete rotation
around its own axis again from the West
towards the east from these two
movements two Illusions result
one
each day as the planet turns from west
to east the sun which is of course a
fixed Point appears to move across the
sky from east to west two roughly every
30 days as the spinning Earth Journeys
along its orbital path around the sun
the sun itself slowly appears to pass
through one after another of The Twelve
zodiacal constellations which are also
fixed points and again it appears to be
moving in an East-West Direction
on any particular day of the year in
other words corresponding on our diagram
to any point we care to choose around
the inner concentric Circle marking the
Earth's orbit it is obvious that the sun
will lie between an observer on the
earth and one of the twelve zodiacal
constellations on that day what the
Observer will see so long as he or she
is up and about well Before Dawn is the
sun rising in the east in the portion of
the sky occupied by that particular
constellation
beneath the clear and unpolluted heavens
of the ancient world it is easy to
understand how human beings might have
felt reassured by regular Celestial
motions such as these it is equally easy
to understand why the four cardinal
points of the year the spring and Autumn
equinoxes the winter and summer
solstices should everywhere have been
accorded immense significance even
greater significance was accorded to the
conjunction of these cardinal points
with the zodiacal constellations but
most significant of all was the
constellation in which the sun was
observed to rise on the morning of the
spring or vernal equinox
because of the Earth's axial procession
the Ancients discovered that this
constellation was not fixed or permanent
for all time but that the honor of
housing or carrying the sun on the day
of the vernal equinox circulated very
very slowly among all the constellations
of the zodiac
in the words of Giorgio de santiliana
the sun's position among the
constellations at the vernal equinox was
the pointer that indicated the hours of
the precessional cycle very long hours
indeed the equinoxual sun occupying each
zodiacal constellation for almost 2 200
years
the direction of the Earth's slow axial
precession is clockwise that is from
east to west and thus in opposition to
the direction of the planet's annual
path around the Sun
in relation to the constellations of the
zodiac lying fixed in space this causes
the point at which the Spring Equinox
occurs to move stubbornly along the
ecliptic in the opposite direction to
the yearly course of the Sun that is
against the right sequence of the
zodiacal signs Taurus Aries Pisces
Aquarius instead of Aquarius Pisces
Aries Taurus
that in a nutshell is the meaning of
precession of the equinoxes and that is
exactly what is involved in the notion
of the dawning of the age of Aquarius
the famous lion from the musical hair
refers to the fact that every year for
the last two thousand years or so the
sun has risen in Pisces on the vernal
equinox
age of Pisces however is now approaching
its end and the Vernal sun will soon
pass out of the sector of the fish and
begin to rise against the new background
of Aquarius
the 25
776-year cycle of precession is the
engine that drives this Majestic
Celestial Juggernaut along its
never-ending tour of the heavens but the
details of exactly how precession moves
the equinoxual points from Pisces into
Aquarius and that's onwards around the
Zodiac are also worth knowing
remember that the equinoxes occur on the
only two occasions in the year when the
Earth's tilted axis lies broadside onto
the sun these are when the Sun rises due
east all over the world and day and
night are of equal length
because the Earth's axis is slowly but
surely precessing in a direction
opposite to that of its own orbit the
points at which it lies broadside onto
the sun must occur fractionally earlier
in the orbit each year these annual
changes are so small as to be almost
imperceptible a one degree shift along
the ecliptic equivalent to the width of
your little finger held up to the
Horizon requires approximately 72 years
to complete however as the Santa Yana
points out such minute changes add up in
just under 2 200 years to a 30 degree
Passage through a complete House of the
zodiac and in just under 26 000 years to
a 360 degree Passage through a complete
cycle of procession
when did the Ancients first work out
precession
in the answer to this question lies a
great secret and mystery
before we try to penetrate the mystery
and to learn the secret we should
acquaint ourselves with the official
line
the Encyclopedia Britannica is as good a
repository as any of conventional
historical wisdom and this is what it
tells us about a scholar named
hipparchus the supposed discoverer of
precession
hipparchus born nicaea
died after 127 BC roads Greek astronomer
and mathematician who discovered
the precession of the equinoxes
this notable Discovery was the result of
painstaking observations worked upon by
an acute mind hipparchus observed the
positions of the stars and then compared
his results with those of timocharis of
Alexandria about 150 years earlier and
with even earlier observations made in
Babylonia
he discovered that the celestial
longitudes were different and that this
difference was of a magnitude exceeding
that attributable to errors of
observation
he therefore proposed precession to
account for the size of the difference
and he gave a value of 45 or 46 seconds
of Arc for annual changes this is very
close to the figure of 50.274 seconds of
Arc accepted today
first a point of terminology seconds of
Arc are the smallest subdivisions of a
degree of Arc there are 60 of these Arc
seconds in one arc minute 60 Minutes in
one degree and 360 degrees in the full
circle of Earth's path around the Sun
an annual change of 50.274 seconds of
Arc represents a distance somewhat under
1 60th of one degree so that it takes
roughly 72 years an entire human
lifetime where the equinoxual sun to
migrate just one degree along the
ecliptic it is because of the
observational difficulties entailed in
detecting this snail's pace rate of
change that the value worked out by
hipparchus in the 2nd Century BC is
hailed in the Britannica as a notable
discovery
would this discovery seem so notable if
it turned out to be a rediscovery would
the mathematical and astronomical
achievements of the Greeks shine so
brightly if we could prove that the
difficult challenge of measuring
precession had been taken up thousands
of years before hipparchus what if this
heavenly cycle almost 26 000 years long
had been made the object of precise
scientific investigations long epochs
before the supposed dawn of scientific
thought
in seeking answers to such questions
there is much that may be relevant which
would never be accepted by any court of
law as concrete proof that has not
accept it either we have seen that
hippocus proposed a value of 45 or 46
seconds of Arc for one year of
precessional motion let us therefore not
attempt to dislodge the Greek astronomer
from his pedestal as the discoverer of
recession unless we can find a
significantly more accurate value
recorded in a significantly more ancient
source
of course there are many potential
sources at this point however in the
interests of succinctness we shall limit
our inquiry to Universal myths we've
already examined one group of myths in
detail the traditions of flood and
cataclysm set out in part four and we've
seen that they possess a range of
intriguing characteristics
one there is no doubt that they are
immensely old take the Mesopotamian
flood story versions of which have been
found inscribed on tablets from the
earliest strata of Sumerian history
around 3000 BC these tablets handed down
from the dawn of the recorded past leave
no room for doubt that the tradition of
a world-destroying flood was ancient
even then and therefore originated long
before the dawn we cannot say how long
the fact remains that no scholar has
ever been able to establish a date for
the creation of any myth let alone for
these venerable and widespread
traditions in a very real sense they
seem all wish to have been around part
of the permanent baggage of human
culture
two the possibility cannot be ruled out
that this Aura of vast Antiquity is not
an illusion on the contrary we've heard
that many of the Great myths of
cataclysm seem to contain accurate
eyewitness accounts of real conditions
experienced by Humanity during the last
ice age in theory therefore these
stories could have been constructed at
almost the same time as the emergence of
our subspecies Homo sapiens sapiens
perhaps as long as 50 000 years ago the
geological evidence however suggests a
more recent provenance and we have
identified the epoch 15
000 to 8000 BC as the most likely only
then in the whole of human experience
where their rapid climatic changes on
the convulsive scale the myths so
eloquently describe
3. the Ice Age and its tumultuous
demands were a global phenomena
it is therefore perhaps not surprising
that the cataclysm traditions of many
different cultures widely scattered
around the globe should be characterized
by a high degree of uniformity and
convergence
4. what is surprising however is that
the myths not only describe shared
experiences but that they do so in what
appears to be a shared symbolic language
same literary motifs keep propping up
again and again the same stylistic props
the same recognizable characters and the
same plots
according to Professor de santillana
this type of uniformity suggests a
guiding hand at work
in Hamlet's Mill a seminal and original
thesis on ancient myth written in
collaboration with hertha Von deschen
professor of the history of science at
Frankfurt University he argues that
universality is in itself a test when
coupled with a firm design
when something found say in China turns
up also in Babylonian astrological texts
then it must be assumed to be relevant
if it reveals a complex of uncommon
images which nobody could claim had
risen independently by spontaneous
generation
take the origin of music
Orpheus and his harrowing death may be a
poetic creation born in more than one
instance in diverse places
but when characters who do not play the
liar but blow pipes get themselves
flayed alive for various absurd reasons
and their identical end is rehearsed on
several continents then we feel we have
got hold of something for such stories
cannot be linked by internal sequence
and when the Pied Piper turns up both in
the German myth of Hamelin and in Mexico
long before Columbus and is linked in
both places to certain attributes like
the color red it can hardly be a
coincidence likewise when one finds
numbers like 108 or 9 multiplied by 13
reappearing under several multiples in
The Vedas in the temples of Angkor in
Babylon in heraclitus's dark utterances
and also in the Norse Valhalla it is not
accident
connecting the great Universal myths of
cataclysm is it possible that such
coincidences that cannot be coincidences
and accidents that cannot be accidents
could denote the global influence of an
ancient though as yet unidentified
guiding hand
if so could it be that same hand during
and after the last ice age which drew
the series of highly accurate and
technically Advanced world maps reviewed
in part one and might not that same hand
have left its ghostly fingerprints on
another body of universal myths those
concerning the death and resurrection of
gods and great trees around which the
Earth and Heavens turn and whirlpools
and churns and drills and other similar
revolving grinding contrivances
according to santiliana and Von deschen
all such images refer to celestial
events and do so furthermore in the
refined technical language of an archaic
but immensely sophisticated astronomical
and mathematical science
this language ignores local beliefs and
Cults it concentrates on numbers motions
measures overall frames schemas on the
structure of numbers on Geometry
where could such a language have come
from
Hamlet's Mill is a Labyrinth of
brilliant but deliberately evasive
scholarship and offers us no
straightforward answer to this question
here and there however almost with
embarrassment inconclusive hints are
dropped for example at one point the
authors say that the scientific language
or code they believe they have
identified is of awe-inspiring Antiquity
on another occasion they pinned down the
depth of this Antiquity more precisely
to a period at least 6 000 years before
Virgil in other words 8 000 years ago or
more
what civilization known to history could
have developed and made use of a
sophisticated technical language more
than 8 000 years ago the honest answer
to this question is none followed by a
Frank admission that what is being
conjectured is nothing less than a
forgotten episode of high technological
culture in prehistoric times
once again Santa Yana and vondeshin are
elusive when it comes to the crunch
speaking only of the Legacy we all owe
to some almost unbelievable ancestor
civilization that first dared to
understand the world as created
according to number measure and weight
the Legacy it is clear has to do with
scientific thinking and complex
information of a mathematical nature
because it is so extremely old however
the passage of time has dissipated it
when the Greeks Came Upon the scene the
dust of centuries had already settled
upon the remains of this great worldwide
archaic Construction
yet something of it survived in
traditional rights in myths and fairy
tales no longer understood
these are tantalizing fragments of a
lost hole they make one think of those
missed Landscapes of which Chinese
painters are Masters which show here a
rock here a Gable they're the tip of a
tree and leave the rest to imagination
even when the code shall have yielded
when the techniques shall be known we
cannot expect to gauge the thought of
these remote ancestors of ours wrapped
as it is in its symbols since the
creating ordering Minds that devise the
symbols have banished forever
what we have here therefore are two
distinguished professors of the history
of science from esteemed universities on
both sides of the Atlantic claiming to
have discovered the remnants of a coded
scientific language many thousands of
years older than the oldest human
civilizations identified by scholarship
moreover though generally cautious
santiliada and vondesh and also claim to
have broken part of that code
this is an extraordinary statement for
two serious academics to have made
Chapter 30 the cosmic tree and the mill
of the Gods
in their brilliant and far-reaching
study Hamlet's Mill professors de Santa
Diana and vondeshand present a
formidable array of mythical and
iconographic evidence to demonstrate the
existence of a curious phenomenon
with some inexplicable reason at some
unknown date it seems that certain
archaic myths from all over the world
were co-opted no other word will really
do to serve as vehicles for a body of
complex technical data concerning the
precession of the equinoxes the
importance of this astonishing thesis as
one leading Authority on ancient
measurement has pointed out is that it
has fired the first Salvo in what may
prove to be a copernican revolution in
current conceptions of the development
of human culture
Hamlet's Mill was published in 1969 so
the revolution has been a long time
coming
during this period however the book has
been neither widely distributed among
the general public nor widely understood
by Scholars of the remote past
this state of affairs has not come about
because of Any inherent problems or
weaknesses in the work instead in the
words of Martin Vernal professor of
government studies at Cornell University
it has happened because few
archaeologists egyptologists and aged
historians have the combination of time
effort and skill necessary to take on
the very technical arguments of De Santa
Jana what those arguments predominantly
concern is the recurrent and persistent
transmission of a pre-sessional message
in a wide range of ancient myths and
strangely enough many of the key images
and symbols that crop up in these myths
notably those that concern a derangement
of the heavens are also to be found
embedded in the ancient traditions of
worldwide cataclysm reviewed in chapters
24 and 25.
in Norse mythology for example we saw
how the wolf fenrir whom the gods had so
carefully chained up broke his bonds at
last and Escape he shook himself and the
world trembled
tremble the ash tree igdrasil was shaken
from its roots to its topmost branches
mountains crumbled or split from top to
bottom the Earth began to lose its shape
already the stars were coming adrift in
the sky
in the opinion of De Santa Yana and Von
deschend this myth mixes The Familiar
theme of catastrophe with the quite
separate theme of precession on the one
hand we have an Earthly disaster on a
scale that seems to dwarf even the flood
of Noah on the other we hear that
ominous changes are taking place in the
heavens and that the Stars which have
come adrift in the sky are dropping into
the void
such Celestial imagery repeated again
and again with only relatively minor
variations in myths from many different
parts of the world belongs to a category
earmarked in Hamlet's Mill as Not Mere
storytelling of the kind that comes
natural
moreover the Norse Traditions that speak
of the Monstrous wolf fenril and of the
shaking of ygdrasil go on to report the
final Apocalypse in which the forces of
Valhalla issue forth on the side of
order to participate in the terrible
last battle of the gods a battle that
will end in apocalyptic destruction
500 doors and 40 there are I wean in
valhalla's walls 800 Fighters through
each door Fair went to war with the wolf
they go
with a lightness of touch that is almost
subliminal this verse has encouraged us
to count valhalla's Fighters thus
momentarily obliging us to focus our
attention on their total number
540 multiplied by 800 equals 432
000.
this total as we shall see in chapter 31
is mathematically linked to the
phenomenon of precession it is unlikely
to have found its way into Norse
Mythology by accident especially in a
context that has previously specified a
derangement of the heavens severe enough
to have caused the Stars to come adrift
from their stations in the sky
to understand what is going on here it's
essential to grasp the basic imagery of
the ancient message that santilana and
Von dashen claim to have stumbled upon
this imagery transforms the Luminous
Dome of the celestial sphere into a vast
and intricate piece of machinery and
like a mill wheel like a churn like a
Whirlpool like a corn this machine turns
and turns and turns endlessly its
motions being calibrated all the time by
the sun which Rises first in one
constellation of the zodiac then in
another and so on all the year round
the four key points of the year are the
Springer daughter equinoxes and the
winter and summer solstices at each
point naturally the sun is seen to rise
in a different constellation thus if the
sun rises in Pisces at the Spring
Equinox as it does at present it must
rise in Virgo at the Autumn Equinox in
Gemini at the winter solstice and in
Sagittarius at the summer solstice on
each of these four occasions for the
last two thousand years or so this is
exactly what the sun has been doing as
we've seen however precession of the
equinoxes means that the Vernal point
will change in the not so distant future
from Pisces to Aquarius when that
happens the three other constellations
marking the three other key points will
change as well from Virgo Gemini and
Sagittarius to Leo Taurus and Scorpius
almost as though the giant mechanism of
Heaven has ponderously switched gears
this instinctively suggests a straight
upright post but that would be an
oversimplification
in the mythical context it is best not
to think of the axis in analytical terms
one line at a time but to consider it
and the frame to which it is connected
as a whole
as radius automatically calls Circle to
mine so axis should invoke the two
determining great circles on the surface
of the sphere the equinoxual and
solstitial colluras
these colors are the imaginary Hoops
intersecting at the celestial North Pole
which connect the two equinoxual points
on the earth's path around the Sun that
is where it stands on the 20th of March
and the 22nd of September and the two
solstitial points where it stands on the
21st of June and the 21st of December
the implication is that the rotation of
the Polar axis must not be disjointed
from the great circles that shift along
with it in heaven framework is thought
of as all one with the axis
santiliana and Von deschender are
certain that what confronts us here is
not a belief but an allegory they insist
that the notion of a spherical frame
composed of two intersecting Hoops
suspended from an axis is not under any
circumstances to be understood as the
way in which ancient science envisaged
the cosmos instead it is to be seen as a
thought tool designed to focus the minds
of people bright enough to crack the
code upon the hard to detect
astronomical fact of precession of the
equinoxes it is a thought tool that
keeps on cropping up in numerous
disguises all over the myths of the
ancient world
at the Mill with slaves
one example from Central America which
also provides a further illustration of
the Curious symbolic crossovers between
myths of precession and myths of
catastrophe was summarized by Diego de
Lambda in the 16th century
among the multitude of gods worshiped by
these people the Maya were for whom they
called by the name baka
these were they say Four Brothers placed
by God when he created the world at its
Four Corners to sustain the heavens lest
they fall they also say that these
backups escaped when the world was
destroyed by a deluge
it is the opinion of santiliana and Von
deschan that the Mayan astronomer
priests did not subscribe for a moment
to the simple-minded notion that the
Earth was flat with four corners instead
they say the image of the four backups
is used as a technical allegory intended
to shed light on the phenomenon of
procession of the equinoxes
the backup stand in short for the system
of coordinates of an astrological age
they represent the equinoxual and
sawstitial colluras Binding Together the
four constellations in which the sun
continues to rise at the spring and
Autumn equinoxes and at the winter and
summer solstices or epochs of just under
2 200 years of course it is understood
that when the gears of Heaven change the
old age comes crashing down and a new
age is born all this so far is routine
processional imagery what stands out
however is the explicit linkage to an
Earthly disaster in this case a flood
which the backups survive it may also be
relevant that relief carvings at Chichen
Itza unmistakably represent the backups
as being bearded and of European
appearance
be that as it may the backup image
linked to a number of badly
misunderstood references to the four
corners of Heaven the quadrangular Earth
and so on is only one among many that
seem to have been designed to serve as
thought tools for precession archetypal
amongst these is of course the mill of
santiliana's title Hamlet's Mill
it turns out that the Shakespearean
character whom the poet made one of us
the first unhappy intellectual conceals
a past as a legendary being his features
predetermined pre-shaped by
long-standing myth
in all of his many incarnations this
Hamlet remains
strangely himself
the original amlodi or sometimes amleth
as his name was in Icelandic Legend
shows the same characteristics of
melancholy and high intellect he too is
a son dedicated to avenge his father a
speaker of cryptic but inescapable
truths an elusive carrier of Fate who
must yield once his mission is
accomplished
in the crude and vivid imagery of the
Norse amlodi was identified with the
ownership of a fabled mill or quern
which in its time ground out gold and
peace and plenty
in many of the Traditions two giant
maidens Fenger and menja were indentured
to turn this great Contraption which
could not be budged by any human
strength something went wrong and the
two giantesses were forced to work day
and night with no rest
fourth to the mill bench they were
brought to set the gray stone in motion
he gave them no rest nor peace attentive
to the creek of the mill their song was
a howl shattering silence
lower the bin and lighten the stones yet
he would have them grind more
rebellious and angry fenja and menja
waited until everyone was asleep
and then began to turn the mill in a Mad
World until its great props though cased
in Iron best a Sunday
immediately afterwards in a confusing
episode The Mill was stolen by a sea
king named my singer and loaded aboard
his ship together with the giantesses
meisenger ordered the pair to grind the
game but this time they ground out salt
at midnight they asked him whether he
was not weary of salt he paid them grind
longer they had ground but a little
longer when down sank the ship the huge
props flew off the bin the iron rivets
burst the shaft tree shivered the bin
shot down when it reached the Bottom of
the Sea The Mill continued to turn but
it ground out Rock and Sand creating a
vast Whirlpool the Maelstrom
such images Santa lyanna and vondesh and
assert signify precession of the
equinoxes the axis and iron props of the
mill stand for a system of coordinates
in the celestial sphere and represent
the frame of a world age actually the
frame defines a world age because the
polar axis and the Colliers form an
invisible hole the entire frame is
thrown out of kilter if one part of it
is moved
when that happens a new pole star with
appropriate Colliers of its own must
replace the obsolete apparatus
furthermore the engulfing whirlpool
belongs to the stocking trade of ancient
Fable it appears in The Odyssey as
charybdis in The Straits of Messina and
again in other cultures in the Indian
Ocean and the Pacific it is found there
too curiously enough with an overhanging
fig tree to whose bows the hero can
cling as the ship goes down whether it
be satyavata in India or Kai in Tonga
the Persistence of detail rules out free
invention such stories have belonged to
the cosmographical literature since
antiquity
the appearance of the whirlpool in
Homer's Odyssey which is a compilation
of Greek myths more than 3000 years old
should not surprise us because the great
Mill of Icelandic Legend appears there
also and does so moreover in familiar
circumstances
it is the last night before the decisive
confrontation
Odysseus bent on Revenge has landed at
Ithaca and is hiding under the magical
spell of the goddess Athena which
protects him from recognition
Odysseus prays to Zeus to send him an
encouraging sign before the great ordeal
straight away Zeus thundered from
shining Olympus and goodly Odysseus was
glad moreover a woman a grinder at the
Mill uttered a voice of omen from within
the house hard by where stood the Mills
of The Shepherd of the people
at these hand Mills 12 women in all
applied their task making meal of barley
and of wheat the marrow of men now all
the others were asleep for they had
ground out their task of grain but this
one alone rested not yet being the
weakest of all she now stayed her Quin
and spake the word
May the enemies of Odysseus on this day
for the last time make their sweet
feasting in his Halls they that have
loosened my knees with cruel toil to
grind their barley meal may they now sub
their last
sentiliana and vondesh and argue that it
is no accident that the allegory of the
orb of Heaven that turns around like a
millstone and ever does something bad
also makes an appearance in the biblical
tradition of Samson ilus in Gaza at the
Mill with slaves his merciless captors
unbind him
so that he can make sport for them in
their Temple instead with his last
strength he takes hold of the middle
pillars of that great structure and
brings the whole edifice crashing down
killing everybody
like Fenger and menja he gets his
revenge
the theme resurfaces in Japan in Central
America among the maoris of New Zealand
and in the myths of Finland there the
Hamlet Samson figure is known as culervo
and the mill has a peculiar name the
sampo like Fenger and menger's Mill it
is ultimately stolen and loaded on board
a ship and like their Mill it ends up
being broken in pieces
it turns out that the word sampo has its
origins in the Sanskrit scamba meaning
pillar or Pole and in the athava Vader
one of the most ancient pieces of North
Indian literature we find an entire hymn
dedicated to the scamba in whom Earth
atmosphere in whom sky is set where fire
Moon Sun wind stand fixed the scamba
sustains both Heaven and Earth the
scamba sustains the wide atmosphere the
scamba sustains the Six Wide directions
into the scamba entered all existence
Whitney the translator athava Vader 10 7
comments in some perplexity scamba
literally prop support pillow
strangely used in this hymn as frame of
the universe
yet with an awareness of the complex of
ideas linking Cosmic Mills and
whirlpools and World trees and so on the
archaic Vedic usage should not seem so
strange what is being signaled here as
in all the other allegories is the frame
of a world age that same Heavenly
mechanism that turns for more than 2 000
years with the sun rising always in the
same four cardinal points and then
slowly shifts those Celestial
coordinates to four new constellations
for the next couple of thousand years
this is why the mill always breaks why
the huge props always fly off the bin in
one way or another why the iron rivets
burst why the shaft tree Shivers
precession of the equinoxes merits such
imagery because and widely separated
intervals of time it does indeed change
or break the stabilizing coordinates of
the entire celestial sphere
openers of the way
what is remarkable about all this is the
way that the mill which continues to
serve as an allegory for Cosmic
processes stubbornly keeps on
resurfacing all over the world even
where the context has been jumbled or
lost indeed in santileana and from
deschan's argument it doesn't really
matter if the context is lost the
particular Merit of mythical terminology
they say is that it can be used as a
vehicle for handing down solid knowledge
independently from the degree of insight
of the people who do the actual telling
of stories fables Etc
what matters in other words is that
certain Central imagery should survive
and continue to be passed on in
retellings however far these May Drift
from the original storyline
an example of such drift
coupled with the retention of essential
imagery and information is found among
the Cherokees whose name for the Milky
Way our own Galaxy is where the dog ran
in ancient times according to Cherokee
tradition the people in the South had a
corn Mill from which meal was stolen
again and again in due course the owners
discovered the thief a dog who ran off
howling to his home in the north with
the meal dropping from his mouth as he
ran and leaving a white Trail where now
we see the Milky Way which the Cherokee
called to this day where the dog ran
in Central America one of the many myths
concerning Quetzalcoatl depicts him
playing a key role in the Regeneration
of mankind After the all-destroying
flood that ended the fourth son
together with his dog-headed companion
zolotl he descends into the underworld
to retrieve the skeletons of the people
killed by the deluge this he succeeds in
doing after tricking miklantalucci the
god of death and the bones are brought
to a place called tamoanchan there like
corn they are milled into a fine meal on
a grindstone upon this ground meal the
gods then release blood thus creating
the Flesh of the current age of men
santiliana and Von dashen do not think
that the presence of a canine character
in both the above variants of the myth
of the cosmic Mill is likely to be
accidental they point out that culevo
the Finnish Hamlet is also accompanied
by the Black Dog musty likewise after
his return to his Estates in Ithaca
Odysseus is first recognized by his
faithful dog and as anyone who has been
to Sunday school will remember Samson is
associated with foxes 300 of them to be
precise which are members of the dog
family in the Danish version of the
amleth Hamlet Saga amlith went on and a
wolf crossed his path amid the thicket
last but not least an alternative
recession of the culevo story from
Finland as the hero rather weirdly being
sent to Estonia to bark under the fence
He barked one year
santiliana and Von Dash and are
confident that all this doggishness is
purposive another piece of the ancient
code as yet unbroken persistently
tapping out its message from place to
place
they list these and many other canine
symbols among a series of morphological
markers which they have identified as
likely to suggest the presence in
ancient myths of scientific information
concerning procession of the equinoxes
these markers may have had meanings of
their own or been intended simply to
alert the target audience that a piece
of hard data was coming up in the story
being told
beguilingly sometimes they may also have
been designed to serve as openers of the
way conduits to enable initiates to
follow the trail of scientific
information from one myth to another
thus even though none of the familiar
Mills and whirlpools is in sight we
should perhaps sit up and pay attention
when we learn that Orion the great
hunter of Greek myth was the owner of a
dog
when Orion tried to Ravish the Virgin
goddess Artemis she produced a scorpion
from the earth which killed him and the
dog Orion was transported to the skies
where he became the constellation that
bears his name today his dog was
transformed into Sirius the dog star
precisely the same identification of
Sirius was made by the ancient Egyptians
who linked the Orion constellation
specifically to their god Osiris
it is in ancient Egypt too that the
character of the faithful Celestial dog
achieves its fullest and most explicit
mythical elaboration in the form of
upwards a jackal-headed deity whose name
means opener of the waves
if we follow this way opener to Egypt
turn our eyes to the constellation of
Orion and enter the potent myth of
Osiris we find ourselves enveloped in a
net of familiar symbols
The Listener will recall that the myth
presents Osiris as the victim of a plot
the conspirators initially dispose of
him by sealing him in a box and casting
him a drift on the Waters of the Nile
in this respect does he not resemble
utnapistim and Noah and koshishly and
all the other Deluge heroes in their
arcs or boxes or chests riding out the
Waters of the flood
another familiar element is the classic
pre-sessional image of the world tree
and or roof pillar in this case combined
the myth tells us how Osiris still
sealed inside his Coffer is carried out
into the sea and washed up at biblos the
waves lay him to rest among the branches
of a tamarisk tree which rapidly grows
to a magnificent size enclosing the
Coffer within its trunk
the king of the country who much admires
the tamarisk tree cuts it down and
Fashions the part which contains Osiris
into a roof pillar for his Palace later
Isis the wife of Osiris removes her
husband's body from the pillar and takes
it back to Egypt to undergo rebirth
the Osiris myth also includes certain
key numbers
whether by accident or by Design these
numbers give access to a science of
procession as we shall see in the next
chapter
31 the Osiris numbers
archaeo astronomer Jane B sellers who
studied egyptology at the University of
Chicago's Oriental Institute spends her
Winters in Portland Maine and summers at
Ripley neck the 19th century Enclave
down east on Maine's Rocky Coast
there she says the night skies can be as
clear as the desert and no one Minds if
you read the pyramid texts out loud to
the seagulls
one of the few serious Scholars to have
tested the theory Advanced by santidiana
and vondesh and in Hamlet's Mill
ERS has been hailed for having drawn
attention to the need to use astronomy
and more particularly procession for the
proper study of ancient Egypt and its
religion
in her words
archaeologists by and large lack an
understanding of precession and this
affects their conclusions concerning
ancient myths ancient gods and Ancient
Temple alignments for astronomers
precession is a well-established fact
those working in the field of ancient
man have a responsibility to attain an
understanding of it
it is seller's contention eloquently
expressed in her book The Death of gods
in ancient Egypt that the Osiris myth
may have been deliberately encoded with
a group of key numbers that are excess
baggage as far as the narrative is
concerned but that offer an eternal
calculus by which surprisingly exact
values can be derived for the following
one the time required for the Earth's
slow precessional wobble to cause the
position of sunrise on the vernal
equinox to complete a shift of one
degree along the ecliptic in relation to
the Stellar background
two the time required for the sun to
pass through one full zodiacal segment
of 30 degrees
three the time required for the sun to
pass through two full zodical segments
totaling 60 degrees
4. the time required to bring about the
great return that is for the sun to
shift 360 Degrees along the ecliptic
thus fulfilling one complete
precessional cycle or great year
Computing the great return
the precessional numbers highlighted by
sellers in the Osiris myth are 360
72
30
and 12. most of them are found in a
section of the myth which provides us
with biographical details of the various
characters
these have been conveniently summarized
by E A Wallace budge formerly keeper of
Egyptian Antiquities at the British
museum
the goddess nut wife of the Sun God Ra
was beloved by the god Geb when ra
discovered the Intrigue he cursed his
wife and declared that she should not be
delivered of a child in any month of any
year then the God Thoth who also loved
Newt played at tables with the moon and
one from her five whole days
these he joined to the 360 days of which
the year then consisted
on the first of these five days Osiris
was brought forth and at the moment of
his birth a voice was heard to Proclaim
that the Lord of creation was born
elsewhere the myth informs us that the
360 day year consists of 12 months of 30
days each and in general as sellers
observes phrases are used which prompt
simple mental calculations and an
attention to numbers
thus far we have been provided with
three of sellers processional numbers
360 12 and 30. the fourth number which
occurs later in the text is by far the
most important
as we saw in chapter 9 the evil deity
known as set led a group of conspirators
in a plot to kill Osiris the number of
these conspirators was 72
with this last number in hand suggests
sellers we are now in a position to boot
up and set running an ancient computer
program
12 equals the number of constellations
in the Zodiac 30 equals the number of
degrees allocated along the ecliptic to
each zodiacal constellation
72 equals the number of years required
for the equinoxual sun to complete a
processional shift of one degree along
the ecliptic 360 equals the total number
of degrees in the ecliptic 72 multiplied
by 30 equals
2160. the number of years required for
the sun to complete a passage of 30
degrees along the ecliptic in other
words to pass entirely through any one
of the 12 zodiacal constellations
2160 multiplied by 12 or 360 multiplied
by 72 equals twenty five thousand nine
hundred and twenty the number of years
in one complete pre-sessional cycle or
great year and thus the total number of
years required to bring about the great
return
other figures and combinations of
figures also emerge for example 36 the
number of years required for the
equinoxual sun to complete a
precessional shift of half a degree
along the ecliptic
4320 the number of years required for
the equinoxual sun to complete a
precessional shift of 60 degrees that is
two zodiacal constellations
these sellers believe constitute the
basic ingredients of a pre-sessional
code which appears again and again with
Eerie persistence in ancient myths and
sacred architecture in common with much
esoteric numerology it is a code in
which it is permissible to shift decimal
points to left or right at will and to
make use of almost any conceivable
combinations permutations
multiplications divisions and fractions
of the essential numbers all of which
relate precisely to the rate of
precession of the equinoxes the
preeminent number in the code is 72. to
this is frequently added 36 making 108
and it is permissible to multiply 108 by
100 to get 10 800 or to divide it by two
to get 54 which may then be multiplied
by 10 and expressed as 540 or as 54 000
or as five hundred and forty thousand or
as five million four hundred thousand
and so on
also highly significant is two thousand
one hundred and sixty the number of
years required for the equinoxual point
to Transit one zodiacal constellation
which is sometimes multiplied by 10 and
by factors of 10 to give two hundred and
sixteen thousand two million one hundred
and sixty thousand and so on and
sometimes by two to give four thousand
three hundred and twenty or 432
000 or 4 320 000 add infinitum
better than hippocus
if sellers is correct in her hypothesis
that the calculus needed to produce
these numbers was deliberately encoded
into the Osiris myth to convey
precessional information to initiates we
are confronted by an intriguing anomaly
if they are indeed about precession the
numbers are out of place in time the
science they contain is too advanced for
them to have been calculated by any
known civilization of antiquity
let us not forget that they occur in a
myth which is present at the very dawn
of writing in Egypt indeed elements of
the Osiris story are to be found in the
pyramid texts dating back to around
2450 BC in a context which suggests that
they were exceedingly old even then
eparchus the so-called discoverer of
precession lived in the 2nd Century BC
he proposed a value of 45 or 46 seconds
of Arc for one year of processional
motion these figures yield a one degree
shift along the ecliptic in 80 years at
45 Arc seconds per annum and in
78.26 years at 46 Arc seconds per annum
the true figure as calculated by modern
science is 71.6 years
if seller's theory is correct therefore
the Osiris numbers which give a value of
72 years are significantly more accurate
than those of hippocus indeed within the
obvious confines imposed by narrative
structure it is difficult to see how the
number 72 could have been improved upon
even if the more precise figure had been
known to the ancient mythmakers one can
hardly insert
71.6 conspiratives into a story but 72
will fit comfortably
working from this rounded up figure the
Osiris myth is capable of yielding a
value of
2160 years for a pre-sessional shift
through one complete House of the zodiac
the correct figure according to today's
calculations is
2148 years the hipparchus figures are
2400 years and 2
347.8 years respectively finally Osiris
enables us to calculate twenty five
thousand nine hundred and twenty as the
number of years required for the
Fulfillment of a complete precessional
cycle through 12 houses of the zodiac
hippocus gives us either 28 800 or 28
173.6 years
the correct figure by today's estimates
is twenty five thousand seven hundred
and seventy six years the hipparchus
calculations for the greater return are
therefore around 3 000 years out of
kilter the Osiris calculations missed
the true figure by only
144 Years and may well do so because the
narrative context forced a rounding up
of the base number from the correct
value of 71.6 to a more workable figure
of 72. all this however assumes that
sellers is right to suppose that the
number is 360. 72 30 and 12 did not find
their way into the Osiris myth by chance
but were placed there deliberately by
people who understood and had accurately
measured precession
is sellers right
times of decay
the Osiris myth is not the only one to
incorporate the calculus for precession
the relevant numbers keep surfacing in
various forms multiples and combinations
all over the ancient world
an example was given in chapter 33 the
Norse myth of the 432 000 fighters who
sallied forth from Valhalla to do battle
with the wolf
a glance back at that myth shows that it
contains several permutations of
precessional numbers
likewise as we saw in chapter 24 ancient
Chinese traditions referring to a
universal cataclysm were said to have
been written down in a great text
consisting of precisely
4320 volumes
thousands of miles away is it a
coincidence that the Babylonian
historian berosa's 3rd Century BC
ascribed a total reign of 432
000 years to the mythical Kings who
ruled the land of Sumer Before the Flood
and is it likewise a coincidence that
this same birosis ascribed 2 million 160
000 years to the period between creation
and Universal catastrophe
do the myths of ancient amerindian
peoples like the Maya also contain or
enable us to compute numbers such as 72
2160 4320
Etc we shall probably never know thanks
to the Conquistadors and zealous Friars
who destroyed the traditional Heritage
of Central America and left us so little
to work
what we can say however is that the
relevant numbers do turn up in relative
profusion in the Mayan Long Count
calendar
details of that calendar were given in
chapter 21. the numerals necessary for
calculating precession are found there
in these Formula One cartoon equals 7
200 days one tune equals 360 days two
Tunes equals 720 days five back tunes
equals seven hundred and twenty thousand
days five cartoons equals thirty six
thousand days Six cartoons equals forty
three thousand two hundred days six
Toons equals two thousand one hundred
and sixty days 15 cartoons equals two
million one hundred and sixty Thousand
Days nor does it seem that seller's code
is confined to mythology in the jungles
of Cambodia the temple complex of Angkor
looks as though it could have been
purpose built as a precessional metaphor
it has for example five gates To Each of
which leads a road Bridging the
crocodile infested moat that surrounds
the whole site
each of these roads is bordered by a row
of gigantic Stone figures 108 per Avenue
54 on each side 540 statues in all and
each row carries a huge Naga serpent
furthermore as Santa Yana and rondashian
point out in Hamlet's Mill the figures
do not carry the serpent but are shown
to pull it which indicates that these
540 statues are churning the Milky ocean
the whole of Angkor thus turns out to be
a colossal model set up with true Hindu
fantasy and incongruousness to express
the idea of procession the same may be
true of Java's famous temple of
borobador with its 72 bell-shaped
stupors and perhaps also the megalith
the bar back in the Lebanon which are
thought to be the world's biggest blocks
of cut stone long pre-dating Roman and
Greek structures on the site the three
that make up the so-called trilathon are
as tall as five-story buildings and
weigh around 900 tons each a fourth
megalith is almost 80 feet in length and
weighs 1100 tons
amazingly these giant blocks were cut
perfectly shaped and somehow transported
to barbic from a quarry several miles
away
in addition they were skillfully
Incorporated at a considerable height
above ground level into the retaining
walls of a magnificent Temple this
Temple was surrounded by 54 Columns of
immense size and height
in the subcontinent of India where the
Orion constellation is known as
kalpurush meaning time man we find that
sellers of Cyrus numbers are transmitted
through a wide range of media in ways
increasingly difficult to ascribe to
chance
there are for instance 10 800 bricks in
the agnikayana the Indian fire altar
there are 10 800 stanzas in the Rick
Vader the most ancient of The Vedic
texts and a rich repository of Indian
mythology
each stanza is made up of 40 syllables
with the result that the entire
composition consists of 432
000 syllables no more no less
and in rigveda 1 164 a typical stanza we
read of the 12 spoked wheel in which 720
sons of Agni are established
in the Hebrew Kabbalah there are 72
Angels through whom the sephiroth Divine
Powers may be approached or invoked by
those who know their names of numbers
Rossi crucian tradition speaks of cycles
of 108 years 72 plus 36 According to
which the secret Brotherhood makes its
influence fell similarly the number 72
and its permutations and subdivisions
are of great significance to the Chinese
secret societies known as Triads an
ancient ritual requires that each
candidate for initiation pay a fee
including 360 cash for making clothes
108 cash for the purse 72 cash for
instruction and 36 cash for decapitating
the traitorous subject the cash the old
Universal brass coin of China with a
square hole in the center is of course
no longer in circulation but the numbers
passed down in the ritual since time
immemorial have survived thus in modern
Singapore candidates for Triad
membership pay an entrance fee which is
calculated according to their financial
circumstances
but which must always consist of
multiples of 1.80
3.60 seven dollars twenty cents ten
dollars eighty cents and thus
18.36.72 108 or 360 dollars seven
hundred twenty dollars one thousand and
eighty dollars and so on
of all the secret societies the most
mysterious and archaic by far is
undoubtedly the hung Lee which scholars
believe to be the depository of the old
religion of the Chinese
in one hung initiation ritual the
neophyte is put through a question and
answer session that goes what did you
see on your War
I saw two pots with red bamboo
do you know how many plants there were
in one plot were 36 and in the other 72
plants together 108.
did you take home some of them for your
use
yes I took home 108 plants
how can you prove that
I can prove it by a verse
how does this verse run
the red bamboo from Canton is rare in
the world in the Groves are 36 and 72
who in the world knows the meaning of
this
when we have set to work we will know
the secret
the atmosphere of intrigue that such
passages generate is accentuated by the
reticent behavior of the hung League
itself an organization resembling the
medieval European order of the Knights
Templar and the higher degrees of modern
Freemasonry in many ways that are beyond
the remit of this book to describe it is
intriguing too that the Chinese
character Hong composed of water and
many signifies inundation in other words
the flood
finally returning to India let us note
the content of the Sacred Scriptures
known as the puranas these speak of four
ages of the earth called yugas which
together are said to extend to twelve
thousand Divine years their respective
durations of these epochs in Divine
years are krita yoga
4800
treta Yuga
3600 davpara Yuga 2500
1200.
the puranas also tell us that one year
of The Mortals is equivalent to one day
of the Gods furthermore and exactly as
in the Osiris myth we discover that the
number of days in the years of both gods
and Mortals has been artificially set at
360 so one year of the Gods is
equivalent to 360 Mortal years
the Kali Yuga therefore at 1 200 years
of the Gods turns out to have a duration
of 432
000 mortal year one Maha Yuga or great
age made up of the twelve thousand
Divine years contained in the four
letter yugas is equivalent to four
million three hundred and twenty
thousand years of Mortals a thousand
such mahayugas which constitute a kalpa
or day of Brahma extend over 4 billion
320 million ordinary years again
supplying the digits for basic
processional calculations separately
there are manvantaras periods of Manu of
which we are told in the scriptures that
about 71 systems of four yugas elapsed
during each manvantara
The Listener will recall that one degree
of processional motion along the
ecliptic requires 71.6 years to complete
a number that can be rounded down to
about 71 in India just as easily as it
was rounded up to 72 in ancient Egypt
the Kali Yuga with a duration of 432 000
mortal years
is by the way our own
in the Carly age the scriptures say
shall Decay flourish until the human
race approaches annihilation
dogs uncles and revenge
it was a dog that brought us to these
decaying times
we came here by way of Sirius the dog
star who stands at the heel of the giant
constellation of Orion where it Towers
in the sky above Egypt in that land as
we've seen Orion is Osiris the god of
death and Resurrection whose numbers
perhaps by chance are 12 30 72 and 360
but can chance account for the fact that
these and other Prime integers of
precession keep cropping up in
supposedly unrelated mythologies from
all over the world and in such solid but
enduring Vehicles as calendar systems
and works of architecture
santiliana and vondesh and Jane Sellers
and a growing body of other Scholars
rule out chance arguing that the
Persistence of detail is indicative of a
guiding hand
if they are wrong we need to find some
other explanation for how such specific
and interrelated numbers the only
obvious function of which is to
calculate precession could by accident
have got themselves so widely imprinted
on human culture but suppose they are
not wrong
suppose that a guiding hand really was
at work behind the scenes
sometimes
when you slip into santillanas and
vondeshen's world of myth and mystery
you can almost feel the influence of
that hair
take the business of the dog or Jackal
or wolf or Fox
the subtle way this shadowy canine
slinks from myth to myth is peculiar
stimulating then baffling you always
luring you onwards
indeed it was this lure we followed from
the mill of amlodi to the myth of Osiris
in Egypt along the way according to the
design of the ancient sages if Sellers
santiliana and Von Dash and are right we
were first encouraged to build a clear
mental picture of the celestial sphere
second we were provided with a
mechanistic model so that we could
visualize the great changes procession
of the Equinox is periodically effects
in all the coordinates of the sphere
finally after allowing the dog Sirius to
open the way for us we were given the
figures to calculate precession more or
less exactly
nor is serious in his eternal station at
Orion's heel the only dogish character
around Osiris we saw in chapter 11 how
Isis who was both the wife and sister of
Osiris searched for her dead husband's
body after he'd been murdered by Seth
who incidentally was also her brother
and the brother of Osiris in this search
according to ancient tradition she was
assisted by dogs jackals in some
versions likewise mythological and
religious texts from all periods of
Egyptian history assert that the Jackal
god Anubis ministered to the spirit of
Osiris after his death and acted as his
guide through the underworld
surviving vignettes depict Anubis as
virtually identical in appearance to upu
out the opener of the waves
last but not least Osiris himself was
believed to have taken the form of a
wolf when he returned from the
underworld to assist his son Horus in
the final battle against set
investigating this kind of material one
sometimes has the spooky sense of being
manipulated by an ancient intelligence
which has found a way to reach out to us
across vast epochs of time and for some
reason has set us a puzzle to Seoul in
the language of myth
if it were just dogs that kept cropping
up again and again it would be easy to
brush off such weird intuitions
the dog phenomenon seems more likely to
be
coincidence than anything else
but it isn't just dogs
the ways between the two very different
myths of Osiris and unloady's Mill which
nonetheless both seem to contain
accurate scientific data about
procession of the equinoxes are kept
open by another strange common factor
family relationships are involved am
Lodi amleth Hamlet is always a son who
revenges the murder of his father by
entrapping and killing the murderer the
murderer furthermore is always the
father's own brother that is Hamlet's
uncle
this is precisely the scenario of the
Osiris myth Osiris and Seth are brothers
Seth murders Osiris or
son of Osiris then takes Revenge upon
his uncle
another twist is that the Hamlet
character often has some sort of
incestuous relationship with his sister
in the case of culevo the Finnish Hamlet
there's a poignant scene in which the
hero returning home after a long absence
meets a maiden in the woods Gathering
berries they lie together only later do
they discover that they are brother and
sister the maiden drowns herself at once
later with the black dog musty padding
along at his heels culervo wanders into
the forest and throws himself upon his
sword
there are no suicides in the Egyptian
myth of Osiris but there is the incest
of Osiris and his sister Isis out of
their Union is born Horus the Avenger
so once again it seems reasonable to ask
what is going on why are there all these
apparent links and connections why do we
have these strings of myths ostensibly
about different subjects all of which
prove capable in their own ways of
shedding light on the phenomenon of
precession of the equinoxes
and why do all these myths have dogs
running through them and characters who
seem unusually inclined to incest
fratricide and revenge it surely drives
skepticism Beyond its limits to suggest
that so many identical literary devices
could keep on turning up purely by
chance in so many different contexts if
not by chance however then who exactly
was responsible for creating this
intricate and clever connecting pattern
who were the authors and designers of
the puzzle and what motives might they
have had
scientists with something to say
whoever it was they must have been smart
smart enough to have observed the
infinitesimal creep of processional
motion along the ecliptic and to have
calculated its rate at a value uncannily
close to that obtained by today's
advanced technology
it therefore follows that we are talking
about highly civilized people indeed we
are talking about people who deserve to
be called scientists they must moreover
have lived in extremely remote Antiquity
because we can be certain that the
creation and dissemination of the common
Heritage of processional myths on both
sides of the Atlantic did not take place
in historic times on the contrary the
evidence suggests that all these myths
were tottering with age when what we
call history began about five thousand
years ago
the great strength of the ancient
stories was this as well as being
forever available for use and adaptation
free of copyright like intellectual
chameleons subtle and ambiguous they had
the capacity to change their color
according to their surround at different
times in different continents the
ancient Tales could be retold in a
variety of ways but would always retain
their essential symbolism and always
continue to transmit the coded
processional data they had been
programmed with at the outset but to
what end
as we'll see in the next chapter the
long slow cycles of precession are not
limited in their consequences to a
changing view of the sky
this Celestial phenomenon born of the
Earth's axial wobble has Direct effects
on the Earth itself in fact it appears
to be one of the principal correlates of
the sudden onset of ice ages and they're
equally sudden and catastrophic decay
chapter 32
speaking to The Unborn
it is understandable that a huge range
of myths from all over the ancient world
should describe geological catastrophes
in graphic detail mankind survived the
horror of the last icing and the most
plausible source for our enduring
traditions of flooding and freezing
massive volcanism and devastating
earthquakes is in the tumultuous
upheavals Unleashed during the Great
meltdown of fifteen thousand to eight
thousand BC
the final Retreat of the ice sheets and
the consequent 300 to 400 foot rise in
global sea levels took place only a few
thousand years before the beginning of
the historical period it is therefore
not surprising that all our early
civilizations should have retained Vivid
memories of the vast cataclysms that had
terrified their forefathers
much harder to explain is the peculiar
but distinctive way the myths of
cataclysm seem to Bear the intelligent
imprint of a guiding hand indeed the
degree of convergence between such
ancient stories is frequently remarkable
enough to raise the suspicion that they
must all have been written by the same
author
could that author have had anything to
do with the wondrous deity or a
superhuman spoken of in so many of the
myths we have reviewed who appears
immediately after the world has been
Shattered by a horrifying geological
catastrophe and brings comfort and the
gifts of civilization to the shocked and
demoralized survivors
white and bearded Osiris is the Egyptian
manifestation of this Universal figure
and it may not be an accident that one
of the first acts he is remembered for
in myth is the abolition of cannibalism
among the Primitive inhabitants of the
Nile Valley
viracocha in South America was said to
have begun his civilizing mission
immediately after a great flood where
sarcoatl the discoverer of maize brought
the benefits of crops mathematics
astronomy and a refined culture to
Mexico after the fourth son had been
overwhelmed by a destroying deluge
could these strange myths contain a
record of encounters between scattered
Paleolithic tribes who had survived the
last ice age and an as yet unidentified
High civilization which passed through
the same epoch and could the myths be
attempts to communicate
a message in the bottle of time
of all the other stupendous inventions
Galileo once remarked what Sublimity of
Mind must have been his who conceived
how to communicate his most secret
thoughts to any other person though very
distant either in time or place speaking
with those who are in the Indies
speaking to those who are not yet born
nor shall be this thousand or ten
thousand years and with no greater
difficulty than the various Arrangements
of two dozen little signs on paper let
this be the Seal of all the admirable
inventions of man
precessional message identified by
Scholars like santiliana bondashen and
Jane sellers is indeed a deliberate
attempt at communication by some Lost
Civilization of antiquity how come it
wasn't just written down and left for us
to find wouldn't that have been easier
than encoding it in myths
perhaps
nevertheless
suppose that whatever the message was
written on got destroyed or worn away
after many thousands of years or suppose
that the language in which it was
inscribed was later forgotten utterly
like the enigmatic Indus Valley script
which has been studied closely for more
than half a century but which has so far
resisted all attempts at decoding
it must be obvious that in such
circumstances a written Legacy to the
Future would be of no value at all
because nobody would be able to make
sense of it
what one would look for therefore would
be a universal language the kind of
language that would be comprehensible to
any technologically advanced Society in
any Epoch even a thousand or ten
thousand years into the future such
languages are few and far between but
mathematics is one of them and the City
of teotuacan may be the calling card of
A Lost Civilization written in the
Eternal language of mathematics
geodetic data related to the exact
positioning of fixed geographical points
and to the shape and size of the Earth
would also remain valid and recognizable
for tens of thousands of years and might
be most conveniently expressed by means
of cartography or in the construction of
giant geodetic monuments like the Great
Pyramid of Egypt as we shall see
another constant in our solar system is
the language of time but great but
regular intervals of time calibrated by
The Inchworm creep of recessional motion
now or ten thousand years in the future
a message that prints out numbers like
72 or
2160 or
4320 or 25
920 should be instantly intelligible to
any civilization that has evolved a
modest talent for mathematics and the
ability to detect and measure the almost
imperceptible reverse wobble that the
Sun appears to make along the ecliptic
against the background of the fixed
Stars one degree in 71.6 years 30
degrees in
2148 years and so on
the sense that the correlation exists is
strengthened by something else it is
neither as firm nor as definite as the
number of syllables in the rig Vader
nevertheless it feels relevant
through powerful stylistic links and
shared symbolism myths to do with global
cataclysms and with precession of the
equinoxes quite frequently into mesh a
detailed interconnectedness exists
between these two categories of
tradition both of which additionally
bear what appear to be the recognizable
Fingerprints of a conscious design quite
naturally therefore one is prompted to
discover whether there might not be an
important connection between precession
of the equinoxes and Global catastrophes
Mill of pain
although several different mechanisms of
an astronomical and geological nature
seem to be involved and although not all
of these are fully understood the fact
is that the cycle of precession does
correlate very strongly with the onset
and demise of ice ages several trigger
factors must coincide which why not
every shift from one astronomical age to
another is implicated nevertheless it is
accepted that precession does have an
impact on both glaciation and
deglaciation at widely separated
intervals the knowledge that it does so
has only been established by our own
science since the late 1970s yet the
evidence of the myths suggests that the
same level of knowledge might have been
possessed by an as yet unidentified
civilization in the depths of the last
ice age
a clear suggestion we may be meant to
grasp is that the terrible cataclysms of
flood and Fire and Ice which the myths
describe where in some way causally
connected to the ponderous movements of
the celestial coordinates through the
great cycle of the zodiac
in the words of santillana and Von
deschend it was not a foreign idea to
the Ancients that the Mills of the Gods
grind slowly and that the result is
usually pain
three principal factors all of which we
have met before are now known to be
deeply implicated in the onset and
Retreat of ice ages together of course
with the diverse cataclysms that ensue
from Sudden freezes and doors
these factors all have to do with
variations in the earth's orbital
geometry they are one the obliquity of
the ecliptic that is the angle of tilt
of the planet's axis of rotation which
is also the angle between the celestial
equator and the ecliptic this as we have
seen varies over immensely long periods
of time between 22.1 degrees the closest
point that the axis reaches to the
vertical and 24.5 degrees the furthest
it falls away from the vertical
2 the eccentricity of the orbit that is
whether the Earth's elliptical path
around the Sun is more or less elongated
in any given epoch
three axial precession which causes the
four cardinal points on the Earth's
orbit the two equinoxes and the winter
and summer solstices decree backwards
very very slowly around the orbital path
we are dipping our toes into the Waters
of a technical and specialized
scientific discipline here one largely
outside the scope of this book
readers seeking detailed information are
referred to the multi-disciplinary work
of the U.S national science foundation's
climap project and to a keynote paper by
professors J.D Hayes and John imbrie
entitled variations in the Earth's orbit
pacemaker of the ice ages
briefly what Hayes and imbrie and others
have proved is that the onset of ice
ages can be predicted when the following
evil and inauspicious conjunctions of
celestial Cycles occur a maximum
eccentricity which takes the Earth
millions of miles further away from the
Sun at apilion the extremity of its
orbit than is normal B minimum obliquity
which means that the Earth's axis and
consequently the North and South Poles
stand much closer to the vertical than
is normal and three precession of the
equinoxes which as the great cycle
continues eventually causes winter in
one Hemisphere or the other to set in
when the earth is at perihelion its
closest point to the sun this in turn
means that summer occurs at apilion and
is thus relatively cold so that ice laid
down in Winter fails to melt during the
following summer and a remorseless
buildup of glacial conditions occurs
leveraged by the changing geometry of
the orbit Global insulation the
differing amounts and intensity of
sunlight received at various latitudes
in any given Epoch can thus be an
important trigger for ice agents is it
possible that the ancient mythmakers
were trying to warn us of great danger
when they so intricately linked the pain
of global cataclysms to the slow
grinding of the mill of Heaven this is a
question we will return to in due course
but meanwhile it's enough to observe
that by identifying the significant
effects of orbital geometry on the
planet's climate and well-being and by
combining this information with precise
measurements of the rate of precessional
motion the unknown scientists of an
unrecognized civilization seem to have
found a way to catch our attention to
bridge the chasm of the ages and to
communicate with us directly
whether or not we listen to what they
have to say is of course entirely up to
us
part six
the Giza invitation
Egypt section one
chapter 33 cardinal points
Giza Egypt 16th of March 1993 3 30 A.M
we walked through the deserted Lobby of
our hotel and stepped into the white
Fiat waiting for us in the driveway
outside it was driven by a lean nervous
Egyptian named Ali whose job it was to
get us past the guards of the Great
Pyramid and away again Before Sunrise he
was nervous because if things went wrong
Santa and I would be deported from Egypt
and he would go to jail for six months
of course things were not supposed to go
wrong that was why Ali was with us the
day before we'd paid him 150 US Dollars
which he had changed into Egyptian
pounds and spread among the guards
concerned they in return had agreed to
turn a blind eye to our presence during
the next couple of hours
we drove to within half a mile of the
pyramid then walked the rest of the way
around the side of the Steep embankment
that looms above the village of nazlet
al-saman and leads to The Monument's
North Face
none of us said very much as we trudged
through the soft sand just out of range
of the security lights we felt excited
and apprehensive at the same time Ali
was by no means certain that his bribes
were going to work
for a while we stood still in the
shadows gazing at the Monstrous bulk of
the pyramid reaching into the darkness
above us and blotting out the southern
stars then a patrol of three men armed
with shotguns and wrapped in blankets
against the night chill came into view
at the northeastern Corner about 50
yards away where they stopped to share a
cigarette
indicating that we should stay put Ali
stepped forward into the light and
walked over to the guards he talked to
them for several minutes apparently
arguing heatedly
finally he beckoned to us indicating
that we should join him there's a
problem he explained one of them the
captain here he indicated a short
unshaven disgruntled looking fellow is
insisting that we pay an extra 30
otherwise the deal is off what do you
want to do
I fished around in my wallet counted out
thirty dollars and handed the bills to
Ali he folded them and passed them to
the captain with an heir of aggrieved
dignity the captain stuffed the money
into his shirt pocket and finally we all
shook hands okay said Ali let's go
inexplicable precision
as the guards continued their patrol in
a Westerly Direction along the northern
face of the Great Pyramid we made our
way around the northeastern corner and
along the base of the Eastern face
I had long ago fallen into the habit of
orienting myself according to the
monument sites the northern face was
aligned almost perfectly to True North
the Eastern face almost perfectly to
True East the southern to True South and
the Western faced a true West the
average ERA was only around three
minutes of Arc down to less than two
minutes on the southern face incredible
accuracy for any building in any Epoch
and an inexplicable almost Supernatural
feat here in Egypt 4 500 years ago when
the Great Pyramid was supposed to have
been built
an error of three arc minutes represents
an infinitesimal deviation from true of
less than
0.015 percent
in the opinion of Structural Engineers
with whom I had discussed the Great
Pyramid the need for such Precision was
impossible to understand
from their point of view as practical
Builders the expense difficulty and time
spent achieving it would not have been
justified by the apparent results even
if the base of the monument had been as
much as two or three degrees out of true
an error of say one percent the
difference to the naked eye would still
have been too small to be noticeable on
the other hand the difference in the
magnitude of the tasks required to
achieve accuracy within three minutes as
opposed to three degrees would have been
immense
obviously therefore the ancient Master
Builders who had raised the pyramid at
the very dawn of human civilization must
have had powerful motives for wanting to
get the alignments with the cardinal
directions just right moreover since
they had achieved their objective with
uncanny exactness they must have been
highly skilled knowledgeable and
competent people with access to
excellent surveying and setting out
equipment this impression was confirmed
by many of The Monument's other
characteristics
for example its sides at the base were
all almost exactly the same length
demonstrating a margin of error far
smaller than modern Architects would be
required to achieve today in the
construction of say an average sized
office
this was no office block however it was
the Great Pyramid of Egypt one of the
largest structures ever built by man and
one of the oldest its north side was 755
feet
4.9818 inches in length its West Side
was 755 feet
9.1551 inches in length East Side was
755 feet
10.4937 inches its South Side
756 feet
0.9739 inches this meant that there was
a difference of less than eight inches
between its shortest and longest sides
an error amounting to a tiny fraction of
one percent on an average side length of
over
9063 inches
once again I knew from an engineering
perspective that the bear figures did
not do justice to the enormous care and
skill required to achieve them I Knew
Too that Scholars had not yet come up
with a convincing explanation of exactly
how the pyramid Builders had adhered
consistently to such high standards of
precision
what really interested me however was
the even bigger question mark over
another issue why had they imposed such
exacting standards on themselves
if they had permitted a margin of error
of one to two percent instead of less
than one tenth of one percent
they could have simplified their tasks
with no apparent loss of quality why
hadn't they done so why had they
insisted on making everything so
difficult why in short in a supposedly
primitive Stone Monument built more than
four thousand five hundred years ago
where we seeing this strange obsessional
adherence to Machine Age standards of
precision
black hole in history
our plan was to climb the Great Pyramid
something that had been strictly illegal
since 1983 when the messy Falls of
several foolhardy tourists had forced
the government of Egypt to impose a ban
I realized that we were being foolhardy
too particularly in attempting The Climb
at night and I didn't feel good about
breaking what was basically a sensible
law
by this stage however my intense
interest in the pyramid and my desire to
learn everything I could about it had
overridden my common sense
now after parting company with the Guard
Patrol at the northeastern corner of the
monument we continued to make our way
surreptitiously along the Eastern face
towards the Southeastern corner
there were dense Shadows among the
twisted and broken paving stones that
separated the Great Pyramid from the
three much smaller subsidiary pyramids
lying immediately to its East there were
also three deep and narrow rock-cut pits
which resembled giant Graves these had
been found empty by the archaeologists
who had excavated them but were shaped
as though they had been intended to
enclose the hulls of high proud
streamlined boats
roughly halfway along the pyramid's
Eastern face we encountered another
Patrol this time it consisted of two
guards one of whom must have been 80
years old His companion a teenager with
pustulant acne informed us that the
money Ali had paid was insufficient and
that 50 more Egyptian pounds would be
required if we were to proceed I already
had the notes in my hand and gave them
to the lad without delay I was past
caring how much this was costing I just
wanted to make the climb and get down
and Away Before Dawn without being
arrested
we walked on reaching the Southeastern
corner at a little after 4 15 am
very few modern buildings even the
houses we live in have corners that
consist of perfect 90 degree right
angles it is common for them to be a
degree or more out of true it doesn't
make any difference structurally and
nobody notices such minute errors in the
case of the Great Pyramid however I knew
that the ancient Master buildings had
found a way to narrow the margin of
error to almost nothing thus while
falling short of the perfect 90 degrees
the Southeastern Corner achieved an
impressive 89 degrees 56 minutes 27
seconds the northeastern Corner measured
90 degrees 3 minutes 2 seconds the
southwestern 90 degrees not minutes 33
seconds and the Northwestern was just
two seconds of a degree out of true at
89 degrees 59 minutes 58 seconds this
was of course a extraordinary and like
almost everything else about the
it was also extremely difficult to
explain
such accurate building techniques as
accurate as the best we have today could
have evolved only after thousands of
years of development and experimentation
yet there was no evidence that any
process of this kind had ever taken
place in Egypt the Great Pyramid and its
neighbors at Giza had emerged out of a
black hole in architectural history so
deep and so wide that neither its bottom
nor its Far Side had ever been
identified
ships in the desert
Guided by the increasingly perspiring
Ali who had not yet explained why it was
necessary for us to circumnavigate the
pyramid before climbing it we now began
to make our way in a Westerly Direction
Along The Monument's southern side
here there were two further boat-shaped
pits one of which though still sealed
had been investigated with fiber optic
cameras and was known to contain a high
proud sea-going vessel more than 100
feet long the other pit had been
excavated in the 1950s its contents an
even larger sea-going vessel a full 141
feet in length had been placed in the
so-called Boat Museum an ugly modern
structure that gangled on stilts beneath
the South face of the Great Pyramid
made of cedar wood the beautiful ship in
the museum was still in perfect
condition 4 500 years after it had been
built with a displacement of around 40
tons its design was particularly thought
provoking incorporating in the words of
one expert all the sea-going ships
characteristic properties with prow and
Stern soaring upward higher than in a
Viking ship to ride out the breakers and
high seas not to contend with the little
ripples of the Nile
another Authority felt that the careful
and clever design of this strange
pyramid boat could potentially have made
it a far more seaworthy craft than
anything available to Columbus moreover
the experts agreed that it had been
built to a pattern that could only have
been created by shipbuilders from a
people with a long solid tradition of
sailing on the Open Sea
present at the very beginning of Egypt's
three thousand year history
who had those as yet unidentified
shipbuilders be they had not accumulated
their long solid tradition of sailing on
the Open Sea while plowing the fields of
the landlocked Nile Valley so where and
when had they developed their Maritime
skills
there was yet another puzzle
I knew that the ancient Egyptians had
been very good at making scale models
and representations of all manner of
things for symbolic purposes I therefore
found it hard to understand why they
would have gone to the trouble of
manufacturing and then burying a boat as
big and sophisticated as this if its
only function as the egyptologists
claimed had been as a token of the
spiritual vessel that would carry the
soul of the deceased King to Heaven that
could have been achieved as effectively
with a much smaller craft and only one
would have been needed not several logic
therefore suggested that these gigantic
vessels might have been intended for
some other purpose altogether or had
some quite different and still
unsuspected symbolic significance
we had reached the rough midpoint of the
Southern face of the Great Pyramid when
we had last realized why we were being
taken on this long Walkabout the
objective was for us to be relieved of
moderate sums of money at each of the
four cardinal points the tally thus far
was 30 US dollars at the northern face
and 50 Egyptian pounds at the Eastern
face now I shelled out a further 50
Egyptian pounds to yet another Patrol
Ali was supposed to have paid off the
day before
Ali I hissed when are we going to climb
the pyramid
right away Mr Graham our guide replied
he walked confidently forward gesturing
directly ahead then add
we shall Ascend at the southwest corner
chapter 34
Mansion of Eternity
have you ever climbed a pyramid at night
fearful of arrest with your nerves in
shreds
it's a surprisingly difficult thing to
do especially where the Great Pyramid is
concerned
even though its top 31 feet are no
longer intact it's presently exposed
Summit platform still stands more than
450 feet above ground level
it consists moreover of 203 separate
courses of masonry with the average
course height being two and a quarter
feet
averages don't tell you everything as I
discovered soon after we began the climb
the courses turned out to be of unequal
depth some barely reaching knee level
While others came up almost to my chest
and created formidable obstacles
at the same time the horizontal Ledges
between each of the steps were very
narrow often only a little wider than my
foot and many of the big Limestone
blocks which had looked so solid From
Below proved to be crumbling and broken
somewhere around 30 courses are Santa
and I began to appreciate what we'd let
ourselves in for
our muscles were aching and our knees
and fingers stiff and bruised yet we
were barely one seventh of the way to
the summit and there were still more
than 170 courses to climb
another worry was the vertiginous drop
steadily opening beneath us
looking down along the ruptured Contours
that marked the line of the southwestern
corner I was taken aback to see how far
we had already climbed and experienced a
momentary giddying presentment of how
easy it would be for us to fall Head
Over Heels like Jack and Jill bouncing
and jolting over the huge layers of
stone breaking our crowns at the bottom
Ali had permitted a pause of a few
moments for us to catch our breath
but now he signaled that we should press
on and began to climb again
still using the corner as a guideline he
rapidly disappeared into the darkness
above
somewhat less confidently Santa and I
followed
time and motion
the 35th course of masonry was a hard
one to clamber over being made of
particularly massive blocks much larger
than any of the others we'd so far
encountered except those at the very
base and estimated to weigh between 10
and 15 Tons apiece this contradicted
engineering logic and Common Sense both
of which called for a progressive
decrease in the size and weight of the
blocks that had to be transported to the
summit as the pyramid Rose ever higher
courses 1 to 18 which diminished from a
height of about 55.5 inches at ground
level to just over 23 inches of course
17 did obey this rule then suddenly at
course 19 the block height rose again to
almost 36 inches at the same time the
other dimensions of the blocks also
increased and their weight Grew From the
relatively maneuverable range of two to
six tons that was common in the first 18
courses to the more ponderous and
cumbersome range of 10 to 15 Tons
these therefore were really big
monoliths that had been carved out of
solid Limestone and raised more than 100
feet into the air before being placed
faultlessly in position
to have worked effectively the pyramid
Builders must have had nerves of Steel
the agility of mountain goats the
strength of lions and the confidence of
trained steeplejacks
with the cold morning wind whipping
around my ears and threatening to launch
me into flight I tried to imagine what
it must have been like for them poised
dangerously at this and much higher
altitudes lifting maneuvering and
positioning exactly an endless
production line of chunky Limestone
monoliths the smallest of which weighed
as much as two Modern Family cars
how long had the pyramid taken to
complete
how many men had worked on it the
consensus amongst egyptologists was two
decades and one hundred thousand men it
was also generally agreed that the
construction project had not been a
year-round Affair but had been confined
through Labor Force availability to the
annual three-month agricultural layoff
season imposed by the flooding of the
Nile
as I continued to climb I reminded
myself of the implications of all this
it wasn't just the tens of thousands of
blocks weighing 15 Tons or more that the
builders would have had to worry about
year in year out the real crises would
have been caused by the millions of
average sized blocks weighing say 2.5
tons that also had to be brought to the
working plane
the pyramid has been reliably estimated
to consist of a total of
2.3 million blocks assuming that the
Masons worked 10 hours a day
365 days a year the mathematics indicate
that they would have needed to place 31
blocks in position every hour about one
block every two minutes to complete the
pyramid in 20 years assuming that
construction work had been confined to
the annual three-month layoff the
problems multiplied four blocks a minute
would have had to be delivered about 240
every hour
such scenarios are of course the stuff
construction managers nightmares are
made of Imagine for example the daunting
degree of coordination that must have
been maintained between the Masons and
the quarries to ensure the requisite
rate of block flow across the production
side imagine also the Havoc if even a
single 2.5 tonne block had been dropped
from say the 175th course
physical and managerial obstacles seemed
staggering on their own but beyond these
was the geometrical challenge
represented by the pyramid itself which
had to end up with its apex positioned
exactly over the center of its base
even the my newest error in the angle of
incline of any one of the sides at the
base would have led to a substantial
misalignment of the edges at the Apex
incredible accuracy therefore had to be
maintained throughout at every course
hundreds of feet above the ground with
great stone blocks of killing weight
rampant stupidity
how had the job been done
at the last count there were more than
30 competing and conflicting theories
attempting to answer that question
the majority of academic egyptologists
have argued that ramps of one kind or
another must have been used this was the
opinion for example of Professor IES
Edwards a former keeper of Egyptian
Antiquities at the British museum who
asserted categorically only one method
of lifting heavy weights was open to the
ancient Egyptians namely by means of
ramps composed of brick and Earth which
sloped upwards from the level of the
ground to whatever height was desired
John Baines professor of egyptology at
Oxford University agreed with Edward's
analysis and took it further as the
pyramid grew in height the length of the
ramp and the width of its base were
increased in order to maintain a
constant gradient about 1 in 10 and to
prevent the ramp from collapsing several
ramps approaching the pyramid from
different sides were probably used
to carry an inclined plane to the top of
the Great Pyramid at a gradient of one
in ten would have required a ramp four
thousand eight hundred feet long and
more than three times as massive as the
Great Pyramid itself
with an estimated volume of 8 million
cubic meters as against the pyramids 2.6
million cubic meter
heavy weights could not have been
dragged up any gradient steeper than
this by any normal means if a lesser
gradient had been chosen the ramp would
have had to be even more absurdly and
disproportionately massive
the problem was that mile long ramps
reaching a height of 480 feet could not
have been made out of bricks and Earth
as Edwards and other egyptologists
supposed
on the contrary Modern Builders and
Architects have proved that such ramps
would have caved in under their own
weight if they'd consisted of any
material less costly and less stable
than the Limestone ashlars of the
pyramid itself
since this obviously made no sense
besides where had the 8 million cubic
meters of surplus blocks been taken
after completion of the work
other egyptologists had proposed the use
of spiral ramps made of mud brick and
attached to the sides of the pyramid
these would certainly have required less
material to build but they would also
have failed to reach the top
they would have presented deadly and
perhaps insurmountable problems to the
teams of men attempting to drag the Big
Blocks of stone around their hairpin
corners and they would have crumbled
under constant use most problematic of
all such ramps would have cloaked the
whole pyramid thus making it impossible
for The Architects to check the accuracy
of the setting out during building
but the pyramid Builders had checked the
accuracy of the setting out and they had
got it right because the apex of the
pyramid was poised exactly over the
center of the base its angles and its
Corners were true each block was in the
correct place and each course had been
laid down level in near perfect Symmetry
and with near perfect alignment to the
cardinal points then as though to
demonstrate that such tour de force of
technique were mere Trifles the ancient
Master Builders had gone on to play some
clever mathematical games with The
Monuments Dimensions presenting us for
example as we heard in chapter 23 with
an accurate use of the transcendental
number Pi in the ratio of its height to
its base perimeter for some reason too
it had taken their fancy to place the
Great Pyramid almost exactly on the 30th
parallel at Latitude 29 degrees 58
minutes 51 seconds this as a former
astronomer oil of Scotland once observed
was a sensible defarcation from 30
degrees but not necessarily in error 4.
if the original designer had wished that
men should see with their body rather
than their mental eyes the pole of the
sky from the foot of the Great Pyramid
at an altitude before them of 30 degrees
he would have to take account of the
refraction of the atmosphere and that
would have necessitated the building
standing not at 30 degrees but at 29
degrees 58 minutes 22 seconds
compared to the true position of 29
degrees 58 minutes 51 seconds this was
an error of less than half an arc minute
suggesting once again that the surveying
and geodetic skills brought to bear here
must have been of the highest order
feeling somewhat over awed we climbed on
past the 44th and 45th courses of the
hulking and enigmatic structure at the
46th course
an angry voice hailed Us in Arabic from
the plaza below and we looked down to
see a tiny turbaned man dressed in a
billowing caftan despite the rage he had
unslung his shotgun and Was preparing to
take aim at us
the guardian
and the vision
he was of course
the guardian of the pyramid's western
face the patrolman of the fourth
Cardinal Point and he had not received
the extra funds dispense to his
colleagues of the north east and south
faces
I could tell from Ali's perspiration
that we were in a potentially tricky
situation the guard was ordering us to
come down at once so that he could place
us under arrest
this however could probably be avoided
with a further payment Ali explained I
groaned offer him a hundred Egyptian
pounds
Too Much Charlie caution it will make
the others resentful I shall offer him
50.
more words were exchanged in Arabic
indeed over the next few minutes Ali and
the guard managed to have quite a
sustained conversation up and down the
southwest corner of the pyramid at 4 40
in the morning at one point a whistle
was blown then the guards of the
Southern face put in a brief appearance
and stood in conference with the guard
of the western face who had now also
been joined by two other members of his
Patrol
just when it seemed that Ali had lost
whatever argument he was having on our
behalf he smiled and heaved a sigh of
relief you will pay the extra 50 pounds
when we have returned to the ground he
explained they're letting us continue
but they say that if any senior officer
comes along and sees us they will not be
able to help us
we struggled up with in silence for the
next 10 minutes or so until we'd reached
the 100th course roughly the halfway
mark and already well over 250 feet
above the ground
we gazed over our shoulders to the
Southwest where a once in a lifetime
vision of Staggering Beauty and power
confronted us
the Crescent Moon would hung low in the
sky to the southeast had emerged from
behind a scudding cloud bank and
projected its ghostly Radiance directly
at the northern and Eastern faces of the
neighboring second pyramid supposedly
built by the fourth Dynasty pharaoh
kafri kephrim
this stunning Monument second only in
size and Majesty to the Great Pyramid
itself being just a few feet shorter and
48 feet narrower at the base appeared
litter as though energized from within
by a pale and unearthly Fire
behind it in the distance slightly
offset among the dark Desert Shadows was
the smaller pyramid of menkare my
serenas measuring 356 feet along each
side and some 215 feet in height
for a moment against the glittering
backdrop of an Inky Sky I experienced
the illusion of being in motion of
standing at the stern of some great ship
of the heavens and looking back at two
other vessels which seemed to follow in
my wake strung out in Battle Order
behind me
so where was this Convoy going this
Squadron of pyramids and were the
prodigious structures all the work of
megalomaniac pharaohs as the
egyptologists believed or had they been
designed by mysterious hands to Voyage
eternally through time and space towards
some as yet unidentified objective
from this altitude though the southern
sky was partially occluded by the vast
bulk of the Pyramid of cafrei I could
see all the Western sky as it arched
down from the celestial North Pole
towards the distant rim of the revolving
planet
Polaris the pole star was far to my
right in the constellation of the little
bear low on the horizon about 10 degrees
north and west regulus the poor star of
the Imperial constellation of Leo was
about to set
under Egyptian scars
just above the 150th course Ali histored
us to keep our heads down a police car
had come into view around the
Northwestern corner of the Great Pyramid
and was now proceeding along the western
flank of the monument with its blue
light slowly flashing
we stayed Motionless In the Shadows
until the car had passed then we began
to climb again with a renewed sense of
urgency heading as fast as we could
towards the summit which we now imagined
we could see jutting out above the Misty
pre-dawn Hayes
for what seemed like five minutes we
climbed without stopping when I looked
up however the top of the pyramid still
seemed as far away as ever we climbed
again panting and sweating and once
again the summit Drew back before us
like some legendary Welsh Peak then just
when we'd resigned ourselves to an
endless succession of such
disappointments we found ourselves at
the top under a breathtaking canopy of
stars more than 450 feet above the
surrounding Plateau on the most
extraordinary viewing platform in the
world
to our north and east sprawled out
across the wide sloping Valley of the
River Nile lay the City of Cairo a
jumble of skyscrapers and flat
traditional roofs separated by the dark
defiles of narrow streets and
interspersed with the needlepoint
minarets of a Thousand and One mosques
film of reflected Street lighting
shimmered over the whole scene closing
the eyes of modern kyrenes to The Wonder
of the stars but at the same time
creating the hallucination of a
fairyland illuminated in Greens and reds
and blues and sulfurous yellows
he felt privileged to witness this
strange electronic Mirage from such an
incredible vantage point perched on the
summit platform of the last surviving
wonder of the ancient world hovering in
the sky over Cairo like Aladdin on his
magic carpet
not that the 203rd course of the Great
Pyramid of Egypt could be described as a
carpet measuring just under 30 feet on
each side as Against The Monument's side
length of around
755 feet at the base it consisted of
several hundred waste High Limestone
blocks Each of which weighed about five
tons the course was not completely level
a few blocks were missing or broken and
Rising towards the southern end there
were the substantial remains of about
half an additional step of Masonry
moreover at the very center of the
platform someone had arranged for a
triangular wooden scaffold to be erected
through the middle of which rose a thick
pole just over 31 feet long which marked
The Monument's original true height of
481.3949 feet
beneath this a scroll of graffiti had
been carved into the Limestone by
generations of tourists
the complete Ascent of the pyramid had
taken us about half an hour and it was
now just after 5am the time of morning
worship almost in unison the voices of a
thousand and one was ins rang out from
the balconies of the minarets of Cairo
calling the faithful to prayer and
reaffirming the greatness the
indivisibility the mercy and the
compassion of God behind me to the
Southwest the top 22 courses of cafres
pyramid still clad with their original
facing Stones seemed to float like an
iceberg on the ocean of moonlight
knowing that we could not stay long in
this bewitching place I sat down and
gazed around at the heaven
over to the west across Limitless Desert
Sands regulus had now sat Beneath The
Horizon and the rest of the Lion's body
was poised to follow
the constellations of Virgo and Libra
were also dropping lower in the sky and
much farther to the north I could see
the great and little bears slowly pacing
out their Eternal cycle around the
celestial Pole
I looked Southeast across the Nile
Valley and there was the Crescent Moon
still spreading its spectral Radiance
from the bank of the Milky Way
following the course of the celestial
River I looked due south
there crossing the Meridian was the
resplendent constellation of Scorpius
dominated by the first magnitude star
Antares a red supergiant 300 times the
diameter of the sun Northeast above
Cairo sailed cygnus the swan his tail
feathers marked by deneb a blue white
supergiant visible to us across more
than 1 800 light years of interstellar
space
last but not least in the northern sky
the dragon Rock coiled sinuously Among
the circumpolar Stars indeed 4500 years
ago when the Great Pyramid was
supposedly being built for the fourth
Dynasty Pharaoh Khufu chiops one of the
stars of Draco had stood close to the
celestial North Pole and had served as
the pole star this had been Alpha
draconis also known as uban with the
passing of the Millennia however it had
gradually been displaced from its
position by the remorseless Celestial
Mill of the Earth's axial procession so
that the pole star today is Polaris in
the little bear
I laid back
cushioned my head in my hands and gazed
directly up towards the Zenith of Heaven
through the smooth Cold Stones I rested
on I thought I could sense beneath me
like a living Force the stupendous
gravity and mass of the pyramid
thinking like giants
covering a full 13.1 Acres at the base
the Great Pyramid weighed about 6
million tons more than all the buildings
in the square mile of the city of London
added together and consisted as we've
seen of roughly 2.3 million individual
blocks of limestone and Granite to these
had once been added a 22 acre
mirror-like cladding consisting of an
estimated 115
000 highly polished casing Stones each
weighing 10 tons which had originally
covered all four of its faces
after being shaken Loose by a massive
earthquake in ad 1301 the majority of
the facing blocks had subsequently been
removed for the construction of Cairo
here and there around the base however I
knew that enough had remained in
position to permit the great 19th
century archaeologist w m Flinders
Petrie to carry out a detailed study of
them
he'd been stunned to Encounter
tolerances of less than 100 of an inch
and cemented joints so precise and so
carefully aligned that it was impossible
to slip even the fine blade of a pocket
knife between them
merely to place such stones in exact
contact would be careful work he
admitted but to do so with cement in the
joint seems almost impossible it is to
be compared to the finest optician's
work on a scale of Acres
of course the jointing of the casing
Stones was by no means the only almost
impossible feature of the Great Pyramid
the alignments to true north south east
and west were almost impossible so too
were the near perfect 90 degree corners
and the incredible symmetry of the four
enormous sides and so were the
engineering Logistics of raising
millions of huge Stones hundreds of feet
in the air
whoever they had been there for the
Architects engineers and stonemasons who
had designed and successfully built this
stupendous Monument must indeed have
thought like men 100 feet tall as
jean-francois champollion the founder of
modern egyptology had once observed he
had seen clearly what generations of his
successes were to close their eyes to
that the pyramid Builders could only
have been men of giant intellectual
stature
beside the Egyptians of old he had added
we in Europe are but lilliputians
chapter 35
tombs and tombs only
climbing down the Great Pyramid was more
nerve-wracking than climbing up
we were no longer struggling against the
force of gravity so the physical effort
was less but the possibilities of a
fatal fall seemed greatly magnified now
that our attention was directed
exclusively towards the ground rather
than the heavens
we picked our way with exaggerated care
towards the base of the enormous
mountain of stone sliding and slithering
among the treacherous masonry blocks
feeling as though we had been reduced to
ants
by the time we had completed The Descent
the night was over and the first wash of
pale sunlight was filtering into the sky
we paid the 50 Egyptian pounds promised
to the guard of the pyramid's western
face and then with a tremendous sense of
release and exaltation we walked
jauntily away from the monument in the
direction of the Pyramid of cafre a few
hundred meters to the Southwest
Khufu kafre mencare chions
whether they were referred to by their
Egyptian or their Greek names the fact
remained that these three pharaohs of
the fourth Dynasty
2575 to
2467 BC were universally acclaimed as
the Builders of the Giza Pyramids this
had been the case at least since ancient
Egyptian tour guides had told the Greek
historian Herodotus that the Great
Pyramid had been built by Khufu
Herodotus had Incorporated this
information into the oldest surviving
written description of The Monuments
which continued
she helps they said reigned for 50 years
and on his death the kingship was taken
over by his brother jeffron he also made
a pyramid it is 40 feet lower than his
brother's pyramid but otherwise of the
same greatness chefrin reigned for 56
years then there succeeded my serenis
the son of chios this man left the
pyramid much smaller than his father's
Herodotus saw The Monuments in the 5th
Century BC more than 2 000 years after
they'd been built nevertheless it was
largely on the foundation of his
testimony that the entire subsequent
Judgment of History was based all other
commentators up to the present continued
uncritically to follow in the Greek
historians footsteps
and down the ages although it had
originally been little more than hearsay
the attribution of the Great Pyramid to
Khufu the second pyramid to kafrei and
the third pyramid to menka Ray had
assumed the stature of unassailable fact
trivializing the mystery
having parted company with Ali satha and
I continued our walk into the desert
skirting the immense Southwestern corner
of the second pyramid our eyes were
drawn towards its Summit
there we noted again the intact facing
stones that still covered its top 22
courses we also noticed that the first
few courses above its base Each of which
had a footprint of about a dozen Acres
were composed of truly massive blocks of
limestone almost too high to clamber
over which were about 20 feet long and
six feet thick these extraordinary
monoliths as I was later to discover
weighed 200 tons apiece and belonged to
a distinct style of masonry to be found
at several different and widely
scattered locations within the Giza
necropolis
on its north and west sides the second
pyramid sat on a level platform cut down
out of the surrounding bedrock and was
thus enclosed within a wide trench more
than 15 feet deep in places walking due
south parallel to the monuments scarred
Western flank we picked our way along
the edge of this trench towards the much
smaller third pyramid which lays some
400 meters ahead of us in the desert
Khufu kafre mencare according to all
Orthodox egyptologists the pyramids had
been built as tombs and only as tombs
for these three pharaohs
yet there were some obvious difficulties
with such assertions for example the
spacious burial chamber of the coffrey
pyramid was empty when it was opened in
1818 by the European explorer Giovanni
Belzoni indeed more than empty the
chamber was starkly or Steely bare the
polished Granite sarcophagus which lay
embedded in its floor had also been
found empty with its lid broken in two
pieces nearby how was this to be
explained
two egyptologists the answer seemed
obvious at some early date probably not
many hundreds of years after kathry's
death tomb robbers must have penetrated
the chamber and cleared all its contents
including the mummified body of the
Pharaoh
much the same thing seemed to have
happened at the smaller third pyramid
towards which Santa and I were now
walking that attributed to menka Ray
here the first European to break in had
been a British Colonel how advised who
had entered the burial chamber in 1837.
he found an empty Basalt sarcophagus an
anthropoid coffin lid made of wood and
some bones the natural assumption was
that these were the remains of mencare
modern science had subsequently proved
however that the bones and the coffin
lid dated from the early Christian era
that is from 2500 years after the
pyramid age and thus represented the
intrusive burial of a much later
individual quite a common practice
throughout ancient Egyptian history
as to the basalt sarcophagus well it
could have belonged to menkare
unfortunately however nobody had the
opportunity to examine it because it had
been lost at sea when the ship on which
Vice sent it to England had sunk off the
coast of Spain since it was a matter of
record that the sarcophagus had been
found empty by Vice it was once again
assumed that the body of the Pharaoh
must have been removed by tomb robbers
a similar assumption had been made about
the body of Khufu which was also missing
here the scholarly consensus expressed
as well as anyone by George Hart of the
British museum was that no later than
500 years after khufu's funeral Roberts
had forced their way into the greater
pyramid to steal the burial treasure
the implication is that this incursion
must have occurred by or before 2000 BC
since Khufu is believed to have died in
2528 BC
moreover it was assumed by Professor IES
Edwards a leading Authority on these
matters that the burial treasure had
been removed from the famous inner
sanctum now known as the king's chamber
and that the empty Granite sarcophagus
which stood at the Western end of that
sanctum had once contained The King's
body probably enclosed within an inner
coffin made of wood
all this is orthodox mainstream modern
scholarship which is unquestioningly
accepted as historical fact and taught
as such at universities everywhere but
suppose it isn't fact
the cupboard was Bare
The Mystery of the missing mummy of
Khufu begins with the records of Khalif
Alma Moon a Muslim governor of Cairo in
the 9th Century A.D
he had engaged a team of couriers to
Tunnel their way into the pyramid's
northern face
urging them on with promises that they
would discover treasure through a series
of Lucky accidents mamoon's whole as
archaeologists now refer to it had
joined up with one of The Monuments
several internal passageways the
descending Corridor leading downwards
from the original concealed doorway in
the northern face the location of which
though known in classical times had been
forgotten by mamoon's day by a further
lucky accident the vibrations that the
Arabs had caused with their battering
rams and drills dislodged a block of
limestone from the ceiling of the
descending Corridor when the socket from
which it had fallen was examined it was
found to conceal the opening to another
Corridor this time ascending into the
bowels of the pyramid
there was a problem however the opening
was blocked by a series of enormous
plugs of solid Granite clearly
contemporaneous with the construction of
the monument which were held in place by
a narrowing of the lower end of the
corridor
the couriers were unable either to break
or to cut through the plugs they
therefore tunneled into the slightly
softer Limestone surrounding them and
after several weeks of back-breaking
toil rejoined the ascending Corridor
higher up having bypassed a formidable
obstacle never before breached
the implications were obvious since no
previous treasure Seekers had penetrated
this far the interior of the pyramid
must still be Virgin Territory the
diggers must have licked their lips with
anticipation at the immense quantities
of gold and jewels they could now expect
to find
similarly though perhaps for different
reasons mahmoon must have been impatient
to be the first into any chambers that
lay ahead it was reported that his
primary motive in initiating this
investigation had not been an ambition
to increase his vast personal wealth
but the desire to gain access to a
storehouse of ancient wisdom and
technology which he believed to lie
buried within the monument
in this Repository
according to age-old tradition the
pyramid Builders had placed instruments
of iron and arms which rust not and
glass which might be bended and yet not
broken and strange spells
but mahmoon and his men found nothing
not even any down-to-earth treasure and
certainly not any high-tech
anachronistic plastic or instruments of
iron or rust proof weapons or strange
spells either
the erroneously named Queen's chamber
which lay at the end of a long
horizontal passageway that branched off
from the ascending Corridor turned out
to be completely empty just a severe
geometrical room more disappointing
still the king's chamber which the Arabs
reached after climbing the imposing
Grand Gallery also offered little of
Interest its Only Furniture was a
granite Coffer just big enough to
contain the body of a man later
identified are no very good grounds as a
sarcophagus this undecorated Stone box
was approached with trepidation by
mammoon and his team who found it to be
littlest and as empty as everything else
in the pyramid
why how and when exactly had the Great
Pyramid been emptied of its contents had
it been 500 years after khufu's death as
the egyptologists suggested or was it
not more likely as the evidence was
beginning to suggest that the inner
chambers of the pyramid had been empty
all along from the very beginning that
is from the day that the monument had
originally been sealed nobody after all
had reached the upper part of the
ascending Corridor before marmoon and
his men and it was certain too that
nobody had cut through the granite plugs
blocking the entrance to that corridor
Common Sense ruled out the possibility
of any earlier incursion unless there
was another way in
bottlenecks in the well shaft
there was another way in
farther down the descending Corridor
more than 200 feet beyond the point
where the plugged end of the ascending
Corridor had been found lies the
concealed entrance to another secret
passageway deep within the Subterranean
Bedrock of the Giza plateau if Mamoon
had discovered this passageway he could
have saved himself a great deal of
trouble since it provided a ready-made
Route Around the plugs blocking the
ascending Corridor his attention however
had been distracted by the challenge of
tunneling past those plugs and he made
no effort to investigate the lower
reaches of the descending Corridor which
he ended up using as a dump for the tons
of stone his diggers removed from the
core of the pyramid
the full extent of the descending
Corridor was however well known and
explored In classical times the Greek or
Roman geographer strabo left quite a
clear description of the large
Subterranean chamber it debouched into
at a depth of almost 600 feet below the
apex of the pyramid
graffiti from the period of the Roman
occupation of Egypt was also found
inside this underground chamber
confirming that it had once been
regularly visited yet because it had
been so cunningly hidden in the
beginning the secret doorway leading off
to one side about two-thirds of the way
down the Western Wall of the descending
Corridor remained sealed and
undiscovered until the 19th century
what the doorway led to was a narrow
well shaft about 160 feet in extent
which rose almost vertically through the
Bedrock and then threw more than 20
complete courses of the great pyramid's
Limestone core blocks until it joined up
with the main internal Corridor system
at the base of the grand gallery there
is no evidence to indicate what the
purpose of this strange architectural
feature might have been although several
Scholars have hazarded guesses
indeed the only thing that is clear is
that it was engineered at the time of
the construction of the pyramid and was
not the result of an intrusion by
tunneling tomb robbers
question remains open however as to
whether tomb robbers might have
discovered the hidden entrance to the
shaft and made use of it to siphon off
the treasures from the kings and queens
Chambers such a possibility cannot be
ruled out nevertheless a review of the
historical record indicates little in
its favor
for example the upper end of the well
shaft was entered off the grand Gallery
by the Oxford astronomer John Greaves in
1638 he managed to descend to a depth of
about 60 feet in 1765 another Britain
Nathaniel Davison penetrated to a depth
of about 150 feet but found his way
blocked by an impenetrable mass of sand
and stones
later in the 1830s captain G.B caviglia
an Italian Adventurer reached the same
depth and encountered the same obstacle
more enterprising than his predecessors
he hired Arab workers to start
Excavating the rubble in the hope that
there might be something of Interest
beneath it several days of digging in
claustrophobic conditions followed
before the connection with the
descending Corridor was discovered
is it likely that such a cramped blocked
up shaft could have been a viable
conduit but the treasures of Khufu
supposedly the greatest pharaoh of The
Magnificent fourth Dynasty even if it
hadn't been choked with debris and
sealed at the lower end it could not
have been used to bring out more than a
tiny fraction of the treasures of a
typical Royal tomb this is because the
well shaft is only three feet in
diameter and incorporates several tricky
vertical sections
at the very least therefore when mahmoon
and his men battered their way into the
king's chamber around the year
ad820 one would have expected some of
the bigger and heavier pieces from the
original burial still to be in place
like the statues and shrines that bolt
so large in tutankhamans much later and
presumably inferior too but nothing was
found inside khufu's pyramid making this
and the alleged Looting of cafres
Monument the only two robberies in the
history of Egypt which achieved a clean
sweep leaving not a single trace behind
not a torn cloth Not A Shard of broken
pottery not an unwanted figurine not an
overlooked piece of jewelry just the
bare floors and walls and the gaping
mouths of empty sarcophagus
not like other tools
it was now after six in the morning and
the Rising Sun had bathed the Summits of
khufus and kafres pyramids with a
fleeting blush of pastel pink light
menkare's pyramid being some 200 feet
lower than the other two was still in
Shadow asantha and I skirted its
Northwestern corner and continued our
walk into the rolling sand dunes of the
surrounding desert
I still have the tomb robbery theory on
my mind
as far as I could see the only real
evidence in favor of it was the absence
of grave goods and mummies that it had
been invented to explain in the first
place all the other facts particularly
where the Great Pyramid was concerned
seemed to speak persuasively against any
robbery having occur
it was not just a matter of the
narrowness and unsuitability of the well
shaft as an escape route for bulky
Treasures the other remarkable feature
of khufu's pyramid was the absence of
inscriptions or decorations anywhere
within its immense network of galleries
corridors passageways and Chambers and
the same was true of calf raise and
mencare's pyramids in none of these
amazing monuments had a single word been
written in Praise of the Pharaohs whose
bodies they were supposed to house
this was exceptional no other proven
burial place of any Egyptian Monarch had
ever been found undecorated the fashion
throughout Egyptian history had been for
the tombs of the Pharaohs to be
extensively decorated beautifully
painted from top to bottom as in the
valley of Kings at Luxor for example and
densely inscribed with the ritual spells
and invocations required to assist the
deceased on his journey towards eternal
life as in the fifth Dynasty pyramid
that Sakara just 20 miles to the south
of giesner why had Khufu kafrei and
menkare done things so differently
had they not built their monuments to
serve as tombs at all but for another
and more subtle purpose or was it
possible a certain Arab and esoteric
Traditions maintained that the Giza
Pyramids had been erected long before
the fourth Dynasty by The Architects of
some earlier and more advanced
civilization
neither hypothesis was popular with
egyptologists for reasons that were easy
to understand moreover while conceding
that the second and third pyramids were
completely devoid of internal
inscriptions lacking even the names of
Cafe and menkare the scholars were able
to cite certain hieroglyphic Quarry
marks
graffiti dorbed on stone blocks before
they left the Quarry found inside the
Great Pyramid which did seem to Bear the
name of Khufu
a certain smell
the discoverer of the Quarry marks was
Colonel Howard Vice during the
destructive excavations he undertook at
Giza in 1837 extending an existing
crawlway he cut a tunnel into the series
of narrow cavities called relieving
Chambers which lay directly above the
king's chain
the Quarry marks were found on the walls
and ceilings of the top four of these
cavities and said things like this
the Craftsmen gang how powerful is the
white crown of Krum kufu
kufu
foreign
year 17.
it was all very convenient right at the
end of a costly and otherwise fruitless
digging season just when a major
archaeological Discovery was needed to
legitimize the expenses he'd run up
buyers had stumbled upon the find of the
decade the first incontrovertible proof
that Khufu had indeed been the builder
of the hitherto anonymous Great Pyramid
one would have thought that the
discovery of this nature would have
settled conclusively any lingering
doubts over the ownership and purpose of
that enigmatic Monument
but the doubts remained largely because
from the beginning a certain smell hung
over vice's evidence
one it was odd that the marks were the
only signs of the name Khufu ever found
anywhere inside the Great Pyramid two it
was odd that they had been found in such
an obscure out of the way corner of that
immense building
three it was odd that they had been
found at all in a monument otherwise
devoid of inscriptions of any kind 4. it
was extremely odd that they had been
found only in the top four of the five
relieving Chambers
inevitably Suspicious Minds began to
wonder whether Quarry marks might also
have appeared in the lowest of these
five Chambers had that chamber 2 being
discovered by Vice rather than by
Nathaniel Davison 70 years earlier
pie last but not least it was odd that
several of the hieroglyphs in the Quarry
marks had been painted upside down and
that some were unrecognizable While
others had been misspelled or used
ungrammatically
was vice a Forger
I know of one plausible case made to
suggest he was exactly that and although
final proof will probably always be
lacking he seemed to me in cautious of
academic egyptology to have accepted the
authenticity of the Quarry marks without
question
besides there was alternative
hieroglyphic evidence arguably of pure
provenance which appeared to indicate
that Khufu could not have built the
Great Pyramid
strangely the same egyptologists who
readily ascribed immense importance to
vice's Quarry marks were quick to
downplay the significance of these other
contradictory hieroglyphs which appeared
on a rectangular Limestone Stellar which
now stood in the Cairo Museum
the inventory Stella as it was called
had been discovered at Giza in the 19th
century by the French archaeologist
Auguste Marriott
it was something of a bombshell because
its text clearly indicated that both the
grades Sphinx and the Great Pyramid as
well as several other structures on the
plateau were already in existence long
before Khufu came to the throne
the inscription also referred to Isis as
the Mistress of the pyramid implying
that the monument had been dedicated to
the goddess of magic and not to Khufu at
all
finally there was a strong suggestion
that khufu's pyramid might have been one
of the three subsidiary structures
alongside the Great Pyramids Eastern
flank
all this looked like damaging evidence
against the Orthodox chronology of
ancient Egypt it also challenged the
consensus view that the Giza Pyramids
had been built as tombs and only as
tombs however rather than investigating
the anachronistic statements in the
inventory Stellar
egyptologists chose to devalue them in
the words of the influential American
Scholar James Henry brestert these
references would be of the highest
importance if the Stellar were
contemporaneous with Khufu but the
orthographic evidences of its late date
are entirely conclusive
breasted meant that the nature of the
hieroglyphic writing system used in the
inscription was not consistent with that
used in the fourth Dynasty
but belonged to a more recent epoch all
egyptologists concurred with this
analysis and the final judgment still
accepted today was that the Stellar had
been carved in the 21st Dynasty about 1
500 years after khufu's Reign and was
therefore to be regarded as a work of
historical fiction
thus citing autographic evidence an
entire academic discipline found reason
to ignore the boat rocking implications
of the inventory stellar and at no time
gave proper consideration to the
possibility that it could have been
based upon a genuine fourth Dynasty
inscription just as the new English
Bible for example is based on a much
older original
exactly the same Scholars however had
accepted the authenticity of a set of
dubious Quarry marks without dimmer
turning a blind eye to their
orthographic and other peculiarities why
the double standard could it have been
because the information contained in the
Quarry marks conformed strictly to
Orthodox opinion that the Great Pyramid
had been built as a tomb for Khufu
whereas the information in the inventory
Stellar contradicted that opinion
overview
by seven in the morning Santa and I had
walked far out into the desert to the
southwest of the Giza Pyramids and had
made ourselves comfortable in the Lee of
a huge June that offered an unobstructed
Panorama over the entire site
the date 16th of March was just a few
days away from the Spring Equinox one of
the two occasions in the year when the
sun rose precisely due east of wherever
you stood in the world
ticking out the days like the pointer of
a giant metronome it had bisected The
Horizon this morning at a point a hare's
breath south of due east and had already
climbed high enough to shrug off the
Nile Mists which clung like a shroud to
much of the City of Cairo
Khufu kafrei menka Ray chiops chefrin
mycerinus whether you called them by
their Egyptian or their Greek names
there was no doubt that the three famous
pharaohs of the fourth Dynasty had been
commemorated by the most Splendid the
most honorable the most beautiful and
the most enormous monuments ever seen
anywhere in the world moreover it was
clear that these pharaohs must indeed
have been closely associated with The
Monuments not only because of the
folklore passed on by Herodotus which
surely had some basis in fact but
because inscriptions and references to
Khufu cafrei and menkare had been found
in moderate quantities outside the three
major pyramids at several different
parts of the Giza necropolis such fines
had been made consistently in and around
the six subsidiary pyramids three of
which laid to the east of the Great
Pyramid and the other three to the south
of the menkare pyramid
since much of this external evidence was
ambiguous and uncertain I found it
difficult to understand why the
egyptologists were happy to go on citing
it as confirmation of the tombs and
tombs only Theory the problem was that
this same evidence was capable of
supporting as equally valid a number of
different and mutually contradictory
interpretations to give just one example
the close Association observed between
the three great pyramids and the
three-fourth dynasty pharaohs could
indeed have come about because these
pharaohs had built the pyramids as their
tombs but it could also have come about
if the gigantic monuments of the Giza
Plateau had been standing long before
the dawn of the historical civilization
known as dynastic Egypt in that case it
was only necessary to assume that in due
course Khufu kafrei and menka Ray had
come along and built a number of the
subsidiary structures around the three
older pyramids something that they would
have had every reason to do because in
this way they could have appropriated
the high Prestige of the original
Anonymous monuments and would almost
certainly be viewed by posterity as
their builders
there were other possibilities too the
point was however that the evidence for
exactly who had built which grade
pyramid when and for what purpose was
far too thin on the ground to justify
the dogmatism of the Orthodox tombs and
tombs only theory in all honesty it was
not clear who built the pyramids it was
not clear in what Epoch they had been
built and it was not at all clear what
their function had been for all these
reasons they were surrounded by a
wonderful impenetrable air of mystery
and as I gazed down at the amount of the
desert they seemed to March towards me
across the dunes
chapter 36
anomalies
viewed from our vantage point in the
desert Southwest of the Giza necropolis
the site plan of the three Great
Pyramids seemed Majestic but bizarre
mankari's pyramid was closest to us with
calfrese and khufu's monuments behind it
to the Northeast these two were situated
along a near-perfect diagonal a straight
line connecting the southwestern and
Northeastern corners of the Pyramid of
cafrei would if extended to the
Northeast also passed through the
southwestern and Northeastern corners of
the Great Pyramid
this presumably was not an accident from
where we sat however it was easy to see
that if the same imaginary straight line
was extended to the Southwest it would
completely miss the third pyramid the
entire body of which was offset to the
east of the principal diagonal
egyptologists refused to recognize any
anomaly in this why should they as far
as they were concerned there was no site
plan at Giza the pyramids were tombs and
tombs only Built for three different
pharaohs over a period of about 75 years
it made sense to assume that each ruler
would have sought to express his own
personality and idiosyncrasies through
his monument and this was probably why
mencare had stepped out of line
the egyptologists were wrong though I
was unaware of it that March morning in
1993 a breakthrough had been made
proving Beyond doubt that the necropolis
did have an overall site plan which
dictated the exact positioning of the
three pyramids not only in relation to
one another but in relation to the River
Nile a few kilometers east of the Giza
Plateau with Eerie Fidelity this immense
and ambitious layout modeled a Celestial
phenomenon which was perhaps why
egyptologists who Pride themselves on
looking exclusively at the ground
beneath their feet had failed to Spot It
on a truly giant scale as we'll learn in
later chapters it also reflected the
same obsessive concern with orientations
and dimensions demonstrated in each of
the monuments
a singular oppression
Giza Egypt 16th of March 1993 8 am
at a little over 200 feet tall and with
a side length at the base of 356 feet
the third pyramid was less than half the
height and well under half the mass of
the Great Pyramid nevertheless it
possessed a stunning and imposing
Majesty of its own as we stepped out of
the desert sunlight and into its huge
geometrical Shadow I remembered what the
Iraqi writer Abdul Latif had said about
it when he had visited it in the 12th
century
it appears small compared with the other
two but viewed at a short distance and
to the exclusion of these it excites in
the imagination a singular oppression
and cannot be contemplated without
painfully affecting the site
the lower 16 courses of the monument
were still cased as they had been since
the beginning with facing blocks
quarried out of red granite so extremely
hard in Abdul latif's words that iron
takes a long time with difficulty to
make an impression on it
some of the blocks were very large they
were also closely and cunningly fitted
together in a complex interlocking
jigsaw puzzle pattern strongly
reminiscent of the cyclopian masonry at
Cusco Machu Picchu and other locations
in far off Peru
as was normal the entrance to the third
pyramid was situated in its northern
face well above the ground
from here at an angle of 26 degrees two
minutes a descending Corridor a lanced
Arrow Strait down into the darkness
oriented exactly north of South this
Corridor was rectangular in section and
so cramped that we had to bend almost
double to fit into it
where it passed through the masonry of
the monument its ceiling and walls
consisted of well-fitted granite blocks
more surprisingly these continued for
some distance below ground level at
about 70 feet from the entrance the
corridor leveled off and opened out into
a passageway where we could stand up
this led into a small anti-chamber with
carved paneling and grooves cut into its
walls apparently to take portcullis
slabs reaching the end of the chamber we
had to crouch again to enter another
Corridor bent double we proceeded South
for about 40 feet before reaching the
first of the three main burial Chambers
if burial Chambers they were these
somber soundless rooms were all hewn out
of solid bedrock the one that we stood
in was rectangular in plan and oriented
east to west measuring about 30 feet
long by 15 feet wide by 15 feet high it
had a flat ceiling and a complex
internal structure with a large
irregular hole in its Western Wall
leading into a dark cave-like space
beyond
there was also an opening near the
center of the floor which gave access to
a ramp sloping westwards leading down to
even deeper levels we descended the ramp
it terminated in a short horizontal
passage to the right of which entered
through a narrow doorway lay a small
empty chamber six cells like the
sleeping quarters of medieval monks had
been hewn out of its walls four on the
Eastern side and two to the north these
were presumed by egyptologists to have
functioned as magazines for storing
objects which the dead King wished to
have close to his body
coming out of this chamber we turned
right again back into the horizontal
passage at its end lay Another Empty
chamber the design of which is unique
among the pyramids of Egypt some 12 feet
long by eight wide and oriented north to
south its walls and extensively broken
and damaged floor were fashioned out of
a peculiarly dense chocolate-colored
Granite which seemed to absorb light and
sound waves
ceiling consisted of 18 huge slabs of
the same material nine on each side laid
in facing Gables because they had been
hollowed out from below to form a
markedly concave surface the effect of
these great monoliths was of a perfect
Barrel Vault much as one might expect to
find in the Crypt of a Romanesque
Cathedral retracing our steps we left
the lower Chambers and walked back up
the ramp to the large flat-roofed
rockhoun room above
passing through the racket aperture in
its Western Wall we found ourselves
looking directly at the upper sides of
the 18 slabs which formed the ceiling of
the chamber below
from this perspective their true form as
a pointed Gable was immediately apparent
what was less clear was how they had
been brought in here in the first place
let alone laid so perfectly in position
each one must have weighed many tons
heavy enough to have made them extremely
difficult to handle under any
circumstances
and these were no ordinary circumstances
as though they had set out deliberately
to make things more complicated for
themselves
or perhaps because they found such tasks
simple the pyramid Builders had
disdained to provide an adequate working
area between the slabs and the Bedrock
above them
by crawling into the cavity I was able
to establish that the clearance varied
from approximately two feet at the
southern end to just a few inches at the
Northern end in such a restricted space
there was no possibility that the
monoliths could have been lowered into
position logically therefore they must
have been raised from the chamber floor
but how had that been done the chamber
was so small that only a few men could
have worked inside it at any one time
too few to have had the muscle power to
lift the slabs by Brute Force
police were not supposed to have existed
in the pyramid age even if they had
there would have been insufficient room
to set up lock and Tackle had some
unknown system of levers being used or
might there be more substance than
Scholars realized to the ancient
Egyptian legends that spoke of huge
Stones being effortlessly levitated by
priests or magicians through the
utterance of Words of Power
not for the first time when confronted
by The Mysteries of the pyramids I knew
that I was looking at an impossible
engineering feat which had nevertheless
been carried out to astonishingly high
and precise standards moreover if
egyptologists were to be believed the
construction work had supposedly been
undertaken at the dawn of human
Civilization by a people who had not
accumulated any experience of massive
construction projects
this was of course a startling cultural
Paradox and one for which no adequate
explanation had ever been offered by an
orthodox academic
the moving finger writes and having writ
it moves on
leaving the underground Chambers which
seemed to vibrate at the core of the
third pyramid like the convoluted
multi-volved heart of some slumbering
Leviathan we made our way along the
narrow entrance Corridor and into the
open air
our objective now was the second pyramid
we walked along its Western flank just
under 708 feet in length turned right
and eventually came to the point on its
northern side about 40 feet east of the
main north-south axis where the
principal entrances were located
one of these was carved directly into
the Bedrock at ground level about 30
feet in front of the monument
the other was cut into the northern face
at a height of just under 50 feet from
the latter a corridor sloped downwards
at an angle of 25 degrees 55 minutes
from the former by which we now entered
the pyramid another descending Corridor
LED deeply underground then leveled off
for a short distance giving access to a
Subterranean chamber then ascended
steeply and finally leveled off again
into a long horizontal passageway
heading due south into which also fed
the upper Corridor that sloped down from
the entrance in the North Face
high enough to stand up in and lined at
first with granite and then with
smoothly polished Limestone the
horizontal passageway was almost at
ground level that is it lay directly
beneath the pyramid's lowest course of
masonry it was also extremely long
running dead straight for a further 200
feet until it debouched in the single
burial chamber at the heart of the
monument
as we've already noted no mummy had ever
been found in this latter chamber nor
any inscriptions with the result that
the so-called pyramid of coffrey was
wholly anonymous Latter Day adventurers
had however carved their names on its
walls notably the former circus
strongman Giovanni Batista Belzoni
1778-1823 who had forced his way into
the monument in 1818.
his huge and flamboyant graffito dubbed
in black paint high on the south side of
the chamber was a reminder of basic
human nature the desire that all of us
feel to be recognized and remember it
was clear that coffrey himself had been
far from immune from this ambition since
repeated references to him as well as a
number of flattering statues appeared in
the surrounding funerary complex
if he had indeed built the Pyramid as
his tomb it seemed inconceivable that
such a man would have failed to stamp
his name and identity somewhere within
its interior I found myself wondering
yet again why egyptologists were so
unwilling to consider the possibility
that the funerary complex might have
been cafrei's work and the pyramid
someone else's
but who else is
in many ways this rather than the
absence of identifying Marx was the
central problem
prior to the Reigns of Khufu Cafe and
menkare there was not a single Pharaoh
whose name could be put forward as a
candidate khufu's father snefaru the
first king of the fourth dynasty was
believed to have built the so-called
bent and red pyramids at dashur about 30
miles south of Giza an attribution that
was itself mysterious
if pyramids were indeed tombs since it
seemed strange that one Pharaoh required
two pyramids to be buried in
sneferu was also credited by some
egyptologists with the construction of
the collapsed pyramid at my Doom
although a number of authorities
insisted that this was the Tomb of huni
the last king of the third Dynasty the
only other builders in the Archaic
Period had been Zoser the second pharaoh
of the third Dynasty to whom was
attributed the construction of the step
pyramid at Sakara
successor second cat whose pyramid also
stood at Sakara
therefore despite the lack of
inscriptions it was now assumed as
obvious that the three pyramids at Giza
must have been built by Khufu kafrei and
menka Ray and must have been intended to
serve as their tombs
we need not reiterate here the many
shortcomings of the tombs and tombs only
Theory however these shortcomings were
not limited to the Giza Pyramids but
applied to all the other third and
fourth Dynasty pyramids listed above not
a single one of these monuments had ever
been found to contain the body of a
pharaoh or any signs whatsoever of a
royal burial some of them were not even
equipped with sarcophagus for example
the collapsed pyramid at my Doom
the Pyramid of Sacrament
first entered in 1954 by the Egyptian
Antiquities organization did contain a
sarcophagus one which had certainly
remained sealed and undisturbed since
its installation in the Tomb
grave robbers had never succeeded in
finding their way to it but when it was
opened it was empty
so what was going on how come more than
25 million tons of stone had been piled
up to form pyramids at Giza dashur
maidulman Sakara if the only point of
the exercise had been to install empty
sarcophagi in empty chambers
even admitting the hypothetical excesses
of one or two megalomaniacs it seemed
unlikely that a whole succession of
pharaohs would have sanctioned such
wastefulness
Pandora's Box
buried beneath the 5 million tons of the
second pyramid at Giza Santa and I now
stepped into The Monument's spacious
inner chamber which might have been a
tune but might equally have served some
other as yet unidentified purpose
measuring 46.5 feet in length from east
to west and 16.5 feet in breadth from
north to south this naked and sterile
apartment was topped off with an
immensely strong gabled ceiling reaching
a height of 22.5 feet at its apex
the Gable slabs each a massive 20-ton
Limestone monolith had been laid in
position at an angle of 53 degrees 7
Minutes 28 seconds which exactly matched
the angle of slope of the pyramid sides
here there were no relieving Chambers as
they were above the king's chamber in
the Great Pyramid instead for more than
four thousand years perhaps far more the
gabled ceiling had taken the immense
weight of the second largest stone
building in the world
I looked slowly around the room which
reflected a yellowish white Radiance
back at me
quarried directly out of the living
Bedrock its walls were not at all
smoothly finished as one might have
expected but were noticeably rough and
irregular the floor too was peculiar of
split level design with a step about a
foot deep separating its eastern and
western halves
the supposed sarcophagus of khafrei lay
near the Western Wall embedded in the
floor
measuring just over six feet in length
quite shallow and somewhat narrow to
have contained the wrapped and embalmed
mummy of a noble Pharaoh its smooth red
granite sides reached to about knee-high
as I gain into its dark interior it
seemed to gape like the doorway to
another dimension
chapter 37
made by some God
I have climbed the Great Pyramid the
night before but as I approached it in
the full glare of midday I experienced
no sense of Triumph on the contrary
standing at its base on the North side I
felt fly-sized and puny an impermanent
creature of Flesh and Blood confronted
with the awe-inspiring Splendor of
Eternity I had the impression that it
might have been here forever made by
some God and set down bodily in the
surrounding sand as the Greek historian
dialed raciculus commented in the first
century BC but which God had made it if
not the god king Khufu whose name
generations of Egyptians had associated
with it
for the second time in 12 hours I began
to climb the monument
up close in this light indifferent to
human chronologies and subject only to
the slow erosive forces of geological
time it reared above me like a frowning
terrifying Crag
fortunately I had only six courses to
clamber over assisted in places by
modern steps before reaching mamoon's
hole which now served as the pyramid's
principal entrance
the original entrance still well hidden
in the 9th century when Mahmoud began
tunneling with some 10 courses higher 55
feet above ground level and 24 feet east
of the main north-south axis
protected by giant Limestone Gables it
contained the mouth of the descending
Corridor which led downwards at an angle
of 26 degrees 31 minutes 23 seconds
strangely although itself measuring only
some 3 feet 5 inches by 3 feet 11 inches
this Corridor was sandwiched between
Roofing blocks eight feet six inches
thick and 12 feet wide and a flooring
slab known as the basement sheet two
feet six inches thick and 33 feet wide
hidden structural features like these
are bounded in the Great Pyramid
manifesting both incredible complexity
and apparent pointlessness
nobody knew how blocks of this size had
been successfully installed neither did
anyone know how they had been set so
carefully in alignment with other blocks
or at such precise angles because as The
Listener will have realized the 26
degree slope of the descending Corridor
was part of a deliberate and regular
pattern nobody knew either why these
things had been done
the beacon
entering the pyramid through mamoon's
hole did not feel right it was like
entering a cave or Grotto cut into the
side of a mountain
it lacked the sense of deliberate and
geometrical purposefulness that would
have been conveyed by the original
descending Corridor worse still the dark
and inauspicious horizontal tunnel
leading inwards looked like an ugly
deformed thing and still bore the marks
of violence where the Arab workmen had
alternately heated and chilled the
stones with Fierce fires and cold
vinegar before attacking them with
hammers and chisels battering rams and
borers on the one hand such vandalism
seemed gross and irresponsible on the
other a startling possibility had to be
considered was there not a sense in
which the pyramid seemed to have been
designed to invite human beings of
intelligence and curiosity to penetrate
its Mysteries
after all if you were a pharaoh who
wanted to ensure that his deceased body
remained inviolet for eternity would it
make better sense a to advertise to your
own and all subsequent Generations the
whereabouts of your burial place or be
to choose some secret and unknown
location of which you would never speak
and where you might never be found
the answer was obvious you would go for
secrecy and seclusion as the vast
majority of the Pharaohs of ancient
Egypt had done
why then if it was indeed a royal tomb
was the Great Pyramid so conspicuous
why did it occupy a ground area of more
than 13 acres why was it almost 500 feet
high why in other words if its purpose
was to conceal and protect the body of
Khufu had it been designed so that it
could not fail to attract the attention
in all epochs and under all imaginable
circumstances of treasure crazed
adventurers and of prying and
imaginative intellectuals
it was simply not credible that the
brilliant Architects stonemasons
surveyors and Engineers who had created
the Great Pyramid could have been
ignorant of basic human psychology the
vast ambition and the Transcendent
Beauty power and Artistry of their
handiwork spoke of refined skills
deep insight and a complete
understanding of the symbols and
primordial patterns by which the minds
of men could be manipulate
logic therefore suggested that the
pyramid Builders must also have
understood exactly what kind of Beacon
they were piling up with such incredible
Precision on this Windswept Plateau on
the West Bank of the Nile in those high
and Far Away times
they must in short have wanted this
remarkable structure to exert a
perennial fascination
to be violated by Intruders to be
measured with increasing degrees of
exactitude and to haunt the collective
imagination of mankind like a persistent
ghost summoning intimations of a
profound and long forgotten Secret
mind games
the pyramid builders
the point where Mamoun's whole
intersected with the 26 degree
descending Corridor was closed off by a
modern steel door
Beyond it to the North that Corridor
sloped up until it reached The Gables of
The Monument's original entrance to the
South as we've seen the corridor sloped
down for almost another 350 feet into
the Bedrock before opening out into a
huge Subterranean chamber 600 feet
beneath the apex of the pyramid
the accuracy of this Corridor was
astonishing from top to bottom the
average deviation from straight amounted
to less than one quarter of an inch in
the sides and three tenths of an inch on
the roof
passing the steel door I continued
through mamoon's tunnel breathing in its
ancient air and adjusting my eyes to the
Gloom of the low wattage bulbs that Lit
it then ducking my head I began to climb
through the Steep and narrow section
packed upwards by the Arab diggers in
their feverish thrust to bypass the
series of granite plugs blocking the
lower part of the ascending corridor
at the top of the tunnel two of the
original plugs could be seen
still in situ but partially exposed by
quarrying egyptologists assumed that
they had been slid into their present
position from above all the way down the
129 foot length of the ascending
corridor from the foot of the grand
gallery
Builders and Engineers however whose
trend of thought was perhaps more
practical had pointed out that it was
physically impossible for the plugs to
have been installed in this way because
of the leaf thin clearance that
separated them from the walls floor and
ceiling of the corridor friction would
have foiled any sliding operation in a
matter of inches let alone 100 feet
the puzzling implication was therefore
that the ascending Corridor must have
been plugged while the pyramid was still
being built
but why would anyone have wished to
block the main entrance to the monument
at such an early stage of its
construction even while continuing to
enlarge and elaborate its inner Chambers
moreover if the objective had been to
deny Intruders admission wouldn't it
have been much easier and more efficient
to have plugged the descending corridor
from its entrance in the North Face to a
point below its Junction with the
ascending Corridor that would have been
the most logical way to seal the pyramid
and would have made plugs unnecessary in
the ascending corridor
there was only one certainty since the
beginning of History the single known
effect of the Granite plugs had not been
to prevent an intruder from Gaining
access instead like bluebeard's locked
door the barrier had magnetized my
Moon's attention and inflamed his
curiosity so that he had felt compelled
to Tunnel his way past them convinced
that something of inestimable value must
lie Beyond them
might this not have been what the
pyramid Builders had intended the first
Intruder who reached this far to feel it
would be premature to rule out such a
strange and unsettling possibility at
any rate thanks to Mamoon and to the
predictable constants of human nature I
was now able to insert myself into the
unblocked upper section of the original
ascending corridor
a smoothly cut aperture measuring three
feet five inches wide by 3 feet 11
inches high exactly the same dimensions
as the descending Corridor it sloped up
into the darkness at an angle of 26
degrees 2 minutes 30 seconds as against
26 degrees 31 minutes 23 seconds in the
descending corridor
what was this meticulous interest in the
angle of 26 degrees and was it a
coincidence that it amounted to half of
the angle of inclination of the pyramid
sides 52 degrees
The Listener may recall the significance
of this angle it was a key ingredient of
the sophisticated and advanced formula
by which the design of the Great Pyramid
had been made to correspond precisely to
the Dynamics of spherical geometry thus
the original height of the monument
481.3949 feet and the perimeter of its
base
3023.16 feet stood in the same ratio to
each other as did the radius of a sphere
to its circumference this ratio was 2 pi
2 times 3.14 and to express it the
builders had been obliged to specify the
tricky and idiosyncratic angle of 52
degrees for the pyramid sides since any
greater or lesser slope would have meant
a different height to Perimeter ratio
in chapter 23 we saw that the so-called
pyramid of the Sun at teotiwakan in
Mexico also expressed a knowledge and
deliberate use of the transcendental
number Pi in its case the height
233.5 feet stood in a relationship of 4
pi to the perimeter of its base
2932.76 feet
the Crux therefore was that the most
remarkable Monument of ancient Egypt and
the most remarkable Monument of ancient
Mexico both Incorporated Pi
relationships long before and far away
from the official discovery of this
transcendental number by the Greeks
moreover the evidence invited the
conclusion that something was being
signaled by the use of Pi almost
certainly the same thing in both cases
not for the first time and not for the
last I was overwhelmed by a sense of
contact with an ancient intelligence not
necessarily Egyptian or Mexican which
had found a way to reach out across the
ages and draw people towards it like a
beacon
some might look for treasure others
captivated by the deceptively simple
manner in which the builders had used
pie to demonstrate their Mastery of the
secrets of transcendental numbers might
be inspired to search for further
mathematical epiphanies
bent almost double my back brushing
against the polished Limestone ceiling
it was with such thoughts in my mind
that I began to scramble up the 26
degree slope of the ascending Corridor
which seemed to penetrate the vast bulk
of the 6 million ton building like a
trigonometrical device
after I had banged my head on its
ceiling a couple of times however I
began to wonder why the ingenious people
who designed it hadn't made it two or
three feet higher if they could erect a
monument like this in the first place
which they obviously could and equip it
with corridors surely it would not have
been beyond their capabilities to make
these corridors roomy enough to stand up
in once again I was tempted to conclude
that it was the result of a deliberate
decision by the pyramid Builders they
had made the ascending Corridor this way
because they had wanted it this way
rather than because such a design had
been forced upon them
was their motive in the apparent Madness
of these archaic mind games
unknown dark distance
at the top of the ascending Corridor I
emerged into yet another inexplicable
feature of the pyramid the most
celebrated architectural work to have
survived from the Old Kingdom the grand
gallery
soaring upwards at the continuing
Majestic angle of 26 degrees and almost
entirely Vanishing into the Airy Gloom
above its spacious corbelld Vault made a
stunning impression
it was not my intention to climb the
grand Gallery yet branching off due
south at its base was a long horizontal
passageway three feet nine inches high
and 127 feet in length that led to the
Queen's chamber
I wanted to revisit this room which I
had admired for its Stark Beauty since
becoming acquainted with the Great
Pyramid several years previously
today however to my considerable
irritation the passageway was barred
within a few feet of its entrance
the reason though I was unaware of it at
the time was that a German robotics
engineer named Rudolf gantenbring was at
work within slowly and painstakingly
maneuvering at 250 000 robot up the
narrow Southern shaft of the Queen's
chamber hired by the Egyptian
Antiquities organization to improve the
ventilation of the Great Pyramid he had
already used his high-tech equipment to
clear debris from the king's chamber's
narrow Southern shaft believed by
egyptologists to have been designed as a
ventilation shaft in the first place and
had installed an electric fan at its
mouth
at the beginning of March 1993 he
transferred his attentions to the
Queen's chamber deploying upu out a
miniaturized remote-controlled robot
camera to explore its Southern Charm on
the 22nd of March some 200 feet along
the steeply sloping shaft which rose at
an angle of 39.5 degrees and was only
about eight inches high by nine inches
wide the floor and walls suddenly became
very smooth
azupuat crawled into a section made of
fine Tura Limestone the type normally
used for lining sacred areas such as
chapels or tombs that in itself was
intriguing enough but at the end of this
Corridor apparently leading to a sealed
chamber deep within the pyramid's
masonry was a solid Limestone door
complete with metal fittings
it had long been known that neither this
Southern shaft nor its counterpart in
the chamber's northern wall had any exit
on the outside of the Great Pyramid in
addition and equally inexplicably
neither had originally been fully cut
through for some reason the builders had
left the last five inches of stone
intact in the last block over the mouth
of each of the shafts thus rendering
them invisible and inaccessible to any
casual intruder why
to make sure they would never be found
or to make sure that they would be found
someday under the right circumstances
after all they are had from the
beginning been two conspicuous shafts in
the king's chamber penetrating the North
and South walls it should not have been
beyond the mental powers of the pyramid
Builders to predict that sooner or later
some inquiring person would be tempted
to look for shafts in the Queen's
chamber as well in the event nobody did
look for more than a thousand years
after Khalif Mamoon had opened the
monument to the world in ad 820 then in
1872 an English engineer named Wayne
Dixon a Freemason who had been led to
suspect the existence of the shafts by
their presence in the king's chamber
above went tapping around the Queen's
chamber's walls and located them he
opened the southern shaft first setting
his Carpenter and man of all work Bill
Grundy to jump a hole with a hammer and
steel chisel at that place
so to work the faithful fellow went and
with a will which soon began to make a
way into the soft Limestone at this
point when low after a comparatively
very few Strokes flop went the Chisel
right into something or other
the something or other Bill Grundy's
chisel had reached turned out to be a
rectangular horizontal tubular Channel
about nine inches by eight inches in
transverse breadth and height going back
seven feet into the wall and then rising
at an angle into an unknown dark
distance
it was up that angle and into that
unknown dark distance
121 years later that Rudolf cantonbrink
sent his robot the technology of our
species having finally caught up with
our powerful instincts to pry those
instincts were clearly no weaker in 1872
than in 1993 among the many interesting
things the remote controlled camera
succeeded in filming in the Queen's
chamber shafts was the far end of a long
sectioned metal rod of 19th century
design which Wayne mendixen and the
faithful Bill Grundy had secretly
stuffed up the Intriguing Channel
predictably they had assumed that if the
pyramid Builders had gone to the trouble
of constructing and then concealing the
shards then they must have hidden
something worth looking for inside them
the notion that there might have been an
intention from the outset to stimulate
such investigations would seem quite
implausible if the final upshot of the
discovery and exploration of the shafts
had been a dead end instead as we've
seen a door was found a sliding Port
Cullis door with curious metal fittings
and an enticing Gap at its base beneath
which the laser spot projected by
gantenbrink's robot was seen to
disappear entire
once again there seemed to be a clear
invitation to proceed further
the latest in a long line of invitations
which had encouraged Khalif Mamoon and
his diggers to break into the central
passageways and Chambers of the monument
which had waited for Wayne man Dixon to
test the hypothesis that the walls of
the Queen's chamber might contain
concealed charts and Richard then waited
again until arousing the Curiosity of
Rudolph gantenbrink whose high-tech
robot revealed the existence of the
hidden door and brought Within Reach
whatever Secrets or disappointments or
further invitations might lie behind it
the Queen's chamber
we shall hear more of Rudolph gantenberg
out in later chapters on the 16th of
March 1993 however knowing nothing of
this I was frustrated to find the
Queen's chamber closed and glared
resentfully through the metal grill that
barred its entrance corridor
I remembered that the height of that
Corridor three feet nine inches was not
constant approximately 110 feet due
south from Where I Stood and only about
15 feet from the entrance to the chamber
a sudden downward step in the floor
increased The Standing Room to five foot
eight inches nobody had come up with a
convincing explanation for this peculiar
feature
the Queen's chamber itself apparently
empty since the day it was built
measured 17 feet two inches from north
to south and 18 feet 10 inches from east
to west
it was equipped with an elegant gabled
ceiling 20 feet 5 inches in height which
lay exactly along the East-West axis of
the pyramid its floor however was the
opposite of elegant and looked
unfinished there was a constant salty
emanation through its pale Refuge
Limestone walls giving rise to much
fruitless speculation
in the North and South walls still
bearing the incised legend opened
1872 where the rectangular apertures
discovered by Wayman Dixon which led
into the dark distance of the mysterious
shafts the Western war was quite bare
offset a little over two feet to the
south of its Center Line the eastern
wall was dominated by a niche in the
form of a Corbell Vault fifteen feet
four inches high and five feet two
inches wide at the base originally three
feet five inches deep a further cavity
had been cut in the back of this niche
in medieval times by Arab treasure
Seekers looking for hidden Chambers they
had found nothing
egyptologists had also been unable to
come to any persuasive conclusions about
the original function of the niche or
for that matter of the Queen's chamber
as a whole
all was confusion all was Paradox all
was mystery
instrument
the grand Gallery had its Mysteries too
indeed it was among the most mysterious
of all the internal features of the
Great Pyramid measuring six feet nine
inches wide at the floor its walls Rose
vertically to a height of seven feet six
inches above that level seven further
courses of masonry each one projecting
inwards some three inches beyond the
course immediately below it carried the
Vault to its full height of 28 feet and
its culminating width of 3 feet 5 inches
remember that structurally the gallery
was required to support forever the
multi-million ton weight of the upper
three-quarters of the largest and
heaviest stone monument ever built on
planet Earth
was it not quite remarkable that a group
of supposed
technological Primitives had not only
envisaged and designed such a feature
but had completed it successfully more
than 4 500 years before our time
even if they had made the gallery only
20 feet long and had sought to erect it
on a level plane the task would have
been difficult enough indeed
extraordinarily difficult but they had
opted to erect this astonishing Corbell
vault at a slope of 26 degrees and to
extend its length to a staggering
153 feet
moreover they had made it with perfectly
dressed Limestone megaliths throughout
huge smoothly polished blocks carved
into sloping parallelograms and laid
together so closely and with such
rigorous Precision that the joints were
almost invisible to the naked eye
the pyramid Builders had also included
some interesting symmetries in their
work for example the culminating width
of The Gallery at its apex was three
feet five inches while it's width that
the floor was six feet nine inches at
the exact center of the floor running
the entire length of the gallery and
sandwiched between flat topped masonry
ramps each one foot eight inches wide
there was a sunken channel two feet deep
and three feet five inches wide what
could have been the purpose of this slot
and why had it been necessary for it to
mirror so precisely the width and form
of the ceiling which also looked like a
slot sandwiched between the two upper
courses of Masonry
I knew that I was not the first person
to have stood at the foot of the grand
gallery and to have been overtaken by
the disorienting sense of being in the
inside of some enormous instrument of
some sort
who was to say that such intuitions were
completely wrong
or for that matter that they were right
no record as to function remained other
than in mystical and symbolic references
in certain ancient Egyptian liturgical
texts these appeared to indicate that
the pyramids had been seen as devices
designed to turn dead men into Immortal
beings to throw open the doors of the
firmament and make a road so that the
deceased Pharaoh might Ascend into the
company of the Gods
I had no difficulty accepting that such
a belief system might have been at work
here and obviously it could have
provided a motive for the whole
Enterprise
nevertheless I was still puzzled by more
than six million tons of physical
apparatus intricately interlaced with
channels and tubes corridors and
Chambers had been deemed necessary to
achieve a mystical spiritual and
symbolic objective
being inside the grand Gallery did feel
like being inside an enormous instrument
it had an undeniable aesthetic impact
upon me admittedly a heavy and
domineering one but it was also
completely devoid of decorative features
and of anything figures of deities
reliefs of liturgical texts and so on
which might be suggestive of worship or
religion the primary impression it
conveyed was one of strict functionalism
and purposefulness as though it had been
built to do a job at the same time I was
aware of its focused solemnity of style
and gravity of manner which seemed to
demand nothing less than Sirius and
complete attention
by now I had climbed steadily through
about half the length of the gallery
ahead of me and behind Shadows and Light
played tricks amid the looming stone
walls
pausing I turned my head looking upwards
through the Gloom towards the vaulted
ceiling which supported the crushing
weight of the Great Pyramid of Egypt
it suddenly hit me how dauntingly and
disturbingly old it was
and how completely my life at this
moment depended on the skills of the
ancient builders
the Hefty blocks that span the distant
ceiling were examples of those skills
every one of them laid at a slightly
steeper gradient than that of the
gallery as the great archaeologist and
surveyor Flinders Petri had observed
this had been done in order that the
lower edge of each Stone should hitch
like a pole into a ratchet cut into the
top of the walls hence no stone compress
on the one below it so as to cause a
cumulative pressure all down the roof
and each stone is separately upheld by
the side walls which it lies across
and this was the work of a people whose
civilization had only recently emerged
from Neolithic hunter-gathering
I began to walk up the gallery once
again using the two foot deep Central
flooring slot a modern wooden covering
fitted with helpful slats and side
railings made the ascent relatively easy
in Antiquity however the floor had been
smoothly polished Limestone which at a
gradient of 26 degrees must have been
almost impossible to climb how had it
been done had it been done at all
looming ahead at the end of the grand
Gallery was the dark opening to The
King's chamber beckoning each and every
inquiring Pilgrim Into the Heart of the
Enigma
chapter 38 interactive three-dimensional
game
reaching the top of the grand Gallery I
clambered over a chunky Granite step
about three feet high I remembered that
it lay like the roof of the Queen's
chamber exactly along the East-West axis
of the Great Pyramid and therefore
marked the point of transition between
the northern and southern halves of the
monument somewhat like an altar in
appearance the step also provided a
solid horizontal platform immediately in
front of the low Square tunnel that
served as the entrance to the king's
chamber
pausing for a moment I looked back down
the gallery taking in once again its
lack of decoration its lack of religious
iconography and its absolute lack of any
of the recognizable symbolism normally
associated with the archaic belief
system of the ancient Egyptians
all that registered upon the eye along
the entire
153-foot length of This Magnificent
geometrical cavity was its disinterested
regularity and its Stark machine-like
simplicity
looking up I could just make out the
opening of a dark aperture chiseled into
the top of the eastern wall above my
head nobody knew when or by whom this
foreboding hole had been cut or how deep
it had originally penetrated
it led to the first of the five
relieving Chambers above the king's
chamber and had been extended in 1837
when Howard Wise had used it to break
through to the remaining four
looking down again I could just make out
the point at the bottom of the gallery's
western wall where the near vertical
well shaft began its precipitous
160-foot descent through the core of the
pyramid to join the descending Corridor
far below ground level
why would such a complicated apparatus
of pipes and passageways have been
required at first sight it didn't make
sense but then nothing about the Great
Pyramid did make sense unless you were
prepared to devote a great deal of
attention to it in unpredictable ways
when you did that it would from time to
time reward you
if you were sufficiently numerous for
example as we've seen it would respond
to your basic inquiries into its height
and base perimeter by printing out the
value of pi and if you were prepared to
investigate further as we shall see it
would download other useful mathematical
tidbits each a little bit more complex
and obstruse than its predecessor there
was a programmed feel about this whole
process as though it had been carefully
pre-arranged
not for the first time I found myself
willing to consider the possibility that
the pyramid might have been designed as
a gigantic challenge or learning machine
or better still as an interactive
three-dimensional puzzle set down in the
desert for Humanity to solve
anti-chamber
just over three feet six inches high the
entry passage to the king's chamber
required All Humans of normal stature to
stoop about four feet further on however
I reached the anti-chamber where the
roof level Rose suddenly to 12 feet
above the floor the East and West walls
of the anti-chamber were composed of red
granite into which were cut four
opposing pairs of wide parallel slots
assumed by egyptologists to have held
thick portcullis slabs
three of these pairs of slots extended
all the way to the floor and were empty
the fourth the northernmost had been cut
down only as far as the roof level of
the entry passage that is three feet six
inches above floor level and still
contained a hulking sheet of granite
perhaps nine inches thick and six feet
high
there was a horizontal space of only 21
inches between this suspended Stone
portcullis and the Northern end of the
entry passage from which I had just
emerged there was also a gap of a little
over two feet deep between the top of
the port Collis and the ceiling whatever
function it was designed to serve it was
hard to agree with the egyptologists
that this peculiar structure could have
been intended to deny access to tomb
Roberts genuinely puzzled I ducked under
it and then stood up again in the
southern portion of the anti-chamber
which was some 10 feet long and
maintained the same roof height of 12
feet
though much worn the grooves for the
three further portcullis slabs were
still visible in the eastern and western
walls there was no sign of the slabs
themselves and indeed it was difficult
to see how such cumbersome pieces of
stone could have been installed in so
severely constricted a working space
I remember that Flinders Petrie who had
systematically surveyed the entire Giza
necropolis in the late 19th century had
commented on a similar puzzle in the
second pyramid the granite port colors
in the lower passage shows great skill
in moving masses as it would need 40 or
60 men to lift it yet it has been moved
and raised into place in a narrow
passage where only a few men could
possibly reach it
exactly the same observations applied to
the port color slabs of the Great
Pyramid if they were port color slabs
gateways capable of being raised and
lowered
the problem was that the physics of
raising and lowering them required that
they be shorter than the full height of
the anti-chamber so that they could be
drawn into the roof space to allow the
entry and exit of legitimate individuals
prior to the closure of the Tomb this
meant of course that when the bottom
edges of the slabs were lowered to the
floor to block the anti-chamber at that
level an equal and opposite space would
have opened up between the top edges of
the slabs and the ceiling through which
any enterprising tomb robber would
certainly have been able to climb
the anti-chamber clearly qualified as
another of the pyramid's many
thought-provoking paradoxes in which
complexity of structure was combined
with apparent pointlessness of function
an exit tunnel the same height and width
as the entrance tunnel and lined with
solid red granite LED off from the
anti-chamber's Southern Wall also made
of granite but incorporating a 12-inch
thick Limestone layer at its very top
after about a further nine feet the
tunnel debauched into the king's chamber
a massive somber Red Room made entirely
of granite which radiated an atmosphere
of prodigious energy and power
Stone enigmas
I moved into the center of the king's
chamber the long axis of which was
perfectly oriented east to west while
the short axis was equally perfectly
oriented north to south
the room was exactly 19 feet one inch in
height and formed a precise 2x1
rectangle measuring 34 feet 4 inches
long by 17 feet 2 inches wide with a
floor consisting of 15 massive Granite
paving stones and walls composed of 100
gigantic Granite blocks each weighing 70
tons or more and laid in five courses
and with a ceiling spanned by nine
further Granite blocks each weighing
approximately 50 tons the effect was of
intense and overwhelming compression
at the chamber's Western end was the
object which if the egyptologists were
to be believed the entire Great Pyramid
had been built to house
that object carved out of one piece of
dark chocolate colored granite
containing peculiarly hard granules of
feldspar quartz and Mica was the
littlest Coffer presumed to have been
the sarcophagus of Khufu its interior
measurements were six feet 6.6 inches in
length 2 feet 10.42 inches in depth and
2 feet 2.81 inches in width its exterior
measurements were 7 feet
5.62 inches in length 3 feet 5.31 inches
in depth and 3 feet 2.5 inches in width
an inch too wide incidentally for it to
have been carried up through the lower
and now plugged entrance to the
ascending corridor
some routine mathematical games were
built into the dimensions of the
sarcophagus for example it had an
internal volume of
1166.4 liters and an external volume of
exactly twice that at
2332.8 liters
such a precise coincidence could not
have been arrived at accidentally the
walls of the Coffer had been cut to
Machine Age tolerances by Craftsmen of
enormous skill and experience
seemed more over as Flinders Petri
admitted with some puzzlement after
completing his painstaking survey of the
Great Pyramid that these Craftsmen had
access to tools such as we ourselves
have only now reinvented
Petrie examined the sarcophagus
particularly closely and reported that
it must have been cut out of its
surrounding Granite block with straight
sores eight feet or more in length
since the granite was extremely hard he
could only assume that these swords must
have had bronze blades the hardest metal
then supposedly available in set with
cutting points made of even harder
jewels the character of the work would
certainly seem to point to Diamond as
being The Cutting Jewel and only the
considerations of its Rarity in general
and its absence from Egypt interfere
with this conclusion
an even bigger mystery surrounded the
hollowing out of the sarcophagus
obviously a far more difficult
Enterprise than separating it from a
block of bedrock here Petrie concluded
that the Egyptians must have adapted
their sawing principle into a circular
instead of a rectilinear form curving
the blade round into a tube which
drilled out a circular groove by its
rotation thus by breaking away the cores
left in such grooves they were able to
hollow out large holes with a minimum of
Labor these tubular drills varied from
one quarter of an inch to five inches
diameter and from 1 30th to one-fifth of
an inch thick
of course as Petrie admitted no actual
jeweled drills or saws had ever been
found by egyptologists
the visible evidence of the kinds of
drilling and sawing that had been done
however compelled him to infer that such
instruments must have existed he became
especially interested in this and
extended his study to include not only
the king's chamber sarcophagus but many
other Granite artifacts and granite
drill cores which he collected at Giza
the deeper his research however the more
puzzling the stone cutting technology of
the ancient Egyptians became
the amount of pressure
shown by the rapidity with which the
drills and soars pierced through the
hard Stones is very surprising Petrie
reported
probably a load of at least a ton or two
was placed on the four inch drills
cutting in Granite
on the granite core number seven the
spiral of the cut sinks one inch in the
circumference of six inches a rate of
plowing out which is astonishing these
rapid spiral grooves cannot be ascribed
to anything but The Descent of the drill
into the granite under enormous pressure
wasn't it peculiar that at the supposed
dawn of human civilization more than 4
500 years ago the ancient Egyptians had
acquired what sounded like Industrial
Age drills packing a ton or more of
punch and capable of slicing through
hard Stones like hot knives through
butter
Petrie could come up with no explanation
for this conundrum nor was he able to
explain the kind of instrument used to
cut hieroglyphs into a number of diorite
bowls with fourth Dynasty inscriptions
which he found at Giza the hieroglyphs
are incised with a very free cutting
point they are not scraped or ground out
but are plowed through the diorite with
rough edges to the line
this bothered The Logical Petri because
he knew that diorite was one of the
hardest stones on Earth
far harder even than iron
yet here it was in ancient Egypt being
cut with incredible power and precision
by some as yet unidentified braving tool
as the lines are only one 150th of an
inch wide Petri reported it is evident
that the cutting Point must have been
much harder than quartz and tough enough
not to Splinter when so final Edge was
being employed
probably only one two hundredths of an
inch wide parallel lines are graved only
one thirtieth of an inch apart from
Center to Center
in other words Petrie was envisaging an
instrument with a needle sharp point of
exceptional unprecedented hardness
capable of penetrating and furrowing
diorite with ease and capable also of
withstanding the enormous pressures
required throughout the operation what
sort of instrument was that by what
means would the pressure have been
applied how could sufficient accuracy
have been maintained to scour parallel
lines at intervals of just one thirtieth
of an inch
at least it was possible to conjure a
mental picture of the circular drills
with jeweled teeth which Petrie supposed
must have been used to hollow out the
king's chamber sarcophagus
I found however that it was not so easy
to do the same for the unknown
instrument capable of incising
hieroglyphs into diorite at 2500 BC at
any rate not without assuming the
existence of a far higher level of
Technology than egyptologists were
prepared to consider
nor was it just a few hieroglyphs or a
few diorite bowls during my travels in
Egypt I had examined many Stone vessels
dating back in some cases to
pre-dynastic times that had been
mysteriously hollowed out of a range of
materials such as diorite Basalt quartz
crystal and metamorphic schist
for example more than 30 000 such
vessels had been found in the chambers
beneath the third Dynasty step pyramid
of zoso at Sakara
that meant that they were at least as
old as zoso himself in other words
around
2650 BC theoretically they could have
been even older than that because
identical vessels had been found in
pre-dynastic strata dated to 4000 BC and
earlier and because the practice of
handing down treasured heirlooms from
generation to generation had been deeply
ingrained in Egypt since time immemorial
whether they were made in 2500 BC or
4000 BC or even earlier the stone
vessels from the step pyramid were
remarkable for their workmanship which
once again seemed to have been
accomplished by some as yet unimagined
and indeed almost unimaginable tool why
unimaginable
because many of the vessels were tall
vases with long thin elegant necks and
widely flared Interiors often
incorporating fully hollowed out
shoulders no instrument yet invented was
capable of carving vases into shapes
like these because such an instrument
would have had to have been narrow
enough to have passed through the necks
and strong enough and of the right shape
to have scoured out the shoulders and
the rounded interiors and how could
sufficient upward and outward pressure
have been generated and applied within
the vases to achieve these effects
the tall vases were by no means the only
enigmatic vessels Unearthed from the
Pyramid of zosur and from a number of
other archaic sites
there were monolithic urns with delicate
ornamental handles left attached to
their exteriors by the Carvers there
were bowls again with extremely narrow
necks like the vases and with widely
flared pot-bellied Interiors there were
also open bowls and almost microscopic
vials and occasional strange
wheel-shaped objects cut out of
metamorphic shift with inwardly curled
edges plain down so fine that they were
almost translucent
in all cases what was really perplexing
was the Precision with which the
interiors and the exteriors of these
vessels had been made to correspond
curve-matching curve over absolutely
smooth polished surfaces with no tool
marks visible there was no technology
known to have been available to the
ancient Egyptians capable of achieving
such results nor for that matter would
any stone Carver today be able to match
them even if he were working with the
best tungsten carbide tools the
implication therefore is that an unknown
or secret technology had been put to use
in ancient Egypt
ceremony of the sarcophagus
standing in the king's chamber facing
west the direction of death amongst both
the ancient Egyptians and the Maya I
rested my hands lightly on the gnarled
granite edge of the sarcophagus which
egyptologists insist had been built to
house the body of Khufu I gazed into its
murky depths where the dim electric
lighting of the chamber seemed hardly to
penetrate and saw specks of dust
swirling in a golden cloud
it was just a trick of light and Shadow
of course but the king's chamber was
full of such Illusions I remembered that
Napoleon Bonaparte had paused to spend
the night alone here during his conquest
of Egypt in the late 18th century the
next morning he had emerged pale and
shaking having experienced something
which had profoundly Disturbed him but
about which he never afterwards spoke
had he tried
sleep in the sarcophagus
acting on impulse I climbed into the
granite Coffer and laid down face
upwards my feet pointed towards the
South and my head to the north
Napoleon was a little guy so he must
have fitted comfortably there was plenty
of room for me too
but had Khufu been here as well
I relaxed and tried not to worry about
the possibility of one of the pyramid
guards coming in and finding me in this
embarrassing and probably illegal
position
hoping that I would remain undisturbed
for a few minutes I folded my hands
across my chest and gave voice to a
sustained low-pitched tone something I
had tried out several times before at
other points in the king's chamber on
those occasions in the center of the
floor I had noticed that the walls and
ceilings seemed to collect the sound to
gather and to amplify it and project it
back at me so that I could sense the
returning vibrations through my feet and
scalp and skin
now in the sarcophagus I was aware of
very much the same effect although
seemingly Amplified and concentrated
many times over
it was like being in the sound box of
some giant resonant musical instrument
designed to emit forever just one
reverberating note
sound was intense and quite disturbing I
imagined it rising out of the Coffer and
bouncing off the red granite walls and
ceiling of the king's chamber shooting
up through the northern and southern
ventilation shafts and spreading across
the Giza Plateau like a Sonic mushroom
cloud
with this ambitious Vision in my mind
and with the sound of my low pitched
note echoing in my ears and causing the
sarcophagus to vibrate around me I
closed my eye
when I opened them a few minutes later
it was to Behold a distressing song
six Japanese tourists of mixed ages and
Sexes had congregated around the
sarcophagus two of them standing to the
east two to the west and one each to the
North and South they all looked amazed
and I was amazed to see them because of
recent attacks by armed Islamic
extremists there were now almost no
tourist at Giza and I had expected to
have the king's chambered to myself
what does one do in a situation like
this
Gathering as much dignity as I could
muster I stood upright smiling and
dusted myself off the Japanese stepped
back and I climbed out of the
sarcophagus cultivating a business-like
manner as though I did things like this
all the time I strolled to the point
two-thirds of the way along the northern
wall of the king's chamber were the
entrance to what egyptologists refer to
as the northern ventilation shaft is
located and began to examine it minutely
some eight inches wide by nine inches
high it was I knew more than 200 feet in
length and emerged into open air at the
pyramid's 103rd course of Masonry
presumably by Design rather than by
accident it pointed to the circumpolar
regions of the northern Heavens at an
angle of 32 degrees 30 minutes this in
the pyramid age around 2500 BC would
have meant that it was directed on the
upper culmination of alpha draconis a a
prominent star in the constellation of
Draco
much to my relief the Japanese rapidly
completed their tour of the king's
chamber and left stooping without a
backward glance as soon as they had gone
I crossed over to the other side of the
room to take a look at the southern
charm since I had last been here some
months before its appearance had changed
horribly its mouth now contained a
massive electrical air conditioning unit
installed by Rudolph gantenbrink who
even now was turning his intentions to
the neglected shafts of the Queen's
chamber
since egyptologists were satisfied that
the king's chamber shafts had been built
for ventilation purposes they saw
nothing untoward in using modern
technology to improve the efficiency of
this task
yet wouldn't horizontal shafts have been
more effective than sloping ones if
their primary purpose had been
ventilation and easier to build
it was therefore unlikely to be an
accident that the southern shaft of the
king's chamber targeted the southern
Heavens at 45 degrees during the pyramid
age this was the location for the
Meridian Transit of Zita orionis the
lowest of the three stars of Orion's
Belt an alignment I was to discover in
due course that would turn out to be of
the utmost significance for future
pyramid research
the game master
now that I had the chamber to myself
again I walked over to the Western Wall
on the far side of the sarcophagus and
turned to face East
the huge room had an endless capacity to
generate indications of mathematical
gameplay for example its height 19 feet
1 inch was exactly half the length of
its floor diagonal 38 feet 2 inches
moreover since the king's chamber formed
a perfect 1x2 rectangle was it
conceivable that the pyramid Builders
were unaware that they had also made it
express and exemplify the golden section
known as Phi the golden section was
another irrational number like Pi that
could not be worked out arithmetically
its value was the square root of five
plus one divided by two equivalent to
1.61803 this proved to be the limiting
value of the ratio between successive
numbers in the Fibonacci series the
series of numbers beginning naught 1 1 2
3 5 8 13 in which each term is the sum
of the two previous terms
Phi could also be obtained schematically
by dividing a line A to B at a point C
in such a way that the whole line A to B
was longer than the first part a to c in
the same proportion as the first part a
to c was longer than the remainder C to
B this proportion which had been proven
particularly harmonious and agreeable to
the eye had supposedly been first
discovered by the Pythagorean Greeks who
Incorporated it into the Parthenon at
Athens there is absolutely no doubt
however that Phi was Illustrated and
obtained at least two thousand years
previously in the king's chamber of the
great pyramid at Giza to understand how
it is necessary to envisage the
rectangular floor of the chamber as
being divided into two imaginary squares
of the equal size with the side length
of each Square being given a value of
one if either of these two squares were
then split in half thus forming two new
rectangles and if the diagonal of the
rectangle nearest to the center line of
the king's chamber were swung down to
the base the point where its tip touch
the base would be Phi or 1.618 in
relation to the side length that is one
of the original Square
the egyptologists considered all this
was pure chance yet the pyramid Builders
had done nothing by chance
whoever they had been I found it hard to
imagine more systematic and
mathematically minded people
I'd had quite enough of their
mathematical games for one day as I left
the king's chamber however I could not
forget that it was located in line with
the 50th course of the Great Pyramids
masonry at a height of almost 150 feet
above the ground
this meant as Flinders Petri pointed out
with some astonishment that the builders
had managed to place it at the level
where the vertical section of the
pyramid was half and where the area of
the horizontal section was half that of
the base where the diagonal from corner
to corner was equal to the length of the
base and where the width of the face was
equal to half the diagonal of the base
confidently and efficiently fooling
around with more than six million tons
of stone creating Galleries and Chambers
and shafts and corridors more or less at
will achieving near perfect symmetry
near perfect right angles and near
perfect alignments to the cardinal
points the mysterious Builders of the
Great Pyramid had found the time to play
a great many other tricks as well with
the dimensions of the vast Monument
why did their minds work this way what
had they been trying to say or do and
why so many thousands of years after it
was built did the monument still exert a
magnetic influence upon so many people
from so many different walks of life who
came into contact with it
there was a sphinx in the neighborhood
so I decided that I would put these
riddles to it
chapter 39. place of the beginning
Giza Egypt 16th of March 1993
30 pm
it was mid-afternoon by the time I left
the Great Pyramid retracing the route
that Santa and I had followed the night
before when we climbed the monument I
walked eastwards along the northern face
southwards along the flank of the
Eastern face clambered over mounds of
rubble and ancient tombs that clustered
closely in this part of the necropolis
and came out onto the sand covered
Limestone Bedrock of the Giza Plateau
which sloped down towards the south and
east
at the bottom of this long gentle slope
about half a kilometer from the
Southeastern corner of the Great Pyramid
the Sphinx crouched in his raccoon pit
66 feet high and more than 240 feet long
with a head measuring 13 feet 8 inches
wide he was by a considerable margin the
largest single piece of sculpture in the
world and the most renowned
a shape with Lion body and the head of a
man a gaze blank and pitiless as the sun
approaching the monument from the
Northwest I crossed the ancient Causeway
that connected the second pyramid with
the so-called Valley Temple of Cafe a
most unusual structure located just 50
feet south of the Sphinx itself on the
Eastern edge of the Giza necropolis
this Temple had long been believed to be
far older than the time of kafri indeed
throughout much of the 19th century the
consensus among Scholars was that it had
been built in remote prehistory and had
nothing to do with the architecture of
dynastic Egypt
what changed all that was the discovery
buried within the temple precincts of a
number of inscribed statues of Cafe most
were pretty badly smashed but one found
upside down in a deep pit in an
anti-chamber was almost intact
life-sized and exquisitely carved out of
black Jewel hard diorite it showed the
fourth Dynasty Pharaoh Seated on his
throne gazing with Serene indifference
towards Infinity
at this point the razor sharp reasoning
of egyptology was brought to bear and
the solution of almost all inspiring
Brilliance was worked out
statues of Catherine had been found in
the valley Temple therefore the valley
Temple had been built by Caffrey
the normally sensible Flinders Petri
summed up the fact that the only
dateable remains found in the temple
were statues of Cafe shows that it is of
his period
since the idea of his appropriating an
earlier building is very unlikely
but why was the idea so unlikely
throughout the history of dynastic Egypt
many pharaohs appropriated the buildings
of their predecessors sometimes
deliberately striking out the Cartouche
of the original Builders and replacing
them with their own there was no good
reason to assume that cafrei would have
been deterred from linking himself to
the valley Temple particularly if it had
not been associated in his mind with any
previous historical ruler but with the
great Gods said by the ancient Egyptians
to have brought civilization to the Nile
Valley in the distant and mythical Epoch
they spoke of as the first time in such
a place of archaic and mysterious power
which he does not appear to have
interfered with in any other way kafri
might have thought that the setting up
of beautiful and lifelike statues of
himself could bring Eternal benefits and
if among the gods the valley Temple had
been associated with Osiris whom it was
every Pharaoh's objective to join in the
afterlife carfrey's use of statues to
forge a strong symbolic link would be
even more understandable
Temple of the Giants
after crossing the causeway the route I
had chosen to reach the valley Temple
took me through the rubble of a mustaba
field where lesser notables of the
fourth Dynasty had been buried in
Subterranean tombs under bench-shaped
platforms of stone mastaba is a modern
Arabic word meaning bench hence the name
given to these two
I walked along the southern wall of the
temple itself recalling that this
ancient building was almost as perfectly
oriented north to south as was the Great
Pyramid with an era of just 12 arc
minutes
the temple was Square in Plath
147 feet along each side it was built
into the slope of the plateau which was
higher in the west than in the east in
consequence while its Western walls
stood only a little over 20 feet tall
its eastern raw exceeded 40 feet
viewed from the south the impression was
of a wedge-shaped structure Squat and
Powerful resting firmly on Bedrock a
closer examination revealed that it
Incorporated several characteristics
quite alien and inexplicable to the
modern eye which must have seemed almost
as alien and inexplicable to the ancient
Egyptians
or a start there was the Stark absence
both inside and out of inscriptions and
other identifying marks
in this respect as The Listener will
appreciate the valley Temple could be
compared with a few of the other
Anonymous and frankly Undateable
monuments on the Giza Plateau including
the Great Pyramids and also with a
mysterious structure at abidos known as
the asarion which we consider in detail
in a later chapter but otherwise bore no
resemblance to the typical and
well-known products of ancient Egyptian
art and architecture all copiously
decorated embellished and inscribed
another important and unusual feature of
the valley Temple was that its core
structure was built entirely
entirely of gigantic limestone megaliths
the majority of these measured about 18
feet long by 10 feet wide by eight feet
high and somewhere as large as 30 feet
long by 12 feet wide by 10 feet high
routinely exceeding 100 tons in weight
each was heavier than a modern diesel
locomotive and there were hundreds of
blocks was this in any way mysterious
egyptologists did not seem to think so
indeed few of them had bothered to
comment except in the most superficial
manner either on the Staggering size of
these blocks or the mind-bending
logistics of how they might have been
put in place as we have seen monoliths
of up to 70 tons each about as heavy as
100 family-sized cars had been lifted to
the level of the king's chamber in the
Great Pyramid again without provoking
much comment from the egyptological
fraternity so the lack of curiosity
about the valley Temple was perhaps no
surprise nevertheless the block size was
truly extraordinary seeming to belong
not just to another Epoch but to another
ethic altogether one that reflected
incomprehensible aesthetic and
structural concerns and suggested a
scale of priorities utterly different
from our own why for example insist on
using these cumbersome monoliths when
you could simply slice each of them up
into 10 or 20 or 40 or 80 smaller and
more maneuverable blocks why make things
so difficult for yourself when you could
achieve much the same visual effect with
much less effort
and how had the Builders of the valley
Temple lifted these colossal megaliths
to Heights of more than 40 feet
at present there are only two land-based
cranes in the world that could lift
weights of this magnitude at the very
frontiers of construction technology
these are both vast industrialized
machines with booms reaching more than
220 feet into the air which require
on-board counterweights of 160 tons to
prevent them from tipping over the
preparation time for a single lift is
around six weeks and calls for the
skills of specialized teams of up to 20
men
in other words Modern Builders with all
the advantages of high-tech engineering
at their disposal can barely hoist such
huge weights was it not therefore
somewhat surprising that the builders at
Giza had hoisted such weights on an
almost routine basis
moving closer to the Temple's looming
Southern Wall I observed something else
about the huge Limestone blocks not only
were they ridiculously large but as
though to complicate still further and
almost impossible task they had been cut
and fitted into multi-angle jigsaw
puzzle patterns similar to those
employed in the cyclopian stone
structures at Saxe huaman and Machu
Picchu in Peru
another point I noticed was that the
temple walls appeared to have been
constructed in two stages the first
stage most of which was intact though
deeply eroded consisted of the strong
and heavy core of megalithic Limestone
blocks onto both sides of these had been
grafted a facade of dressed Granite
which as we shall see was largely intact
in the interior of the building but had
mainly Fallen away on the outside
a closer look at some of the remaining
exterior facing blocks where they had
become detached from the core revealed a
curious fact when they had been placed
here in Antiquity the backs of these
blocks had been cut to fit into and
around the Deep coves and scallops of
existing weathering patterns on the
Limestone core
the presence of those patterns seemed to
imply that the core blocks must have
stood here exposed to the elements for
an immense span of time before they had
been faced with granite
Lord of rostow
I now moved around to the entrance of
the valley Temple located near the
Northern end of the 43-foot high eastern
wall
here I saw that the granite facing was
still in perfect condition consisting of
huge slabs weighing between 70 and 80
tons apiece which protected the
underlying Limestone core blocks like a
suit of armor incorporating a tall
narrow ruthless Corridor this dark and
imposing portal ran east to west at
first then made a right angle turn to
the South leading me into a spacious
anti-chamber it was here that the
life-sized diorite statue of Caffrey had
been found upside down and apparently
ritually buried at the bottom of a deep
pit
lining the entire interior of the
anti-chamber was a majestic jigsaw
puzzle of smoothly polished Granite
facing blocks which continued through
the whole building
exactly like the blocks on some of the
bigger and more bizarre pre-inker
monuments in Peru these Incorporated
multiple finely chiseled angles in the
joints and presented a complex overall
pattern of particular note was the way
certain blocks wrapped around corners
and were received by re-entering angles
cut into other blocks
from the anti-chamber I passed through
an elegant Corridor which led West into
a spacious t-shaped Hall
I found myself standing at the head of
the T looking further westwards along an
imposing Avenue of Monolithic columns
reaching almost 15 feet in height and
measuring 41 inches on each side all
these columns supported Granite beams
which were again 41 inches square a row
of six further columns also supporting
beams ran along the north-south axis of
the T the overall effect was of massive
but refined simplicity
what was this building for
according to the egyptologists who
attributed it to Cafe its purpose was
obvious it had been designed they said
as a venue for certain of the
purification and rebirth rituals
required for the funeral of the Pharaoh
the ancient Egyptians themselves however
had left no inscriptions confirming this
on the contrary the only written
evidence that has come down to us
indicated that the valley Temple could
not originally at any rate have had
anything to do with coffrey for the
simple reason that it was built before
his Reign this written evidence is the
inventory Stellar referred to in chapter
35 which also indicated a much greater
age for the Great Pyramid and the Sphinx
what the inventory Stella had to say
about the valley Temple was that it had
been standing during the reign of
Caffrey's predecessor Khufu when it had
been regarded not as a recent but as a
remotely ancient building moreover it
was clear from the context that it was
not thought to have been the work of any
earlier pharaoh instead it was believed
to have come down from the first time
and to have been built by the gods who
had settled in the Nile Valley in that
remote epoch it was referred to quite
explicitly as the house of Osiris Lord
of roster rosto being an archaic name
for the Giza necropolis as we shall see
in part 7 Osiris was in many respects
the Egyptian counterpart of veracocha
and Quetzalcoatl the civilizing deities
of the Andes and of Central America with
them he shared not only a common Mission
but a vast Heritage of common symbolism
seemed appropriate therefore that the
house or Sanctuary or Temple of such a
wise teacher and law Giver should have
been established at Giza within sight of
the Great Pyramid and in the immediate
vicinity of the Great Sphinx
vastly remotely fabulously ancient
following the directions given in the
inventory Stellar which stated that the
Sphinx lay on the north west of the
House of Osiris I made my way to the
North End of the Western Wall that
enclosed the valley Temple's t-shaped
Hall I passed through a monolithic
doorway and entered a long sloping
Alabaster floored Corridor also oriented
Northwest which eventually opened out
onto the lower end of the causeway that
led up to the second pyramid from the
edge of the causeway I had an unimpeded
view of the Sphinx immediately to my
North
as long as a city block as high as a
six-story building it was perfectly
oriented due east and thus faced the
Rising Sun on the two equinoxual days of
the year man-headed
lion-bodied crouched as though ready at
last to move its slow thighs after
Millennia of Stony sleep it had been
carved in one piece out of a single
Ridge of limestone on a site that must
have been meticulously pre-selected
the exceptional characteristic of this
site as well as overlooking the Valley
of the Nile was that its geological
makeup Incorporated a null of Hard Rock
jutting at least 30 feet above the
general level of the Limestone Ridge
from this null the head and neck of the
Sphinx had been carved while beneath it
the vast rectangle of limestone that
would be shaped into the body had been
isolated from the surrounding bedroom
the builders had done this by Excavating
an 18 foot wide 25 foot deep trench all
around it creating a freestanding
monolith
First and Lasting Impression of the
Sphinx and of its enclosure is that it
is very very old not a mere handful of
thousands of years like the fourth
Dynasty Egyptian pharaohs but vastly
remotely fabulously old this was how the
ancient Egyptians in all periods of
their history regarded the monument
which they believed guarded The Splendid
place of the beginning of all time and
which they revered as the focus of a
great magical power extending over the
whole region
this as we have already seen is the
general message of the inventory Stellar
more specifically it is also the message
of the Sphinx Stella erected here in
around 1400 BC but Moses IV an 18th
Dynasty Pharaoh still standing between
the pores of the Sphinx this Granite
tablet records that prior to the closest
rule the monument had been covered up to
its neck in sand that Moses liberated it
by clearing all the sand and erected the
Stellar to commemorate his work
there have been no significant changes
in the climate of the Giza Plateau over
the last five thousand years it
therefore follows that throughout this
entire period the Sphinx enclosure must
have been as susceptible to sand
encroachment as when that Moses cleared
it and indeed as it still is today
recent history proves that the enclosure
can fill up rapidly if left unattended
in 1818 Captain caviglia had it cleared
of sand for the purposes of his
excavations and in 1886 when Gaston
maspero came to re-excavate the site he
was obliged to have it cleared of sand
once again
39 years later in 1925 the Sands had
returned in full force and the Sphinx
was buried to its neck when the
Egyptians serviced their Antiquities
undertook its clearance and restoration
once more
does this not suggest that the climate
could have been very different when the
Sphinx enclosure was carved out what
would have been the sense of creating
this immense statue if its destiny were
merely to be engulfed by the shifting
Sands of the Eastern Sahara however
since the Sahara is a young desert and
since the Giza area in particular was
wet and relatively fertile eleven
thousand to fifteen thousand years ago
is not worth considering another
scenario altogether is it not possible
that the Sphinx enclosure was carved out
during Those Distant green Millennia
when topsoil was still anchored to the
surface of the plateau by the roots of
grasses and shrubs and when what is now
a desert of wind-blown sand more closely
resembled the rolling Savannahs of
modern Kenya and Tanzania
under such congenial climatic conditions
the creation of a semi-subterranean
monument like the Sphinx would not have
outraged common sense the builders would
have had no reason to anticipate the
slow desiccation and desertification of
the plateau that would ultimately follow
yet Is it feasible to imagine that the
Sphinx could have been built when Giza
was still green long long ago
as we shall see such ideas are anathema
to Modern egyptologists who are
nevertheless obliged to admit to quote
Dr Mark laner director of the Giza
mapping project that there is no direct
way to date the Sphinx itself because
the Sphinx is carved right out of
natural rock
in the absence of more objective tests
Selena went on to point out
archaeologists had to date things by
context and the context of the Sphinx
that is the Giza necropolis a well-known
fourth Dynasty site made it obvious that
the Sphinx belonged to the fourth
Dynasty as well
such reasoning was not regarded as
axiomatic by Elena's distinguished
predecessors in the 19th century who
were at one time convinced that the
Sphinx long predated the fourth Dynasty
whose Sphinx Is It Anyway
in his passing of Empires published in
1900 the distinguished French
egyptologist Gaston maspero who made a
special study of the content of the
Sphinx Stellar erected by thotnosis IV
wrote the Stellar of the Sphinx Bears on
line 13 the Cartouche of khafrei in the
middle of a gap there I believe is an
indication of a renovation and clearance
of the Sphinx carried out under this
Prince and consequently the more or less
certain proof that the Sphinx was
already covered with Sam during the time
of Khufu and his predecessors the
equally distinguished Auguste Marriott
agreed naturally enough since he had
been the finder of the inventory Stellar
which as we've seen asserted
matter-of-factly that the Sphinx was
standing on the Giza Plateau long before
the time of Khufu also generally
concurring were Brooks Egypt under the
Pharaohs London 1891 Petrie seis and
many other eminent Scholars of the
travel writers such as John Ward
affirmed that the Great Sphinx must be
numberless years older even than the
pyramids and as late as 1904 Wallace
budge the respected keeper of Egyptian
Antiquities at the British museum had no
hesitation in making this unequivocal
assertion the oldest and finest
human-headed lion statue is the famous
Sphinx at Giza
this marvelous object was in existence
in the days of Cafe the builder of the
second pyramid and was most probably
very old even at that early period the
Sphinx was thought to be connected in
some way with foreigners or with a
foreign religion which dated from
pre-dynastic times
between the beginning and the end of the
20th century however egyptologists views
about the Antiquity of the Sphinx
changed dramatically
today there is not a single Orthodox
egyptologist who would even discuss let
alone consider seriously the Wild and
irresponsible suggestion once a
commonplace that the Sphinx might have
been built thousands of years before
Caffrey's reign according to Dr zahi
awas for example director of Giza and
Sakara for the Egyptian Antiquities
organization many such theories have
been put forward but have Gone With the
Wind because we egyptologists have solid
evidence to state that the Sphinx is
dated to the time of Catherine likewise
Carol Redmond an archaeologist at the
University of California's Barclay
campus was incredulous when it was
suggested to her that the Sphinx might
be thousands of years older than Cafe
there is just no way that could be true
she protested the people of that region
would not have had the technology the
governing institutions or even the will
to build such a structure thousands of
years before cafres reign when I first
started to research this issue I had
assumed as hawas appeared to claim that
some incontrovertible new evidence must
have been found which had settled the
identity of The Monument's builders this
was not the case indeed there are only
three contextual reasons why the
construction of the anonymous
uninscribed and enigmatic Sphinx is now
so confidently attributed to kafri one
because of the Cartouche of cafrei on
line 13 of the Sphinx Stellar erected by
thudmosis IV
maspero gave a perfectly reasonable
explanation for the presence of this
Cartouche that Moses had been a restorer
of the Sphinx and had paid due tribute
to an earlier restoration of the
monument one undertaking during the
fourth Dynasty by cafre this explanation
which Bears the obvious implication that
the Sphinx must already have been old in
cafres time is rejected by modern
egyptologists with their usual
telepathic like-mindedness they now
agree that tutmosis put the Cartouche on
the Stella to recognize that cuffre had
been the original Builder and not a mere
restorer
since there had only ever been this
single Cartouche and since the texts on
either side of it were missing when the
Stellar was excavated is it not a little
premature to come to such hard and fast
conclusions what sort of science is it
that allows the mere presence of the
Cartouche of a fourth Dynasty Pharaoh on
a Stella erected by an 18th Dynasty
pharaoh to determine the entire
identification of an otherwise Anonymous
Monument besides even that Cartouche has
now flaked off and cannot be examined
2 because the valley Temple next door is
also attributed to covering that
attribution based on statues which may
well have been intrusive is shaky to say
the least it has nevertheless received
the wholehearted endorsement of
egyptologists who in the process decided
to attribute the Sphinx to cafrei II
since the Sphinx and the valley Temple
are so obviously connected
3 because the face of the Sphinx is
thought to resemble the intact statue of
kafri found in the pit of the valley
Temple this of course is a matter of
opinion I have never seen the slightest
resemblance between the two faces nor
for that matter had forensic artists
from the New York Police Department who
had recently been brought in to do an
identicate comparison between the Sphinx
and the statue all in all therefore as I
stood overlooking the Sphinx in the late
afternoon of the 16th of March 1993 I
considered that the jury was still very
much out on the correct attribution of
this Monument either to kafri on the one
hand or to The Architects of an as yet
unidentified High civilization of
prehistoric Antiquity on the other
no matter what the current flavor of the
month or Century happened to be with the
egyptologists the fact was that both
scenarios were plausible what was needed
therefore was some completely hard and
unambiguous evidence which would settle
the matter one way or the other
part 7 Lord of Eternity
Egypt section 2.
chapter 40 are there any secrets left in
Egypt
during the early evening of the 26th of
November 1922 the British archaeologist
Howard Carter together with his sponsor
Lord carnarvon entered the tomb of a
youthful pharaoh of the 18th Dynasty who
had ruled Egypt from 1 352 to
1343 BC the name of that Pharaoh which
has since resounded around the world was
Tutankhamun
two nights later on the 28th of November
the tomb's treasury was breached it was
filled with a huge golden Shrine and
gave access to another chamber Beyond
rather unusually this chamber although
heaped with a dazzling array of Precious
and Beautiful artifacts had no door its
entrance was washed over by an
extraordinarily lifelike Effigy Of The
jackal-headed Mortuary god Anubis
with his ears erect the god crouched
dog-like Poor Paws stretched out on the
lid of a gilded wooden casket perhaps
four feet long three feet high and two
feet wide
the Egyptian Museum Cairo December 1993.
still pushed to stride his casket but
now locked away in a Dusty glass display
case Anubis held my attention for a long
quiet moment his Effigy had been carved
out of stuccoed wood entirely covered
with black resin and then painstakingly
inlaid with gold Alabaster carlsite
obsidian and silver materials used to
particular effect in the eyes which
glittered watchfully
with an unsettling sense of Fierce and
focused intelligence a at the same time
his finely etched ribs and live
musculature gave off an aura of
understated strength energy and Grace
captured by the force field of this
occult and Powerful presence I was
vividly reminded of the universal myths
of precession I had been studying during
the past year
canine figures moved back and forth
among these myths in a manner which at
times had seemed almost plotted in the
literary sense I had begun to wonder
whether the symbolism of dogs wolves
jackals and so on might have been
deliberately employed by the long dead
mythmakers to guide initiates through a
maze of Clues to secret reservoirs of
lost scientific knowledge
amongst these reservoirs I suspected was
the myth of Osiris
much more than a myth it had been
dramatized and performed each year in
ancient Egypt in the form of a mystery
play a plotted literary artifact passed
down as a treasured tradition since
prehistoric time
this tradition as we saw in part 5
contained values for the rate of
precessional motion that were so
accurate and so consistent it was
extremely difficult to attribute them to
chance nor did it seem likely to be an
accident that the Jackal gold had been
assigned a role center stage in the
drama serving as the spirit guide of
Osiris on his journey through the
underworld
it was tempting too to wonder whether
there was any significance in the fact
that in ancient times Anubis had been
referred to by Egyptian priests as the
guardian of the of the secret and sacred
writings
under the grooved edge of the Gilded
casket on which his Effigy now crouched
was found in inscription initiated into
the secrets alternative translations of
the same hieroglyphic text rendered it
variously as he who is upon the secrets
and as guardian of the secrets but were
there any secrets left in Egypt after
More Than A Century of intensive
archaeological investigations could the
sounds of this antique land yield any
further surprises
boval's stars and West's stones
in 1993 there was an astonishing new
discovery which suggested that there was
much still to learn about ancient Egypt
the discoverer moreover was not some
astigmatic archaeologist sieving his way
through the dust of Ages but an outsider
to the field Robert boval a Belgian
construction engineer with a flair for
astronomy who observed a correlation in
the sky that the experts had missed in
their fixation with the ground at their
feet
what bhaval saw was this as the three
belt stars of the Orion constellation
crossed the Meridian at Giza they lay in
a not quite straight line high in the
southern Heavens the lower two stars
al-nitak and al-nilam formed a perfect
diagonal but the third star mintaka
appeared to be offset to The Observers
left that is towards the east
curiously enough as we saw in chapter 36
this was exactly the site plan of the
three enigmatic pyramids of the Giza
plateau boval realized that an aerial
view of the Giza necropolis would show
the Great Pyramid of Khufu occupying the
position of arnitak and the second
pyramid of carfrey occupying the
position of al-nilam while the third
pyramid of menkaare was offset to the
east of the diagonal formed by the other
two thus completing what seemed at first
to be a vast diagram of the Stars
was this indeed what the Giza Pyramids
represented I knew that bovard's later
work which had been wholeheartedly
endorsed by mathematicians and
astronomers had borne out his inspired
hunch his evidence reviewed fully in
chapter 49 showed that the three
pyramids were an unbelievably precise
terrestrial map of the three stars of
Orion's Belt accurately reflecting the
angles between each of them and even by
means of their respective sizes
providing some indication of their
individual magnitudes moreover this map
extended outwards to the North and South
to Encompass several other structures on
the Giza Plateau once again with
fulfur's Precision however the real
surprise revealed by boval's
astronomical calculations was this
despite the fact that some aspects of
the Great Pyramid did relate
astronomically to the pyramid age the
Giza monuments as a whole were so
arranged as to provide a picture of the
Skies which altered their appearance
down the ages as a result of procession
of the equinoxes not as they had looked
in the fourth Dynasty around 2500 BC but
as they had looked and only as they had
looked around the year 10
450 BC
I had come to Egypt to go over the Giza
site with Robert baval and to question
him about his star correlation theory in
addition I wanted to Canvas his views on
what sort of human society if any could
have had the technological know-how such
a very long while ago to measure
accurately the altitudes of the stars
and to devise a plan as mathematical and
ambitious as that of the Giza necropolis
I had also come to meet another
researcher who had challenged the
Orthodox chronology of ancient Egypt
with a well-founded claim to have found
hard evidence of a high civilization in
the Nile Valley in 10 000 BC or earlier
like boval's astronomical data the
evidence had always been available but
had failed to attract the attention of
established egyptologists the man
responsible for bringing it before the
public now was The American Scholar John
Anthony West who argued that the
Specialists had missed it not because
they had failed to find it but because
they had found it and failed to
interpret it properly
West's evidence focused on certain key
structures notably the Great Sphinx and
the Bali Temple at Giza and much farther
south the mysterious osarion at abidos
he argued that these desert monuments
showed many scientifically unmistakable
signs of having been weathered by water
an erosive agent they could only have
been exposed to insufficient quantities
during The Damp pluvial period that
accompanied the end of the last ice age
around the 11th millennium BC the
implication of this peculiar and
extremely distinctive pattern of
precipitation-induced weathering was
that the osirion the Sphinx and other
Associated structures were built before
10000 BC a British investigative
journalist summed up the effect West is
really an academic's worst nightmare
because Here Comes somebody way out of
left field with a thoroughly well
thought out well presented coherently
described Theory full of data they can't
refute and it pulls the rug out from
beneath their feet so how do they deal
with it they ignore it they hope it'll
go away and it won't go away
the reason the new Theory would not
under any circumstances go away despite
its rejection by droves of competent
egyptologists was that it had one
widespread support from another
scientific branch of scholarship geology
Dr Robert shock a professor of geology
at Boston University had played a
prominent role in validating West's
estimates concerning the true age of the
Sphinx and his views had been endorsed
by almost 300 of his peers at the 1992
annual Convention of the Geological
Society of America
since then most often out of the public
eye an acrimonious dispute had begun to
smolder between the geologists and the
egyptologists and though very few people
other than John West were prepared to
say as much what was at stake in this
dispute was a complete upheaval in
accepted views about the evolution of
human civilization
according to West we are told that the
evolution of human civilization is a
linear process that it goes from stupid
cavemen to Smart old us with our
hydrogen bombs and striped toothpaste
but the proof that the Sphinx is many
many thousands of years older than the
archaeologists think it is that it
preceded by many thousands of years even
dynastic Egypt means that there must
have been at some distant point in
history a high and sophisticated
civilization just as all the Legends
affirm
my own travels and research during the
preceding four years had opened my eyes
to the electrifying possibility that
those Legends could be true and this was
why I had come back to Egypt to meet
Western bhava I was struck by the way in
which there are hitherto disparate lines
of inquiry had converged so convincingly
on what appeared to be the astronomical
and geological Fingerprints of A Lost
Civilization one that might or might not
have originated in the Nile Valley but
that seemed to have had a presence here
as far back as the 11th millennium BC
the way of the jackal
Anubis guardian of the secrets god of
the funerary chamber jackal-headed
opener of the ways of the Dead guide and
companion to Osiris
it was around five o'clock in the
afternoon closing time at the Cairo
Museum when Santa pronounced herself
satisfied with her photographs of the
Sinister black effigy
down below us guards were whistling and
clapping their hands as they sought to
herd the last few sightseers out of the
halls but up on the second floor of the
hundred-year-old building where ancient
Anubis crouched in his Millennial
watchfulness all was quiet all was still
we left the somber Museum and walked
down into the sunlight still bathing
cairo's bustling Terrier Square
Anubis are reflected had shared his
duties as spirit guide and guardian of
the secret writings with another God
whose type and symbol had also been the
Jackal and whose name
literally meant opener of the whales
both these canine deities had been
linked since time immemorial with the
ancient town of abidos in Upper Egypt
the original God of which kentia meant
you the strangely named foremost of the
westerners had also been represented as
a member of the dog family usually lying
recumbent on a black standard
was there any significance in the
repeated recurrence at abidos of all
this mythical and symbolic doggishness
with its promise of high Secrets waiting
to unfold it seemed worthwhile trying to
find out since the extensive ruins there
included the structure known as the
osirion which West's geological research
had indicated might be far older than
the archaeologists thought besides I had
already arranged to meet West in a few
days in the upper Egyptian town of Luxor
less than 200 kilometers south of abdos
rather than flying directly to Luxor
from Cairo as I had originally planned I
now realized that it would be perfectly
feasible to go by Road and to visit
abidos and a number of other sites along
the way
our driver Muhammad waleli was waiting
for us in an underground car park just
off Terrier Square
a large genial elderly man he owned a
battered white Peugeot taxi normally to
be found standing in the rank outside
the Mina House hotel at Giza
over the last few years on our frequent
research trips to Cairo we had struck up
a friendship with them and he now worked
with us whenever we were in Egypt we
haggled for some time about the
appropriate daily rate for the long
return journey to abidos and Luxor many
matters had to be taken into account
including the fact that some of the
areas we would be passing through had
recently been targets of terrorist
attacks by Islamic militants eventually
we agreed on the price and arranged to
set off early the following morning
chapter 41
city of the Sun
chamber of the jackal
Muhammad picked us up at our hotel in
heliopolis at 6am when it was still half
dark
we drank small cups of thick black
coffee at a roadside stall and then
drove West along Dusty streets still
almost deserted towards the River Nile
I had asked Muhammad to take us through
maidan al-masala Square which was
dominated by one of the world's oldest
intact Egyptian obelisks
weighing an estimated 350 tons this was
a pink Granite monolith 170 feet high
erected by Pharos and user at the first
1971 to
1928 BC it had originally been one of a
pair at the Gateway of the Great
heliopolitan temple of the Sun in the
four thousand years since then the
temple itself had entirely vanished as
had the second Obelisk indeed almost all
of ancient heliopolis had now been
obliterated cannibalized for its
handsome dressed stones and ready-made
building materials by countless
generations of the citizens of Cairo
heliopolis city of the sun was referred
to in the Bible as on but was originally
known in the Egyptian language as Inu or
inuhret meaning the pillar or the
northern pillar it was a district of
immense sanctity associated with a
strange group of nine solar and Stellar
deities and was old Beyond Reckoning
when sanusore chose it as the sight for
his Obelisk indeed together with Giza
and the distant southern city of abidos
Inu heliopolis was believed to have been
part of the first land that emerged from
the Primeval Waters at the moment of
Creation The Land of the first time
where the gods had commenced their rule
on Earth
heliopolitan theology rested on a
creation myth distinguished by a number
of unique and curious features it taught
that in the beginning the universe had
been filled with a dark and watery
nothingness called the noon
out of this inert Cosmic ocean described
as shapeless black with the Blackness of
the Blackest Night Rose a mound of dry
land on which ra the sun god
materialized in his self-created form as
atum sometimes depicted as an old
bearded man leaning on a star
the sky had not been created the Earth
had not been created the children of the
earth and the reptiles had not been
fashioned in that place I a tomb was one
by myself there existed no other who
worked with me
conscious of being alone this blessed
and Immortal being contrived to create
two Divine Offspring shoe god of the air
and dryness and tefnut the goddess of
moisture I thrust my phallus into my
closed hand
I made my seed to enter my hand I poured
it into my own mouth I evacuated under
the form of shoe I passed water under
the form of tefnut
despite such apparently inauspicious
Beginnings Shu and tefnut who were
always described as Twins and frequently
depicted as lions grew to maturity
copulated and produced offspring of
their own Geb the god of the earth and
Newt the goddess of the sky these two
also mated creating Osiris and Isis set
and neptus and so completed the any AD
the full company of the nine gods of
heliopolis of the nine ra Shu gab and
Osiris were said to have ruled in Egypt
as kings followed by Horus and lastly
for
3226 years by the ibis-headed wisdom God
Thoth
who were these people or creatures or
beings or gods were they figments of the
Priestly imagination or symbols or
ciphers where the stories told about
them Vivid myth memories of real events
which had taken place thousands of years
previously or were they perhaps part of
a coded message from the Ancients that
had been transmitting itself over and
over again down the epochs a message
only now beginning to be unraveled and
understood
such Notions seemed fanciful
nevertheless I could hardly forget that
out of this very same heliopolitan
tradition the great myth of Isis and
Osiris had flowed covertly transmitting
an accurate calculus for the rate of
precessional motion moreover the priests
of Inu whose responsibility it had been
to guard and nurture such Traditions had
been renowned throughout Egypt for their
High wisdom and their Proficiency in
Prophecy astronomy mathematics
architecture and the magic Arts they
were also famous for their possession of
a powerful and sacred object known as
the Ben Ben
the Egyptians called heliopolis Inu the
pillar because tradition had it that the
Ben Ben had been kept here in remote
pre-dynastic times when it had balanced
on top of a pillar of rough hewn Stone
the Benben was believed to have fallen
from the skies
unfortunately it had been lost so long
before that its appearance was no longer
remembered by the time sunusuret took
the throne in
1971 BC
in that period the 12th Dynasty all that
was clearly recalled was that the Ben
Ben had been pyramidal in form thus
providing together with the pillar on
which it stood a prototype for the shape
of all future obelisks the name Ben Ben
was likewise applied to the pyrimidion
or Apex Stone usually placed on top of
pyramids in a symbolic sense it was also
Associated closely and directly with ra
atum of whom the ancient texts said you
became high on the height you Rose up as
the Ben Ben star in the Mansion of the
Phoenix
Mansion of the Phoenix described the
original Temple at teleopolis where the
Ben Ben had been housed it reflected the
fact that the mysterious object had also
served as an enduring symbol for the
mythical Phoenix the Divine bennu bird
whose appearances and disappearances
were believed to be linked to Violent
Cosmic cycles and to the destruction and
Rebirth of world ages
connections and similarities
driving through the suburbs of
heliopolis at around 6 30 in the morning
I closed my eyes and tried to summon up
a picture of the landscape as it might
have looked in the mythical first time
after the island of creation the
primordial mound of raatum had risen out
of the flood waters of the nun
it was tempting to see a connection
between this imagery and the Andean
Traditions that spoke of the emergence
of the civilizer god Vera kocha from the
Waters of Lake Titicaca after an earth
destroying flood
moreover there was the figure of Osiris
to consider a conspicuously bearded
figure like viracocha and like
Quetzalcoatl as well remembered for
having abolished cannibalism among the
Egyptians for having taught them
Agriculture and animal husbandry for
introducing them to such Arts as writing
architecture and music
the similarities between the Old and New
World Traditions were hard to miss but
even harder to interpret it was possible
they were just a series of beguiling
coincidences
on the other hand it was possible that
they might reveal the Fingerprints of an
ancient and unidentified Global
civilization fingerprints that were
essentially the same whether they
appeared in the myths of Central America
or of the high Andes or of Egypt
the priests of heliopolis after all had
taught of the creation but who had
taught them had they sprung out of
nowhere or was it more likely that their
Doctrine with all its complex symbolism
was the product of a long refinement of
religious ideas
if so when and where have these ideas
developed
I looked up to discover that we had left
heliopolis behind and were winding our
way through the noisy and crowded
streets of downtown Cairo we crossed
over to the West Bank of the Nile by way
of the 6th of October bridge and soon
afterwards entered Giza 15 minutes later
passing the massive bulk of the Great
Pyramid on our right we turned south on
the road to Upper Egypt a road which
followed the Meridian course of the
world's longest river through a
landscape of palms and green fields
fringed by the encroaching red wastes of
pitiless deserts
the ideas of the heliopolitan priesthood
had influenced every aspect of secular
and religious life in ancient Egypt but
had those ideas developed locally or had
they been introduced to the Nile Valley
from elsewhere
the traditions of the Egyptians provided
an unambiguous answer to questions such
as these all the wisdom of heliopolis
was a legacy they said and this Legacy
had been passed to humankind by the Gods
gift of the Gods
about 10 miles south of the Great
Pyramid we pulled off the main road to
visit the necropolis of Sakara rearing
up on the desert's Edge the site was
dominated by a six-tier ziggurat the
step pyramid of the third Dynasty
Pharaoh Zoser
this imposing Monument almost 200 feet
tall was dated to approximately
2650 BC it stood within its own compound
surrounded by an elegant enclosure war
and was reckoned by archaeologists to be
the earliest massive construction of
stone ever attempted by Humanity
tradition had it that its architect was
the legendary Imhotep great of magic a
high priest of heliopolis whose other
titles were Sage sorcerer astronomer and
doctor
we shall have more to say about the step
pyramid and its builder in a later
chapter but on this occasion that I had
not come to Sakara to see it my sole
objective was to spend a few moments in
the burial chamber of the nearby pyramid
of unas a fifth Dynasty pharaoh who had
reigned from
2356 to
2323 BC
the walls of this chamber which I had
visited several times before were
inscribed from floor to ceiling with the
most ancient of the pyramid texts an
extravaganza of hieroglyphic
inscriptions giving voice to a range of
remarkable ideas in acute contrast to
the mute and unadorned Interiors of the
fourth Dynasty pyramids at Giza
a phenomenon exclusively of the fifth
and sixth dynasties
2465 to
2152 BC the pyramid texts were sacred
writings parts of which were thought to
have been composed by the heliopolitan
priesthood in the late 3rd millennium BC
and parts of which had been received and
handed down by them from pre-dynastic
times
it was the latter part of these texts
dating to a remote and impenetrable
Antiquity which had particularly aroused
my curiosity when I'd began to research
them a few months previously I had also
been amused and a little intrigued by
the strange way that 19th century French
archaeologists appeared almost to have
been directed to the hidden chamber of
the pyramid texts by a mythological
opener of the ways
according to reasonably well documented
reports an Egyptian Foreman of the
excavations at Sakara had been up and
about at dawn one morning and had found
himself by the side of a ruined pyramid
looking into the bright Amber eyes of a
lone desert jackal
it was as if the animal were taunting
his human Observer and inviting the
puzzled man to chase him
slowly The Jackal sauntered towards the
North Face of the pyramid stopping for a
loan before disappearing into a hole the
bemused Arab decided to follow his lead
after slipping through the narrow hole
he found himself crawling into the dark
bowels of the pyramid soon he emerged
into a chamber and lifting his light saw
that the walls were covered from top to
bottom with hieroglyphic inscriptions
these were carved with exquisite
craftsmanship into the solid Limestone
and painted over with turquoise and gold
today the hieroglyph line chamber
beneath the ruined pyramid of unas is
still reached through the North Face by
The Long descending passage the French
archaeological team excavated soon after
the Foreman's astonishing discovery
the chamber consists of two rectangular
rooms separated by a partition wall into
which is set a low doorway both rooms
are covered by a gabled ceiling painted
with myriads of stars
emerging stooped from the cramped
passage Santa and I entered the first of
the two rooms and passed through the
connecting doorway into the second
this was the tomb chamber proper with
the massive black granite sarcophagus of
unas at its Western end and the strange
utterances of the pyramid texts
proclaiming themselves from every wall
speaking to us directly rather than
through riddles and mathematical Ledger
domain like the unadorned walls of the
Great Pyramid what were the hieroglyphs
saying I knew that the answer depended
to some extent on which translation you
were using largely because the language
of the pyramid texts contained so many
archaic forms and so many unfamiliar
mythological illusions that Scholars
were obliged to fill in the gaps in
their knowledge with guesswork
nevertheless it was generally agreed
that the late Ro Faulkner a professor of
the ancient Egyptian language at
University College London had produced
the most authoritative version
Faulkner whose translation I had studied
line by line described the texts as
constituting the oldest Corpus of
Egyptian funerary literature now extant
and added they are the least corrupt of
all such Collections and are of
fundamental importance to the student of
Egyptian religion
the reason why the texts were so
important as many scholars agreed was
that they were the last completely open
Channel connecting the relatively short
period of the past that Humanity
remembers to the far longer period that
has been forgotten they vaguely
disclosed to us a vanished world of
thought and speech the last of the
unnumbered ales through which
prehistoric man has passed till finally
he enters the historic age
it was hard to disagree with sentiments
like these the texts did disclose a
banished world but what intrigued me
most about this world was the
possibility that it might have been
inhabited not only by primitive Savages
as one would have expected in remote
prehistory but paradoxically by men and
women whose Minds had been enlightened
by a scientific understanding of the
cosmos
the overall picture was equivocal there
were genuinely primitive elements locked
into the pyramid texts alongside the
loftier sequences of ideas nevertheless
every time I immersed myself in what
egyptologists call these ancient spells
I was impressed by the strange glimpses
they seemed to afford of a high
intelligence at work darting from behind
layers of incomprehension reporting on
experiences that prehistoric man should
never have had and expressing Notions he
should never have been able to formulate
in short the effect of the texts
achieved through the medium of
hieroglyphs was akin to the effect of
the Great Pyramid achieved through the
medium of architecture in both cases the
dominant impression was of anachronism
of advanced technological processes used
or described at a period in human
history when there was supposed to have
been no technology at all
chapter 42
anachronisms and enigmas
I looked around the gray wall chamber of
unas up and down the long registers of
hieroglyphs in which the pyramid texts
were inscribed
they were written in a dead language
nevertheless the constant affirmation
repeated over and over again in these
ancient compositions was that of life
eternal life which was to be achieved
through the pharaoh's rebirth as a star
in the constellation of Orion
as The Listener will recall from chapter
19 where we compared Egyptian beliefs
with those of ancient Mexico there were
several utterances which voiced this
aspiration explicitly
O King you are this great star the
companion of Orion who traverses the sky
with Orion you ascend from the east of
the sky being renewed in your due season
and rejuvenated in your due time
though undeniably beautiful there was
nothing inherently extraordinary about
these sentiments and it was by no means
impossible to attribute them to a people
assessed by the French archaeologist
Gaston maspero as having always remained
half Savage
furthermore since baspero had been the
first egyptologist to enter the Pyramid
of unas and was considered a great
Authority on the texts it was hardly
surprising that his opinions should have
shaped all academic responses to this
literature since he'd begun to publish
translations from it in the 1880s
maspero With a Little Help From a jackal
had brought the pyramid texts to the
world thereafter the dominance of his
particular prejudices about the past had
functioned as a filter on knowledge
inhibiting variant interpretations of
the more opaque or puzzling utterances
this seemed to me to be unfortunate to
say the least what it meant was that
despite the technical and scientific
puzzles raised by monuments like the
great pyramid at Giza Scholars had
ignored the implications of some
striking passages in the tests
these passages sounded suspiciously like
attempts to express complex Technical
and scientific imagery in an entirely
inappropriate idiom
maybe it was a coincidence but the
result resembled the outcome that we
might expect today if we were to try to
translate Einstein's theory of
relativity into choserian English or to
describe a supersonic aircraft in
vocabulary derived from Middle High
German
broken images of a lost technology
take for example some of the peculiar
equipment and accessories designated for
the pharaoh's use as he journeyed to his
eternal resting place Among the Stars
the gods who are in the sky are brought
to you the gods who are on earth
assemble for you they Place their hands
under you they make a ladder for you
that you may Ascend on it into the sky
the doors of the sky are thrown open to
you the doors of the starry firmament
are thrown open for you
the ascending Pharaoh was identified
with and frequently referred to as an
Osiris
Osiris himself as we've seen was
frequently linked to and associated with
the constellation of Orion
Cyrus Orion was said to have been the
first to have climbed the great ladder
the gods had made and several utterances
left no doubt that this ladder had not
extended upwards from Earth to heaven
but downwards from Heaven to Earth
it was described as a rope ladder and
the belief was that it had hung from an
iron plate suspended in the sky
were we dealing here I wondered simply
with the bizarre imaginings of
half-savage priests or might there be
some other explanation for illusions
such as these
in utterance 261 the king is a flame
moving before the wind to the end of the
sky and to the end of the Earth the king
travels the air and traverses the Earth
there is brought to him a way of ascent
to the sky
switching to dialogue utterance 310
proclaimed oh you whose vision is in his
face and whose vision is in the back of
his head bring this to me
what ferry boat shall be brought to you
bring me it flies and the lights
utterance 332 supposedly spoken by the
king himself confided I am this one who
has escaped from the coiled serpent I
have ascended in a blast of fire having
turned myself about the two Skies go to
me
and in utterance
669 it was asked wherewith can the king
be made to fly up
the reply was given there shall be
brought to you the hunua bark
and the a little text is missing here of
the hunbo
you shall fly up there with you shall
fly up and a light
other passages also seem to me worthy of
more thorough investigation than they
have received from Scholars here are a
few examples o my father great king the
aperture of the sky window is opened for
you
the door of the sky at the Horizon opens
to you the gods are glad at meeting you
may you sit on this Iron Throne of yours
as the great one who is in heliopolis
O King may you ascend the sky reels at
you the earth quakes at you the
imperishable stars are afraid of you I
have come to you o you whose seats are
hidden that I may embrace you in the sky
the Earth speaks the Gate of the earth
God is open the doors of Gab are opened
for you may you remove yourself to the
sky upon your iron throne
oh my father the king such is your going
when you have gone as a God you are
traveling as a Celestial being you stand
in the conclaves of the Horizon and sit
on this Throne of iron at which the gods
Marvel
the constant references to iron though
easy to overlook were puzzling I and I
knew had been a rare metal in ancient
Egypt particularly in the pyramid age
when it had supposedly only been
available in meteoritic form
yet here in the pyramid texts there
seemed to be an embarrassment of iron
riches iron plates in the sky iron
Thrones and elsewhere and iron scepter
and even Iron Bones for the king
in the ancient Egyptian language the
name for iron had been bajar a word that
literally meant metal of heaven or
divine metal the knowledge of iron was
thus regarded as yet another gift from
the gods
repositories of a lost science
what other fingerprints might these gods
have left behind in the pyramid texts
in my readings here and there amongst
the most archaic of the utterances I had
come across several metaphors that
seemed to refer to the passage of epochs
of processional time these metaphors
stood out from the surrounding material
because they were expressed in what had
become a clear and familiar terminology
to me that of the archaic scientific
language identified by santileana and
vondesh and in Hamlet's Mill
The Listener may recall that a cosmic
diagram of the four props of the sky was
one of the standard thought tools
employed in that ancient language its
purpose was to assist visualization of
the four imaginary bands conceived as
framing supporting and defining a
processional World age these were what
astronomers call the equinoxual and
solsticial colluras and were seen as
hooping down from the celestial North
Pole and marking the four constellations
against the background of which for
periods of
2160 years at a time the sun would
consistently rise on the spring and
Autumn equinoxes and on the winter and
summer solstices
the pyramid texts appear to contain
several versions of this diagram
moreover as is so often the case with
Prehistoric myths which transmit hard
astronomical data the precessional
symbolism is interwoven tightly with
violent images of terrestrial
destruction as though to suggest that
the breaking of the mill of Heaven that
is the transition every
2160 years from one zodiacal age to
another could under ill Omen
circumstances bring catastrophic
influences to bear on terrestrial events
thus it was said that ra ATU The God Who
created himself was originally King over
Gods and Men together but mankind
schemed against his sovereignty for he
began to grow old
his bones became silver his flesh gold
and his hair as lapis lazuli
when he realized what was happening the
Aged Sun God so reminiscent of tanatyu
the bloodthirsty fifth son of the Aztecs
determined that he would punish this
Insurrection by killing off most of the
human race the instrument of the Havoc
he Unleashed was symbolized at times as
a raging lioness wading in Blood and at
times as the Fearsome lion-headed
goddess sakumet who poured fire out of
herself and Savaged Mankind in an
ecstasy of Slaughter
the terrible destruction continued
unabated for a long period Then at last
raw intervened to save the lives of a
Remnant the ancestors of present
Humanity this intervention took the form
of a flood which the Lioness thirstily
lapped up and then fell asleep when she
awoke she was no longer interested in
pursuing the destruction and peace
descended upon the devastated world
meanwhile raw had resolved to draw away
from what was left of his creation as I
live my heart is weary of staying with
mankind I have gone on killing them
almost to the very last one
so the insignificant Remnant is not my
affair the Sun God then Rose into the
sky on the back of the sky goddess nut
who for the purposes of the precessional
metaphor about to be delivered had
transformed herself into a cow
before very long in a close analogy to
the shaft tree that shivered on amlodi's
wildly gyrating Mill the cow grew dizzy
and began to shake and to tremble
because she was so high above the Earth
when she complained to Raw about this
precarious State of Affairs he commanded
let my son Shu be put beneath mute to
keep God for me over the Heavenly
supports which exist in the Twilight put
her above your head and keep her there
as soon as Shu had taken his place
beneath the cow and had stabilized her
body the heavens above and the Earth
beneath came into being at the same
moment the four legs of the cow as
egyptologist Wallace budge commented in
his classic study the gods of the
Egyptians became the four props of
Heaven at the four cardinal points
like most Scholars but you
understandably assumed that the cardinal
points referred to in this ancient
Egyptian tradition had strictly
terrestrial connotations and that heaven
represented nothing more than the sky
above our heads he took it for granted
that the point of the metaphor was for
us to envisage the cow's four legs as
positioned at the Four Points of the
compass north south east and west he
also thought and even today few
egyptologists would disagree with him
that the simple-minded priests of
heliopolis had actually believed that
the sky had four corners which were
supported on four legs and that shoe the
sky Bearer par Excellence had stood
immobile like a pillar at the center of
the whole edifice
reinterpreted in the light of Santa Yana
and Von deschen's findings however Shu
and the four legs of the celestial cow
looked much more like the components of
an archaic scientific symbol depicting
the frame of a precessional world Age
The Polar axis Shu and the Colliers the
four legs or props marking the
equinoxual and solsticial cardinal
points in the annual round of the Sun
moreover it is tempting to speculate
which World age was being signaled here
with a cow involved it could have been
the age of Taurus although the Egyptians
knew the difference between bulls and
cows as well as anyone but a much more
likely Contender at any rate on Purely
symbolic Grounds was the age of Leo from
approximately 10
970 to
8810 BC the reason is that sekhmet the
agent of the destruction of mankind
referred to in the myth was leonine in
form what better way to symbolize the
troubled birth of the new world age of
Leo than to depict its Harbinger as a
rampaging lion particularly since the
age of Leo coincided with the final
ferocious meltdown of the last ice age
during which huge numbers of animal
species all over the Earth were suddenly
and violently rendered extinct mankind
survived the immense floods and
earthquakes and rapid changes of climate
that took place but very probably in
much reduced no
and much reduced circumstances
the train of the sun and the dweller in
Sirius
of course the ability to recognize and
Define precessional World ages in myth
implies that the ancient Egyptians
possessed better observational astronomy
and a more sophisticated understanding
of the mechanics of the solar system
than any ancient people have hitherto
been credited with
there is no doubt that knowledge of this
caliber if it existed at all would have
been highly regarded by the ancient
Egyptians who would have transmitted it
from generation to generation in a
secretive manner indeed it would have
ranked among the highest Arcana
entrusted to the keeping of the Priestly
Elite at heliopolis and would have been
passed on in the main through an oral
and initiatory tradition if by chance it
had found its way into the pyramid texts
is it not likely that its form would
have been veiled by metaphors and
allegories I walked slowly across the
dusty floor of the Tomb chamber of unas
noting the heavy Stillness in the air
casting my eyes over the faded blue and
gold inscriptions
expressed in coded language several
Millennia before Copernicus and Galileo
some of the passages inscribed on these
walls seemed to offer Clues to the true
heliocentric nature of the solar system
in one for example ra the Sun God was
depicted as seated upon an iron throne
encircled by lesser Gods who moved
around him constantly and who were said
to be in his train likewise in another
passage the deceased Pharaoh was urged
to stand at the head of the two halves
of the sky and weigh the words of the
Gods the Aged ones who revolve around ra
if the Aged ones and the encircling Gods
revolving around ra should prove to be
parts of a terminology referring to the
planets of our solar system the original
authors of the pyramid texts must have
enjoyed access to some remarkably
Advanced astronomical data
they must have known that the earth and
the planets revolved around the Sun
rather than vice versa the problem this
raises is that neither the ancient
Egyptians at any stage in their history
nor even their successes the Greeks or
for that matter the Europeans until the
Renaissance are supposed to have
possessed cosmological data of anything
approaching this quality how therefore
can its presence be explained in
compositions which date back to the dawn
of Egyptian civilization
another and perhaps related mystery
concerns the star Sirius which the
Egyptians identified with Isis the
sister and consort of Osiris and the
mother of Horus in a passage addressed
to Osiris himself the pyramid texts
State thy sister Isis cometh unto thee
rejoicing in her love for thee thou
satist her upon thee thy issue entereth
into her and she becometh great with
child like the star sept Sirius the dog
star
Horus sept cometh forth from thee in the
form of Horus dweller incept
many interpretations of this passage are
of course possible what intrigued me
however was the clear implication that
Sirius was to be regarded as a dual
entity in some way comparable to a woman
great with child moreover after the
birth or coming forth at that child the
text makes a special point of reminding
us that Horus remained a dweller incept
presumably suggesting that he stayed
close to his mother
Sirius is an unusual star
sparkling point of light particularly
prominent in the winter months in the
night skies of the northern hemisphere
it consists of a binary star system in
other words it is in fact as the pyramid
texts suggest a dual entity
the major component serious a is what we
see
serious B on the other hand the dwarf
star which revolves around Sirius a is
absolutely invisible to the naked eye
its existence did not become known to
Western science until 1862 when U.S
astronomer Arvin Clark spotted it
through one of the largest and most
advanced telescopes of the day how could
the scribes who wrote The Pyramid texts
possibly have obtained the information
that Sirius was two stars in one
in the serious mystery an important book
published in 1976 I knew that the
American author Robert Temple had
offered some extraordinary answers to
this question his study focused on the
traditional beliefs of the dogon tribe
of West Africa the Leafs in which the
binary character of Sirius was
explicitly described and in which the
correct figure of 50 years was given for
the period of the orbit of Sirius B
around Sirius a
Temple argued cogently that this high
quality technical information had been
passed down to the dogon from the
ancient Egyptians through a process of
cultural diffusion and that it was to
the ancient Egyptians that we should
look for an answer to the serious
mystery he also concluded that the
ancient Egyptians must have received the
information from intelligent beings from
the region of Sirius
like Temple I had begun to suspect that
the more advanced and sophisticated
elements of Egyptian science made sense
only if they were understood as part of
an inheritance
unlike Temple I saw no urgent reason to
attribute that inheritance to
extraterrestrials
to my mind the anomalous star knowledge
the heliopolitan priests had apparently
possessed was more plausibly explained
as the legacy of a lost human
civilization which against the current
of History had achieved a high level of
technological advancement in remote
antiquity
it seemed to me that the building of an
instrument capable of detecting Sirius B
might not have been beyond the Ingenuity
of the unknown explorers and scientists
who originated the remarkable maps of
the prehistoric World discussed in part
one
nor would it have daunted the unknown
astronomers and measurers of time could
bequeathed to the ancient Maya a
calendar of amazing complexity a
database about the movements of the
heavenly bodies which could only have
been the product of thousands of years
of accurately recorded observations and
a facility with very large numbers that
seemed more appropriate to the needs of
a complex technological Society than to
those of a primitive Central American
Kingdom
millions of years and the movements of
the Stars
very large numbers also appeared in the
pyramid texts in the symbolic vote of
millions of years for example in which
the Sun God was said to navigate the
dark and airless wastes of interstellar
space
the god of wisdom he who reckons in
heaven the counter of the Stars the
measurer of the Earth was specifically
empowered to Grant a life of millions of
years to the deceased Pharaoh Osiris
king of Eternity Lord of everlasting was
described as traversing millions of
years in his life
and figures like tens of millions of
years as well as the more mind-boggling
one million of millions of years
occurred often enough to suggest that
some elements at least of ancient
Egyptian culture must have evolved for
the convenience of scientifically minded
people with more than passing insights
into the immensity of time
such a people would of course have
required an excellent calendar one that
would have facilitated complex and
accurate calculations it was therefore
not surprising to learn that the ancient
Egyptians like the Maya had possessed
such a calendar and that their
understanding of its workings seems to
have declined rather than improved as
the ages went by it was tempting to see
this as the gradual erosion of a corpus
of knowledge inherited an extremely long
time ago an impression supported by the
ancient Egyptians themselves who made no
secret of their belief that their
calendar was a legacy which they had
received from the gods we consider the
possible identity of these gods in more
detail in the following chapters whoever
they were they must have spent a great
deal of their time observing the stars
and they had accumulated a fund of
advanced and specialized knowledge
concerning the star Sirius in particular
further evidence for this came in the
form of the most useful calendrical gift
which the gods supposedly gave to the
Egyptians the sothic or Syrian cycle
the suffix cycle was based on what is
referred to in technical jargon as the
periodic Return of the helical rising of
Sirius which is the first appearance of
this star after a seasonal absence
rising at dawn just ahead of the Sun in
the Eastern portion of the sky in the
case of Sirius the interval between one
such rising and the next amounts to
exactly
365.25 days a mathematically harmonious
figure uncomplicated by further decimal
points which is just 12 minutes longer
than the duration of the solar year
curious thing about Sirius is that out
of an estimated 2 000 stars in the
heavens visible to the naked eye it is
the only one to rise her likely at this
precise and nicely rounded interval of
365 and a quarter days a unique product
of its proper motion the speed of its
own movement through space combined with
the effects of the precession of the
equinoxes
moreover it is known that the day of the
helical rising of Sirius New Year's Day
in the ancient Egyptian calendar was
traditionally calculated at heliopolis
where the pyramid texts were compiled
and announced ahead of time to all the
other major temples up and down the Nile
I remember that Sirius was referred to
directly in the pyramid texts by her
name of the new year
together with other relevant utterances
this confirmed that the sothic calendar
was at least as old as the text
themselves and their Origins stretched
back into the Mists of distant Antiquity
the great Enigma therefore is this in
such an early period who could have
possessed the necessary know-how to
observe and take note of The Coincidence
of the period of
365.25 days with the helical rising of
Sirius a coincidence described by the
French mathematician R A schwala de
lubix as an entirely exceptional
Celestial phenomenon
we cannot but admire the lubric's
comments the greatness of a science
capable of discovering such a
coincidence
the double star of Sirius was chosen
because it was the only star that moves
the needed distance and in the right
direction against the background of the
other stars this fact known 4 000 years
before our time and forgotten until our
day obviously demands an extraordinary
and prolonged observation of the sky
it was such a legacy built out of long
centuries of precise observational
astronomy and scientific record keeping
that Egypt seems to have benefited from
at the beginning of the historical
period and that was expressed in the
pyramid texts in this too there lies a
mystery
copies
or translations
writing in 1934 the year of his death
Wallace budge former keeper of Egyptian
Antiquities at the British Museum and
the author of an authoritative
hieroglyphic dictionary made this Frank
admission
the pyramid texts are full of
difficulties of every kind the exact
meanings of a large number of words
found in them are unknown the
construction of the sentence often
baffles all attempts to translate it and
when it contains wholly unknown words it
becomes an unsolved riddle it is only
reasonable to suppose that these texts
were often used for funerary purposes
but it is quite clear that their period
of use in Egypt was little more than 100
years
why they were suddenly brought into use
at the end of the fifth Dynasty and
ceased to be used at the end of the
sixth Dynasty is inexplicable
could the answer be that they were
copies of an earlier literature which
unas the last Pharaoh of the fifth
Dynasty together with several of his
successes in the sixth Dynasty had
attempted to fix forever in stone in the
Tomb chambers of their own pyramids
Butch thought so and felt the evidence
suggested that some at least of the
source documents must have been
exceedingly old
several passages bear evidence that the
scribes who drafted the copies from
which the Cutters of the inscriptions
worked did not understand what they were
writing the general impression is that
the priests who drafted the copies made
extracts from several compositions of
different ages and having different
contents
all this assumed that the source
documents whatever they were must have
been written in an archaic form of the
ancient Egyptian language there was
however an alternative possibility which
budge failed to consider
suppose that the tasks of the priests
had been not only to copy material but
to translate into hieroglyph's texts
originally composed in another language
altogether
if that language had included a
technical terminology and references to
artifacts and ideas for which no
equivalent terms existed in ancient
Egyptian this would provide an
explanation for the strange impression
given by certain of the utterances
moreover if the copying and translating
of the original Source documents had
been completed by the end of the sixth
Dynasty it was easy to understand why no
more pyramid texts had ever been carved
the project would have come to a halt
when it had fulfilled its objective
which would have been to create a
permanent hieroglyphic record of a
sacred literature that had already been
tottering with age when unas had taken
the Throne of Egypt in
2356 BC
last records of the first time
because we wanted to cover as much of
the distance to abidos as was possible
before nightfall Santa and I reluctantly
decided that it was time to get back on
the road
although we had originally intended to
spend only a few minutes the somber
Gloom and ancient voices of the unas
Tomb chamber had lulled our senses in
almost two hours had passed since our
arrival
stooping we left the tomb and climbed
the steeply angled passageway to the
exit where we paused to allow our eyes
to adjust to the harsh mid-morning
sunlight as we did so I took the
opportunity to look over the pyramid
itself which had fallen into such a
crumbling and thoroughly dilapidated
state that its original form was barely
recognizable the core masonry reduced to
little more than a non-descript heap of
rubble was evidently of poor quality and
even the facing blocks some of which
were still intact lacked the Finesse and
careful workmanship demonstrated by the
older pyramids at Giza
this was hard to explain in conventional
historical terms if the normal
evolutionary processes that govern the
development of architectural skills and
ideas had been at work in Egypt one
would have expected to find the opposite
to be true the design engineering and
masonry of the unas pyramid should have
been Superior to those of the Giza Group
which according to Orthodox chronology
had been built about two centuries
previously the uncomfortable fact that
this was not the case
in other words Giza was better than unas
and not vice versa created naughty
challenges for egyptologists and raised
questions to which no satisfactory
answers had been supplied
to reiterate the central problem
everything about the three stunning and
superb pyramids of Khufu cafrei and
menka Ray proclaimed that they were the
end products of hundreds perhaps even
thousands of years of accumulated
architectural and Engineering experience
this was not supported by the
archaeological evidence which left no
doubt that they were among the earliest
pyramids ever built in Egypt in other
words they were not the products of the
mature phase of that country's pyramid
building experiment but anomalously
where the creations of its infancy
a further mystery also cried out for
solution in the three Great Pyramids at
Giza Egypt's fourth Dynasty had reared
up Mansions of Eternity unprecedented
and unsurpassed masterpieces of stone
hundreds of feet high weighing millions
of tons apiece which Incorporated many
extremely Advanced features
no pyramids of comparable quality were
ever built again but only a little later
beneath the smaller shabbier
superstructures of the fifth and sixth
Dynasty pyramids are sort of Hall of
Records seem to have been deliberately
created a permanent exhibition of copies
or translations of archaic documents
which was at the same time an
unprecedented and unsurpassed
Masterpiece of scribal and hieroglyphic
art
in short like the pyramids at Giza it
seemed that the pyramid texts had burst
upon the scene with no apparent
antecedents and had occupied Center
Stage for approximately a hundred years
before ceasing operations never to be
better
presumably the ancient Kings and sages
who had arranged these things had known
what they were doing if so their minds
must have contained a plan and they must
have intended a strong connection to be
seen between the completely uninscribed
but technically brilliant pyramids at
Giza and the brilliantly inscribed but
tactically slip-shot pyramids of the 5th
and 6th dynasties
I suspected too that at least part of
the answer to the problem might lie in
the pyramid field of darshore which we
passed 15 minutes after leaving Sakara
it was here that the so-called bent and
red pyramids were located attributed to
snefaru khufu's Father these two
monuments by all accounts very well
preserved had been closed to the public
many years ago a military base had been
built around them and they had for a
long while been impossible to visit
under any circumstances ever
as we continued our journey South
through the bright colors of that
December day I was overtaken by a
compelling sense but the Nile Valley had
been the scene of momentous events for
Humanity long before the recorded
history of mankind began
all the most ancient records and
traditions of Egypt spoke of such events
and Associated them with the epoch
during which the gods had ruled on Earth
the fabled first time which was called
Zep tepi we shall delve into these
records in the next two chapters
chapter 43
looking for the first time
here is what the ancient Egyptians said
about the first time zept happy when the
gods ruled in their country they said it
was a golden age during which the Waters
of the Abyss receded the primordial
Darkness was banished and Humanity
emerging into the light was offered the
gifts of civilization
they spoke also of intermediaries
between Gods and Men the ushu a category
of lesser divinities whose title meant
the Watchers
and they preserved particularly Vivid
Recollections of the Gods themselves
poissant and beautiful beings called the
netaru who lived on Earth with humankind
and exercised their sovereignty from
heliopolis and other sanctuaries up and
down the Nile
some of these netaru were male and some
female but all possessed a range of
Supernatural Powers which included the
ability to appear at will as men or
women or as animals birds reptiles trees
or plants paradoxically their words
indeed seem to have reflected human
passions and preoccupations likewise
although they were portrayed as stronger
and more intelligent than humans it was
believed that they could grow sick or
even die or be killed under certain
circumstances
records of prehistory
archaeologists are adamant that the
epoch of the Gods which the ancient
Egyptians called the first time is
nothing more than a myth the ancient
Egyptians however who may have been
better informed about their past than we
are did not share this view the
historical records they kept in their
most venerable temples included
comprehensive lists of all the kings of
Egypt lists naming every pharaoh of
every Dynasty recognized by Scholars
today
some of these lists went even further
reaching back beyond the historical
Horizon of the first dynasty into the
Uncharted depths of a remote and
profound antiquity
Kings in this category have survived the
ravages of the ages and having been
exported from Egypt are now preserved in
European museums
we shall consider these lists in more
detail later in this chapter
they are known respectively as the
palermaster dating from the fifth
Dynasty around the 25th Century BC and
the Turin Papyrus a 19th Dynasty Temple
document inscribed in a cursive form of
hieroglyphs known as hieratic and dated
to the 13th century BC
in addition we have the testimony of a
heliopolitan priest named Manito
in the 3rd Century BC he compiled a
comprehensive and widely respected
history of Egypt which provided
extensive King lists for the entire
dynastic period
like the Turin Papyrus and the Palermo
Stone Benito's history also reached much
further back into the past to speak of a
distant Epoch when Gods had ruled in the
Nile Valley
manito's complete text has not come down
to us although copies of it seem to have
been in circulation as late as the 9th
Century A.D fortuitously however
fragments of it were preserved in the
writings of the Jewish chronicler
Josephus ad60 and of Christian writers
such as Africanus ad300 eusebius ad340
and George shinselis ad800
these fragments in the words of the late
professor Michael Hoffman of the
University of South Carolina provide the
framework for modern approaches to the
study of Egypt's path
this is quite true nevertheless
egyptologists are prepared to use
monitho only as a source for the
historical dynastic period and repudiate
the strange insights he provides into
prehistory when he speaks of the remote
golden age of the first time why should
we be so selective in our Reliance on
minito what is the logic of accepting 30
historical dynasties from him and
rejecting all that he has to say about
earlier epochs moreover since we know
that his chronology for the historical
period has been Vindicated by archeology
isn't it a bit premature for us to
assume that his pre-dynastic chronology
is wrong because excavations have not
yet turned up evidence confirming it
Gods demigods and spirits of the Dead
if we are to allow monitho to speak for
himself we have no choice but to turn to
the texts in which the fragments of his
work are preserved
one of the most important of these is
the Armenian version of the chronica of
eusebius it begins by informing us that
it is extracted from the Egyptian
history of Manito who composed his
account in three books these deal with
the gods the demigods the spirits of the
dead and the Mortal Kings who ruled
Egypt citing menetho directly eusebius
Begins by reeling off a list of the Gods
which consists essentially of The
Familiar aniad of heliopolis RA Osiris
Isis Horus set and so on
these were the first to hold sway in
Egypt thereafter the kingship passed
from one to another in unbroken
succession through 13 900 years
after the gods demigods reigned for
1255 years and again another line of
Kings held sway for
1817 years then came 30 more Kings
reigning for
1790 years and then again Ten Kings
ruling for 350 years there followed the
rule of the spirits of the Dead for
5813 years
the total of all these periods adds up
to 24
925 years and takes us far beyond the
biblical date for the creation of the
world sometime in the fifth millennium
BC because it's suggested that biblical
chronology was wrong this created
difficulties for eusebius a staunchly
Christian commentator but after a
moment's thought he overcame the problem
in an inspired way the year he said I
take to be a lunar one consisting that
is of 30 days what we now call a month
the Egyptians used formally to style a
year
of course they did no such thing
by means of this sleight of hand however
eusebius and others succeeded in boiling
down monitho's Grand pre-dynastic span
of almost 25
000 years into a sanitized dollar a bit
over 2 000 years which fits comfortably
into the
2242 years Orthodox biblical chronology
allows between Adam and the flood
a different technique for downplaying
the disturbing chronological
implications of monito's evidence is
employed by the monk George sinceellis
Circa ad800 this commentator who relies
entirely on invective writes Manito
Chief priest of the accursed temples of
Egypt tells us of gods who never existed
these he said reigned for 11
895 years
several other curious and contradictory
numbers crop up in the fragments in
particular Benito is repeatedly said to
have given the enormous figure of 36
525 years for the entire duration of the
civilization of Egypt from the time of
the Gods down to the end of the 30th and
last Dynasty of mortal Kings
this figure of course incorporates the
365.25 days of
the interval between two consecutive
hierarchical risings of Sirius as
described in the last chapter
more likely by Design than by accident
it also represents 25 cycles of
1460 sothic years and 25 cycles of
1461 calendar years since the ancient
Egyptian civil calendar was constructed
around a vague year of 365 days exactly
what if anything does all this mean it's
hard to be sure out of the world tour of
numbers and interpretations however
there is one aspect of monito's original
message that comes through loud and
clear irrespective of everything we have
been taught about the orderly progress
of History what he seems to be telling
us is that civilized beings either gods
or men were present in Egypt for an
immensely long period before the Advent
of the first dynasty around 3100 BC
diode is seculus and Herodotus
in this assertion monitho finds much
support among classical writers
in the 1st Century BC for example the
Greek historian diode is seculus visited
Egypt he is rightly described by CH old
father his most recent translator as an
uncritical compiler who used good
sources and reproduced them Faithfully
in plain English what this means is the
diodorus did not try to impose his
prejudices and preconceptions on the
material he collected he is therefore
particularly valuable to us because his
informants included Egyptian priests who
be questioned about the mysterious past
of their country
this is what they told him
first gods and heroes ruled Egypt for a
little less than 18 000 years the last
of the Gods to rule being Horus the son
of Isis Mortals have been Kings of their
country they say for a little less than
five thousand years
let us review these figures uncritically
and see what they add up to diodorus was
writing in the first century BC if we
journey back from there for five
thousand years during which the Mortal
Kings supposedly ruled we get to around
5100 BC
if we go even further back to the
beginning of the age of gods and heroes
we find that we have arrived at 23 100
BC when the world was still firmly in
the grip of the last ice age
long before diodorus Egypt was visited
by another and more illustrious Greek
historian the great Herodotus who lived
in the 5th Century BC he too it seems
consorted with priests and he too
managed to tune in to Traditions that
spoke of the presence of a high
civilization in the Nile Valley at some
unspecified date in remote Antiquity
Herodotus outlines these traditions of
an immense prehistoric period of
Egyptian civilization in book 2 of his
history in the same document he also
hands on to us without comment A
peculiar nugget of information which had
originated with the priests of
heliopolis
during this time they said there were
four occasions when the sun rose out of
his wanted place twice Rising where he
now sets and twice setting where he now
Rises
what is all this about
according to the French mathematicians
schwala de lubix what Herodotus is
transmitting to us perhaps unwittingly
is a veiled and garbled reference to a
period of time that is to the time that
it takes for sunrise on the vernal
equinox to precess against the Stellar
background through one and a half
complete cycles of the zodiac
as we've seen the equinoxual sun spends
roughly
2160 years in each of the 12 zodiacal
constellations
a full cycle of procession of the
equinoxes therefore takes almost 26 000
years to complete 12 times
2160 years it follows that one and a
half Cycles takes nearly 39 000 years 18
times
2160 years
in the time of Herodotus the sun on the
vernal equinox Rose due east at dawn
against the Stellar background of Aries
at which moment the constellation of
Libra was in opposition lying Due West
where the sun would set 12 hours later
if we wind the clock of procession back
half a cycle however six houses of the
zodiac or approximately thirteen
thousand years we find that the reverse
configuration prevails the Vernal Sun
now Rises due east in Libra while Aries
lies Due West in opposition a further 13
000 years back the situation reverses
itself once more with the Vernal sun
rising again in Aries and with Libra in
opposition this takes us to 26 000 years
before Herodotus if we then step back
another thirteen Thousand Years another
half precessional cycle to 39 000 years
before Herodotus the Vernal Sunrise
returns to Libra and ares is again in
opposition
the point is this with 39 000 years we
have an expanse of time during which the
sun can be described as twice Rising
where he now sets that is in Libra in
the time Herodotus and again at thirteen
thousand and thirty nine thousand years
earlier and as twice setting where he
now Rises that is in Aries in the time
of Herodotus and again at thirteen
thousand and thirty nine thousand years
earlier if schwala's interpretation is
correct and there is every reason to
suppose it is it suggests that the Greek
historians Priestly informants must have
had access to accurate records of the
precessional motion of the Sun going
back at least 39
000 years before their own era
maturing Papyrus and the Palermo Stone
the figure of 39 000 years Accords
surprisingly closely with the testimony
of the Turin Papyrus one of the two
surviving ancient Egyptian king lists
that extends back into prehistoric times
before the first dynasty
originally in the collection of the king
of Sardinia the brittle and crumbling
three thousand-year-old Papyrus was sent
in a box without packing to its present
home in the museum of Turin as any
school Channel could have predicted it
arrived broken into countless fragments
Scholars were obliged to work for years
to piece together and make sense of what
remained and they did a superb job
nevertheless more than half the contents
of this precious record proved
impossible to reconstruct
what might we have learned about the
first time if the Turin Papyrus had
remained intact
the surviving fragments are tantalizing
in one register for example we read the
names of ten nitaru with each name
inscribed in a Cartouche that's an
oblong enclosure in much the same style
adopted in later periods for the
historical kings of Egypt
the number of years that each Netter was
believed to have reigned was also given
but most of these numbers are missing
from the damage document
in another column there appears a list
of the Mortal Kings who ruled in Upper
and Lower Egypt after the gods but prior
to the supposed unification of the
Kingdom Under Menace the first pharaoh
of the first dynasty in 3100 BC from the
surviving fragments it is possible to
establish that nine dynasties of these
pre-dynastic Pharaohs were mentioned
among them were the venerables of
Memphis the venerables of the north and
lastly the shemsuhor the companions or
followers of Horus who ruled until the
time of Menace
the final two lines of the column which
seem to represent a summing up or
inventory are particularly provocative
they read venerables Shem suhor thirteen
thousand four hundred and twenty years
Reigns before the shemsu [ __ ] 23 200
years total 36
620 years
the other king list that deals with
prehistoric times is the Palermo's Stone
which does not take us as far back into
the past as the Turin papyrus
the earliest of its surviving registers
record the Reigns of 120 Kings who ruled
in Upper and Lower Egypt in the late
pre-dynastic period
centuries immediately prior to the
country's unification in 3100 BC
once again however we really have no
idea how much other information perhaps
relating to far earlier periods might
originally have been inscribed on this
enigmatic slab of black Basalt because
it too has not come down to us intact
since 1887 the largest single part has
been preserved in the museum of Palermo
in Sicily a second piece is on display
in Egypt in the Cairo Museum and a third
much smaller fragment is in the Petri
collection at the University of London
these are reckoned by archaeologists to
have been broken out of the center of a
monolith which would originally have
measured about seven feet long by two
feet high stood on its long side
furthermore as one Authority has
observed it is quite possible even
probable that many more pieces of this
invaluable Monument remain if we only
knew where to look as it is we are faced
with the tantalizing knowledge that a
record of the name of every King of the
Archaic Period existed together with the
number of years of his Reign and the
chief events which occurred during his
occupation of the throne
at these events were compiled in the
fifth Dynasty only about 700 years after
the unification so that the margin of
error would in all probability have been
very small
the late professor Walter Emery whose
words these are was naturally concerned
about the absence of much needed details
concerning the Archaic Period
3200 BC to 2900 BC the focus of his own
specialist interests
we should also spare a thought however
for what an intact Palermo Stone might
have told us about even earlier epochs
notably zeptepi the Golden Age of the
Gods the deeper we penetrate into the
myths and memories of Egypt's long past
and the closer we approach to the fabled
first time the stranger the Landscapes
that surround us become as we shall see
chapter 44 gods of the first time
according to heliopolitan theology the
nine original Gods who appeared in Egypt
in the first time were
definite Geb nut Osiris Isis nephthus
and set
The Offspring of these deities included
well-known figures such as Horus and
Anubis
in addition other companies of gods were
recognized notably at Memphis and
hermopolis where they were important and
very ancient Cults dedicated to petar
and to South
these first-time deities were all in one
sense or another gods of creation who
had given shape to chaos through their
Divine will
out of that chaos they formed and
populated the sacred land of Egypt
wherein for many thousands of years they
ruled among men as Divine pharaohs what
was chaos
the heliopolitan priests who spoke to
the Greek historian diodorous syculus in
the 1st Century BC put forward the
thought-provoking suggestion that chaos
was a flood identified by deodorous with
the Earth destroying flood of juqualion
the Greek Noah figure
in general they say that if in the flood
which occurred in the time of ducalion
most living things were destroyed it is
probable that the inhabitants of
Southern Egypt survived rather than any
others or if as some maintain the
destruction of living things was
complete and the Earth then brought
forth again new forms of animals
nevertheless even on such a supposition
the first Genesis of living things
fittingly attaches to this country
why should Egypt have been so blessed
diodorus was told that it had something
to do with its geographical situation
with the great exposure of its Southern
regions to the heat of the Sun and with
the vastly increased rainfall which the
myths said the world had experienced in
the aftermath of the universal deluge
for when the moisture from the Abundant
rains which fell among other peoples was
mingled with the intense heat which
prevails in Egypt itself the air became
very well tempered for the first
generation of all living things
curiously enough Egypt does enjoy a
special geographical situation
as is well known the latitude and
longitude lines which intersect just
beside the Great Pyramid 30 degrees
north and 31 East cross more dry land
than any others curiously two at the end
of the last ice age when millions of
square miles of glaciation were melting
in northern Europe when rising sea
levels were flooding coastal areas all
around the globe and when the huge
volume of extra moisture released into
the atmosphere through the evaporation
of the ice Fields was being dumped as
rain
Egypt benefited for several thousands of
years from an exceptionally humid and
fertile climate it is not difficult to
see how such a climate might indeed have
been remembered as well-tempered for the
first generation of all living things
the question therefore has to be asked
whose information about the past are we
receiving from diodorous and is the
Apparently accurate description of
Egypt's Lush climate at the end of the
last ice age a coincidence or is an
extremely ancient tradition being
transmitted to us here A Memory perhaps
of the first time
breath of the Divine serpent
Ra was believed to have been the first
king of the first time an ancient myths
say that as long as he remained young
and vigorous he reigned peacefully
peaceful the passing years took their
toll on him however and he is depicted
at the end of his rule as an old
wrinkled stumbling man with a trembling
mouth from which saliva ceaselessly
dribbles Shu followed ra as King on
Earth but his Reign was troubled by
plots and conflicts although he
vanquished his enemies he was in the end
so ravaged by disease that even his most
faithful followers revolted against him
weary of reigning Shu abdicated in favor
of his son Geb and took refuge in the
skies after a terrifying Tempest which
lasted nine days
Geb the third Divine Pharaoh Julie
succeeded shoe to the throne his Reign
was also troubled and some of the myths
describing what took place reflect the
odd idiom of the pyramid texts in which
a non-technical vocabulary seems to
wrestle with complex Technical and
scientific imagery for example one
particularly striking tradition speaks
of a golden box in which ra had
deposited a number of objects described
respectively as his Rod or or cane a
lock of his hair and his ureas a rearing
cobra with its Hood extended fashioned
out of gold which was worn on the Royal
headdress
a powerful and dangerous Talisman this
box together with its bizarre contents
remained enclosed in a fortress on the
Eastern Frontier of Egypt until a great
many years after Ras are sent to heaven
when Geb came to power he ordered that
it should be brought to him and unsealed
in his presence in the instant that the
box was opened a bolt of fire the
described as the breath of the Divine
serpent ushered from it struck Dead all
gebb's Companions and Gravely burned the
god king himself
it is tempting to wonder whether what we
are confronted by here might not be a
garbled account of a malfunctioning
man-made device a confused or stricken
recollection of a monstrous instrument
devised by the scientists of A Lost
Civilization
weight is added to such extreme
speculations when we remember that this
is by no means the only golden box in
the ancient world that functioned like a
deadly and unpredictable machine it has
a number of quite unmissable
similarities to the Hebrews enigmatic
Arc of the Covenant which also struck
innocent people dead with bolts of fiery
energy which also was overlaid
roundabout with gold and which was said
to have contained not only the two
tablets of the Ten Commandments but the
golden pot that had mana and aeron's Rod
a proper look at the implications of all
these weird and wonderful boxes and of
other technological artifacts referred
to in ancient Traditions is beyond the
scope of this book
for our purposes here it's sufficient to
note that A peculiar atmosphere of
dangerous and quasi-technological
Wizardry seems to surround many of the
Gods of the heliopolitania
Isis for example wife and sister of
Osiris and mother of Horus carries a
strong whiff of the science lab
according to the Chester Beatty papyrus
in the British museum she was a clever
woman more intelligent than countless
Gods she was ignorant of nothing in
heaven and earth
renowned for her skillful use of
Witchcraft and Magic Isis was
particularly remembered by the ancient
Egyptians as strong of tongue that is
being in command of Words of Power which
she knew with correct pronunciation and
halted not in her speech and was perfect
both in giving the command and in saying
the word in short she was believed by
means of her voice alone to be capable
of bending reality and overriding the
laws of physics
these same Powers though perhaps in
Greater degree were attributed to the
wisdom God Thoth who although not a
member of the heliopolitaniad is
recognized in the Turin Papyrus and
other ancient records as the sixth or
sometimes as the seventh Divine pharaoh
of Egypt
frequently represented on Temple and two
walls as an Ibis or an Ibis headed man
those was venerated as the regulative
force responsible for all Heavenly
calculations and annotations as the Lord
and multiplier of time the inventor of
the alphabet and the patron of magic
he was particularly associated with
astronomy mathematics surveying and
geometry and was described as he who
reckons in heaven the counter of the
stars and the measurer of the Earth
he was also regarded as a deity who
understood the mysteries of all that is
hidden under the Heavenly Vault and who
had the ability to bestow wisdom on
selected individuals it was said that he
had inscribed his knowledge in secret
books and hidden these about the Earth
intending that they should be sought for
by Future Generations but found only by
the worthy who were to use their
discoveries for the benefit of mankind
what stands out most clearly about
thouth therefore in addition to his
credentials as an ancient scientist is
his role as a benefactor and civilizer
in this respect he closely resembles his
predecessor Osiris the high god of the
pyramid texts and the fourth Divine
pharaoh of Egypt whose name becometh sa
Orion whose leg is long and his stride
extended the president of the land of
the South
Osiris and the Lords of Eternity
occasionally referred to in the texts as
a neptem or Universal Master Osiris is
depicted as human but also superhuman
suffering but at the same time
commanding moreover he expresses his
essential dualism by ruling in heaven as
the constellation of Orion and on Earth
as a king among men
like the racoche in the Andes and
Quetzalcoatl in Central America his ways
are subtle and mysterious like them he
is exceptionally tall and always
depicted wearing the curved beard of
divinity and like them too although he
has Supernatural Powers at his disposal
he avoids the use of force whenever
possible
we heard in chapter 16 that Quetzalcoatl
the god king of the Mexicans was
believed to have departed from Central
America by sea sailing away on a raft of
serpents it is therefore hard to avoid a
sense of deja vu when we read in the
Egyptian Book of the Dead that the Abode
of Osiris also rested on water and had
walls made of living serpents at the
very least the convergence of symbolism
linking these two gods and two far-flung
regions is striking
there are other obvious parallels as
well the central details of the story of
Osiris have been recounted in earlier
chapters and we need not go over them
again
the reader will not have forgotten that
this God once again like Quetzalcoatl
and Vera kocha was remembered
principally as a benefactor of mankind
as a bringer of Enlightenment and as a
great civilizing leader he was credited
for example with having abolished
cannibalism and was said to have
introduced the Egyptians to agriculture
in particular to the cultivation of
Wheat and barley and to have taught them
the art of fashioning agricultural
implements since he had a special liking
for fine wine the myths do not say where
he acquired this taste he made a point
of teaching mankind the culture of the
vine as well as the way to harvest the
grave and to and to store the wine
in addition to the gifts of good living
he brought to his subjects Osiris helped
to wean them from their miserable and
barbarous manners by providing them with
a code of laws and inaugurating the cult
of the Gods in Egypt
what he had said everything in order he
handed over the control of the Kingdom
to Isis quit Egypt for many years and
roamed about the world with the sole
intention diodara seculus was told of
visiting all the inhabited Earth and
teaching the race of man how to
cultivate the vine and sow wheat and
barley for he supposed that if he made
man give up their savagery and adopt a
gentle manner of life he would receive
Immortal honors because of the magnitude
of his benefactions
Osiris traveled first to Ethiopia where
he taught tillage and husbandry to the
Primitive hunter-gatherers he
encountered he also undertook a number
of large-scale engineering and
hydraulics Works he built canals with
floodgates and Regulators he raised the
Riverbanks and took precautions to
prevent the Nile from overflowing later
he made his way to Arabia and then to
India where he established many cities
moving on to Thrace he killed a
barbarian king for refusing to adopt his
system of government this was out of
character in general Osiris was
remembered by the Egyptians for having
forced no man to carry out his
instructions but by means of gentle
persuasion and an appeal to their reason
he succeeded in inducing them to
practice what he preached many of his
wise counsels were imparted to his
listeners in hymns and songs which were
sung to the accompaniment of instruments
of music
once again the parallels with
quetzalcoethyl and Vera kocha are hard
to avoid
during a time of darkness and Chaos
quite possibly linked to a flood a
bearded God or man materializes in Egypt
or Bolivia or Mexico he is equipped with
a wealth of practical and scientific
skills of the kind associated with
mature and highly developed
civilizations which he uses unselfishly
for the benefit of humanity
he is instinctively gentle but capable
of great firmness when necessary he is
motivated by a strong sense of purpose
and after establishing his headquarters
at heliopolis or tiwanaco or teotiwakan
he sets forth with a select band of
companions to impose order and to
reinstate the Lost balance of the world
leaving aside for the present the issue
of whether we are dealing here with gods
or men with figments of the Primitive
imagination or with flesh and blood
beings the fact remains that the myths
always speak of a company of civilizers
viracocha has his companions as have
both Quetzalcoatl and Osiris
sometimes there are Fierce internal
conflicts Within These groups and
perhaps struggles for power the battles
between Seth and Horus and between tez
katil poker and Quetzalcoatl are obvious
examples moreover whether the mythical
events unfold in Central America or in
the Andes or in Egypt the upshot is also
always pretty much the same the
civilizer is eventually plotted against
and either driven out or killed
the myths say that Quetzalcoatl and Vera
kocha never came back although as we've
seen their return to the Americas was
expected at the time of the Spanish
Conquest
Osiris on the other hand did come back
although he was murdered by Seth soon
after the completion of his worldwide
mission to make men give up their
savagery he won eternal life through his
resurrection in the constellation of
Orion as the all-powerful god of the
Dead thereafter judging souls and
providing an immortal example of
responsible and benevolent kingship he
dominated the religion and the culture
of ancient Egypt for the entire span of
its known history
Serene stability
who can guess what the civilizations of
the Andes and of Mexico might have
achieved If They too had benefited from
such powerful symbolic continuity
in this respect however Egypt is unique
indeed although the pyramid texts and
other archaic sources recognize a period
of disruption and attempted usurpation
by set and his 72 precessional
conspirators they also depict the
transition to the Reigns of Horus Thoth
and the later Divine pharaohs as being
relatively smooth and inevitable
this transition was mimicked through
thousands of years by the Mortal kings
of Egypt from the beginning to the end
they saw themselves as the lineal
descendants and living representatives
of Horus son of Osiris as Generations
succeeded generation it was supposed
that each deceased Pharaoh was reborn in
the sky as an Osiris and that each
successor to the throne became a Horus
this simple refined and stable scheme
was already fully evolved and in place
at the beginning of the first dynasty
around
3100 BC
Scholars accept this the majority also
accept that what we are dealing with
here is a highly developed and
sophisticated religion
strangely very few egyptologists or
archaeologists have questioned where and
when this religion took shape
is it not to defy logic to suppose that
well-rounded social and metaphysical
ideas like those of the Osiris cult
sprung up fully formed in 3100 BC or
that they could have taken such perfect
shape in the 300 years which
egyptologists sometimes grudgingly allow
for them to have done so
there must have been a far longer period
of development than that spread over
several thousands rather than several
hundreds of years moreover as we've seen
every surviving record in which the
ancient Egyptians speak directly about
their past asserts that their
civilization was a legacy of the Gods
who were the first to hold sway in Egypt
the records are not internally
consistent some attribute much greater
Antiquity to the civilization of Egypt
than others all however clearly and
firmly direct our attention to an Epoch
far far in the past anything from 8 000
to almost 40 000 years before the
foundation of the first dynasty
archaeologists insist that no material
artifacts have ever been found in Egypt
to suggest that an evolved civilization
existed at such early dates but this is
not strictly true
as we saw in part 6 a handful of objects
and structures exist which have not yet
been conclusively dated by any
scientific means the ancient city of
abidos conceals one of the most
extraordinary of these Undateable
enigmas